machine learning is one of the top
technologies of the 21st century
it has brought in a revolution in the
business sectors hello everyone welcome
to this full course video on machine
learning this video will help you
understand all the concepts and give you
ample hands-on experience building
machine learning models
we have our experience instructors who
will take you through this course
first
you will learn the basics of machine
learning and jump into understanding the
various machine learning algorithms you
will learn about linear regression
logistic regression decision trees
support vector machines and many more
then you will look at reinforcement
learning and understand mathematics for
machine learning you will learn the
concepts such as principal component
analysis regularization and feature
selection
finally you will perform your selection
prediction analysis and understand the
machine learning roadmap for 2021 so
let's begin with a short animated video
on machine learning we know humans learn
from their past experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from the past data and
do what humans can do act much faster
well that's called machine learning but
it's a lot more than just learning it's
also about understanding and reasoning
so today we will learn about the basics
of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity and the gender of voice for
simplicity let's just use tempo and
intensity for now so here tempo is on
the x-axis ranging from relaxed to fast
whereas intensity is on the y-axis
ranging from light to soaring we see
that paul likes the song with fast tempo
and soaring intensity while he dislikes
the song with relaxed tempo and light
intensity so now we know paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a song a has fast
tempo and a soaring intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song or not correct so paul likes this
song by looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily right let's say now
paul listens to a new song let's label
it as song b so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether ball likes it or not
not able to guess whether this ball will
like it or dislike it are the choices
unclear correct we could easily classify
song a but when the choice became
complicated as in the case of song b yes
and that's where machine learning comes
in let's see how in the same example for
song b if we draw a circle around the
song b we see that there are four votes
for like whereas one would for dislike
if we go for the majority votes we can
say that paul will definitely like the
song that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called k
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
their label when you feed this data to
the machine learning model it learns
which feature is associated with which
label for example it will learn that if
a coin is of 3 grams it will be a 1
rupee coin let's give a new coin to the
machine on the basis of the weight of
the new coin your model will predict the
currency hence supervised learning uses
labeled data to train the model here the
machine knew the features of the object
and also the labels associated with
those features on this note let's move
to unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you will clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored high
runs and took less wickets while the
other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
a reward based learning or we can say
that it works on the principle of
feedback here let's say you provide the
system with an image of a dog and ask it
to identify it the system identifies it
as a cat so you give a negative feedback
to the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario one facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario 2 netflix recommends new movies
based on someone's past movie choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody's
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing often where it
says the fear of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model which is used by global
taxi giant uber and others where they
have differential pricing in real time
based on demand the number of cars
available bad weather rush r etc so they
use the surge pricing model to ensure
that those who need a cab can get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict where the demand will be high
with the goal that drivers can take care
of the demand and search pricing can be
minimized great hey siri can you remind
me to book a cab at 6 00 pm today okay
i'll remind you thanks no problem
comment below some interesting everyday
examples around you where machines are
learning and doing amazing jobs so
that's all for machine learning basics
today from my site what is machine
learning hello my name is richard
kirschner i'm with the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead today we're
covering what is machine learning what's
in it for you we're going to cover the
basics of machine learning what is
machine learning artificial intelligence
versus machine learning versus deep
learning how does machine learning work
types of machine learning machine
learning pre-requisites applications of
machine learning
here we have our it looks a little bit
like frankenstein our frankenstein
looking robot today let me tell you what
is machine learning machine learning
works on the development of computer
programs that can access data and use it
to automatically learn and improve from
experience
watch a robot builder construct a house
in two days this was back in july 29
2016 so that's pretty impressive this
amount of time to continue to grow in
his development and it's smart enough to
leave spaces in the brickwork for wiring
and plumbing and can even cut and shape
bricks to size
amazon echo relies on machine learning
and with more data it becomes more
accurate play your favorite music order
pizza from domino's voice control your
home request rides from uber have you
ever wondered the difference between ai
machine learning and deep learning
artificial intelligence a technique
which enables machines to mimic human
behavior this is really important
because this is how we are able to gauge
how well our computations or what we're
working on works is the fact that we're
mimicking human behavior we're using
this to replace human work and make it
more efficient and make it more
streamlined and more accurate and so the
center of artificial intelligence is the
big picture of all this put together ibm
deep blue chess electronic game
characters those are just a couple
examples of artificial intelligence
machine learning a technique which uses
statistical methods enabling machines to
learn from their past data so this means
if you have your input from last time
and you have your answer you use that to
help prove the next guess it makes for
the correct answer ibm watson google
search algorithm email spam filters
these are all part of machine learning
and then deep learning which is a subset
of machine learning composing algorithms
that allow a model to train itself and
perform tasks
alphago natural speech recognition these
are a couple examples deep learning is
associated with tools like neural
networks where it's kind of a black box
as it learns it changes all these things
that are as a human we would have a very
hard time tracking and it's able to come
up with an answer from that now let's
see how machine learning works
first we start with training the data
once we've trained the data the train we
go into the machine learning algorithm
which then puts the data into a
processing which then goes down to
machine another machine learning
algorithm and then we take new data
because you have to test whatever you
did to make sure it works correctly and
we put that into the same algorithm once
we do that we check our prediction we
check our results and from the
prediction if we've set aside some
training date and we find out it didn't
do a good job predicting it and it gets
a thumbs down as you see then we go back
to the beginning and we retrain the
algorithm and a lot of times it's not
just about getting the wrong answer it's
about continually trying to get a better
answer so you'll see the first time you
might be like oh this is not the answer
i want depending on what domain you're
working in whether it's medical
economical business stocks whatever you
try out your model and if it's not
giving you a good answer you retrain it
if you think you can get a better answer
you retrain it and you keep doing that
until you get the best answer you can
let's see the types of machine learning
supervised learning unsupervised
learning there's a number of ways to
divide up machine learning and how it
works these are two main categories you
can divide it into supervised learning
we have a known amount of data so in
this case we have a bunch of apples we
have a machine learning algorithm
it goes through the process it goes
through and trains a model based on that
known data and then once you've trained
your model on the known stuff you can
then put an unknown data in there and
you get a new response and of course in
this particular one it's an apple so
it's trying to figure out whether it's
an apple or another fruit there are many
different algorithms you can use for
computing this information for doing
this supervised training just to list
the some of the top ones that are
currently being used and by no means not
there's more than just this so by no
means this isn't the complete list
there's polynomial regression there's a
random forest there's linear regression
there's logistic regression there's
decision trees there's k-nearest
neighbors and there's naive bayes like i
said this is just a short list of some
of the many tools that are out there
nowadays and if you have supervised
learning then we should also look at
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning so we have unknown data in this
case you can see we have a bunch of
fruit and we might not have labeled it
we don't know we've never had anybody
look at it and say this is what this is
and we take that data and we put it
through the machine learning algorithm
and then that goes through the
processing and then the trained model
and with the trained model says hey can
i see a pattern here and from that
pattern it divides it up into a response
in this case apples and pears you can
see some of these things look just like
the other and it tries to put them all
together so that you get similar things
in similar groups and again we have a
nice list of algorithms here and this is
not the only algorithms used for this so
don't limit yourself to this just these
these are just some of the primary ones
used today and of course we have the
k-means clustering singular value
decomposition fuzzy means partial least
squares a priori hierarchical clustering
principle component analysis
machine learning pre-requisites computer
science fundamentals and programming so
any of the machine learning out today
you have to know some basic scripting or
programming intermediate statistical
knowledge you have to understand a
little bit about probabilities if a is
current how likely is b going to happen
if there's clouds overhead how likely is
it going to rain
linear algebra and intermediate calculus
the linear algebra is very important
because you have to understand basically
drawing a line through the data points
and what that means that's the most
fundamental linear regression models you
draw a line through all your data and
you use that line to compute new values
intermediate calculus means you need to
have a little bit of understanding of
what a differential equation is you
really don't need to be an expert
because the computer does all the heavy
lifting for you but it's important to
know the terms when they come up unless
you're doing some advanced programming
on the actual models themselves and data
wrangling and cleaning i would say this
might be the biggest one in here is you
have to start getting a grip on how to
clean up your data there's a saying is
bad data in bad data out good data in
you're more likely to have good data out
some applications of machine learning
instance segmentation object detection
instant segmentation you can see here
where they use machine learning to go in
there and find where the different cats
are and the different objects are in the
picture and then in segmentation it
actually cuts them out kind of a fun one
especially if you have a google pixel
phone and you can do little animation
objects on top of your ongoing pictures
you're taking or movies
number plate detection you can see here
where we have a card it comes in there
and it finds a number plate on the car
once it's done that it can then do
automatic translation automatic
translation is we pick up some symbols
in this case on a machine and it does
machine translation so that you can know
what it's saying even if you don't speak
that language let's look at another
example machine learning based on the
amount of rainfall how much would be the
crop yield so here we have our crops we
have our rainfall and we want to know
how much we're going to get from our
crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary
height where categorical would be
a description the color a dog's breed
gender categorical is limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why we multiple linear
regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance i'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory
understanding linear regression linear
regression is the statistical model used
to predict the relationship between
independent and dependent variables by
examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2
y being the dependent variable remember
that from before and x being the
independent variable so y depends on
whatever x is m in this case is the
slope of the line where m equals the
difference in the y 2 minus y 1 and x2
minus x1 and finally we have c which is
the coefficient of the line or where it
happens to cross the zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
whis and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the x y points and
create all the information you need so
in the top half you can see where we've
broken that down into pieces and as it
goes through the first two points it
computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y and x times y and
then it takes all of x and adds them up
all of y adds them up all of x squared
adds them up and so on and so on and you
can see we have the sum of equal to 15
the sum is equal to 20 all the way up to
x times y where the sum equals 66. this
all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope times x plus the
coefficient c so we go down below and
we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x times the sum of y and
those have both been computed so you
have 15 times 20. and on the bottom we
have the number of lines times the sum
of x squared easily computed as 86 for
the sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values and we're going to go ahead and
plot them we're going to predict them so
y equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see why what we actual
values were and you can see why i
predict it you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic multiple linear
regression let's take a brief look at
what happens when you have multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have well we'll start with the simple
linear regression where we had y equals
m plus x plus c and we're trying to find
the value of y now with multiple linear
regression we have multiple variables
coming in so instead of having just x we
have x1 x2 x3 and instead of having just
one slope each variable has its own
slope attached to it as you can see here
we have m1 m2 m3 and we still just have
the single coefficient so when you're
dealing with multiple linear regression
you basically take your single linear
regression and you spread it out so you
have y equals m1 times x1 plus m2 times
x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it it's such
a visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber scion map plot library
inline that is only because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook requires i put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting so we're just setting up
variables in fact it's not going to do
anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies dot csv you're
going to have to change this to fit
whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that i have companies equals
pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies.csv and then below
there we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the i location and
because this is companies as a pd data
set i can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is or we have a colon minus
one and we want the values set into
there so x is no longer a data set a
pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the panda sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what panda is one
of the things pandas is really good
about is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carrier's
return i don't know about you but i go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165
349.20 cents compared to the
administration cost of 136
897.80 so on so on helps to create the
profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization and again
we're using sns which is pandas as you
can see we imported the map plot library
dot pi plot as plt which then the
seaborn uses and we imported the seaborn
as sns and then that final line of code
helps us show this in our inline coding
without this it wouldn't display and you
could display it to a file and other
means and that's the matplot library in
line with the amber sign at the
beginning so here we come down to the
single line of code
seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame so i can
just take the companies dot core for
coordinates and i can put that right
into the seaborn and when we run this we
get this beautiful plot and let's just
take a look at what this plot means if
you look at this plot on mine the colors
are probably a little bit more purplish
and blue than the original one uh we
have the columns and the rows we have r
and d spending we have administration we
have marketing spending and profit and
if you cross index any two of these
since we're interested in profit if you
cross index profit with profit it's
going to show up if you look at the
scale on the right way up in the dark
why because those are the same data they
have an exact correspondence so r d
spending is going to be the same as r d
spending and the same thing with
administration costs right down the
middle you get this dark row or dark um
diagonal row that shows that this is the
highest corresponding data that's
exactly the same and as it becomes
lighter there's less connections between
the data so we can see with profit
obviously profit is the same as profit
and next it has a very high correlation
with r d spending which we looked at
earlier and it has a slightly less
connection to marketing spending and
even less to how much money we put into
the administration so now that we have a
nice look at the data let's go ahead and
dig in and create some actual useful
linear regression models so that we can
predict values and have a better profit
now that we've taken a look at the
visualization of this data we're going
to move on to the next step instead of
just having a pretty picture we need to
generate some hard data some hard values
so let's see what that looks like we're
going to set up our linear regression
model in two steps the first one is we
need to prepare some of our data so it
fits correctly and let's go ahead and
paste this code into our jupiter
notebook and what we're bringing in is
we're going to bring in the sklearn
pre-processing where we're going to
import the label encoder and the one hot
encoder to use the label encoder we're
going to create a variable called label
encoder and set it equal to capital l
label capital e encoder this creates a
class that we can reuse for transferring
the labels back and forth now about now
you should ask what labels are we
talking about let's go take a look at
the data we processed before and see
what i'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is r and d
spending column one which is
administration column two which is
marketing spending and column three is
state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or a one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
as just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look what this
data is doing you'll see you have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if i go ahead and
just do row 0 you'll see i have a nice
organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computer
has automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transferred all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set and we have
a testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models you usually see that a
capital x and you see the train and the
test and the lower case y what this is
is x is our data going in that's our r d
span our administration our marketing
and then why which we're training is the
answer that's the profit because we want
to know the profit of an unknown entity
that's what we're going to shoot for in
this tutorial the next part train test
split we take x and we take y we've
already created those x has the columns
with the data in it and y has a column
with profit in it and then we're going
to set the test size equals 0.2 that
basically means twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're going to put them off
to the side so since we're using a
thousand lines of data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later and
then the random state equals zero we're
going to randomize which ones it picks
to hold off to the side we'll go ahead
and run this it's not overly exciting
cause it's setting up our variables but
the next step is the next step we
actually create our linear regression
model now that we got to the linear
regression model we get that next piece
of the puzzle let's go ahead and put
that code in there and walk through it
so here we go we're going to paste it in
there and let's go ahead and since this
is a shorter line of code let's zoom up
there so we can get a good look and we
have from the sklearn dot linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now i don't know if
you recall from earlier when we were
doing all the math let's go ahead and
flip back there and take a look at that
do you remember this where we had this
long formula on the bottom and we were
doing all this summarization and then we
also looked at setting it up with the
different lines and then we also looked
all the way down to multiple linear
regression where we're adding all those
formulas together all of that is wrapped
up in this one section so what's going
on here is i'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor dot fit in this case we do
x train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict x test going in and this gives
us y predict now because i'm in jupiter
inline i can just put the variable up
there and when i hit the run button
it'll print that array out i could have
just as easily done print y predict so
if you're in a different ide that's not
an inline setup like the jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side it's going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals m1 times x1 plus m2
times x2 and so on and so on plus c the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope 1 times
column 1 variable plus slope 2 times
column 2 variable all the way to the m
to the n and x to the n plus c the
coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89 to the power of 2 etc etc
times the first column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus 1 0 3 0 0 9 point
boy it gets kind of complicated when you
look at it this is why we don't do this
by hand anymore this is why we have the
computer to make these calculations easy
to understand and calculate now i told
you that was a short detour and we're
coming towards the end of our script as
you remember from the beginning i said
if we're going to divide this
information we have to make sure it's a
valid model that this model works and
understand how good it works so
calculating the r squared value that's
what we're going to use to predict how
good our prediction is and let's take a
look what that looks like in code and so
we're going to use this from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us that we know are true the y
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the r2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 correct but you do
want that in the upper 90s oh and higher
shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 9 2 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression what is logistic
regression as i mentioned earlier
logistic regression is an algorithm for
performing binary classification so
let's take an example and see how this
works let's say your car has not been
serviced for quite a few years and now
you want to find out if it is going to
break down in the near future so this is
like a classification problem find out
whether your car will break down or not
so how are we going to perform this
classification so here's how it looks if
we plot the information along the x and
y axis x is the number of years since
the last service was performed and why
is the probability of your car breaking
down and let's say this information was
this data rather was collected from
several car users it's not just your car
but several car users so that is our
labeled data so the data has been
collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3 and so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was 6 or 7
years there is almost a certainty that
your car is going to break down that is
what this graph shows so this is an
example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variables outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly how
exactly we are going to
determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be set saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say
an output of 0.29 is considered as zero
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say the hr team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
us it is trained and it learns from this
labeled information so that when a new
employees information is fed based on
the rating it will determine what should
be the high so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get five
thousand five thousand five hundred
five thousand six hundred it is not
discrete like a cat or a dog or an apple
or a banana these are discrete or a yes
or no these are discrete values right so
this way you are trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on the scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
that is a discrete problem right a yes
or no kind of a problem in this case we
actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the label data so based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors thus
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at zero and one but still the
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is 1 minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to 0 and when the probability
becomes 1 then the value of the odds is
1 by 0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between 0 and
1. now this is how an equation of a
straight line looks so y is equal to
beta0 plus beta1 x where beta0 is the
y-intercept and beta1 is the slope of
the line if we take the odds equation
and take a log of both sides then this
would look somewhat like this and the
term logistic is actually derived from
the fact that we are doing this we take
a log of dx by 1 minus px this is an
extension of the calculation of odds
that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta0 plus beta1 x which is the
equation of the straight line and now
from here if you want to find out the
value of p x we will see we can take the
exponential on both sides and then if we
solve that equation we will get the
equation of p x like this p x is equal
to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of minus
beta 0 plus beta 1 x and recall this is
nothing but the equation of the line
which is equal to y y is equal to beta 0
plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if you want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not is
going to be sunny or not there is going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so how do we do this so the first
thing is obviously in any machine
learning process you train your model so
in this case we are using logistic
regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
uh
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's uh take
a look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images are
a sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we got we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonals should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagonals the cells other
than the diagonal should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a 2 here there are there's a
1 here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the number that has been fed
is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and the actual value are the same
so along the diagonals that is true
which means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if the maximum number is
here that means that like here in this
case it is 34 which means that 34 of the
images that have been fed or rather
actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two misclassification
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
100 accuracy everything will be only in
the diagonal there will be no numbers
other than 0 in all other cells so that
is like 100 percent accurate model okay
so that's uh just of how to use this
matrix how to use this uh confusion
matrix i know the name
is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix but actually it is not very
confusing it's very straightforward so
you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and the
predicted value and the actual value is
is exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are i think 37 plus
five yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of digit 3 and
the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in
in jupiter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code
then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
1797 by 64. these are like 8x8 images so
that's that's what is reflected in this
shape now from here onwards we are
basically once again importing some of
the libraries that are required like
numpy and matplot and we will take a
look at uh some of the sample images
that we have uh loaded so this one for
example creates a figure and then we go
ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at zero one two three four so this is
how the image is this is how the data is
okay and uh based on this we will
actually train our logistic regression
model and then we will test it and see
how well it is able to recognize so the
way it works is the pixel information so
as you can see here this is an 8 by 8
pixel kind of a
image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn
for which a number what is the pattern
of the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and test so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times and then we test it with the test
data set and the split is usually in the
form of there and there are various ways
in which you can split this data it is
up to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20 0.23 that means 23 percent of that
entire data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is uh called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train these are these are the
features right which is like the
independent variable and why underscore
train is the label right so in this case
what happens is we have the input value
which is or the features value which is
in x underscore train and since this is
the labeled data for each of them each
of the observations we already have the
label information saying whether this
digit is a zero or a one or a two so
that this this is what will be used for
comparison to find out whether the the
system is able to recognize it correctly
or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the label so the same
way x underscore train y underscore
train is for the training data set x
underscore test y underscore test is for
the test data set okay so let me go
ahead and execute this code as well and
then we can go and check quickly what is
the how many entries are there and in
each of these so x underscore train the
shape is 13 83
by 64. and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape
we see is 414 so actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library
and which is a part of scikit-learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line
is where we are passing our data the
training data set and this is our the
the predictors and uh this is our target
we are passing this data set to train
our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning
activities in machine learning projects
we spend a lot of time for the training
part of it okay so here the data set is
relatively small so it was pretty quick
so all right so now our model has been
trained using the training data set and
we want to see how accurate this is so
what we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is uh
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for
a particular value new input you use the
predict method okay so let's run the
predict method and we pass this
particular image and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set okay that's
basically what we will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 percent accurate okay so that's on
this part now what we can also do is we
can also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize how well
this model has
done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the libraries that are required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual values same as
the predictive value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so
on and divide that by the total number
of test observations that will give you
the percentage accuracy using a
confusion matrix now let us visualize
this confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way
using a heat map so we will create a
heat map with some we'll add some colors
as well it's uh it's like more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks
and as you can see here the diagonals
again are all the values are here most
of the values so which means reasonably
this seems to be reasonably accurate and
yeah basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as i
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test values or the
total number of observations in test
data set okay so this is the confusion
matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we we picked up randomly a few of them
so this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four this is an image of
zero so the predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero
then this is the image of nine
so this has also been predicted
correctly nine and actual value is nine
and this is the image of 1 and again
this has been predicted correctly as
like the actual value okay so this was a
quick demo of logistic regression how to
use logistic regression to identify
images what is a decision tree let's go
through a very simple example before we
dig in deep decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
current or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than 2 if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum problems that
decision tree can solve so let's look at
the two different categories the
decision tree can be used on it can be
used on the classification the true
false yes no and it can be used on
regression where we figure out what the
next value is in a series of numbers or
a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
in the different parts we're going to be
using we'll start with entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of uh
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
ten and on the other side height is less
than ten true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went
into the different parts of our tree and
they call the leaf node leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision so it's the final end at the
bottom the decision node has two or more
branches this is where we're breaking
the group up into different parts and
finally you have the root node the
topmost decision node is known as the
root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals all get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with the gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base two of
the same the percentage of that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case it's yellow fence two over
eight two elephants over a total of
eight times log base two two over eight
plus one monkey over total of eight log
base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers log base two
over eight and if we plug that into our
computer our calculator i obviously
can't do logs in my head we get an
entropy equal to 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we'll
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human is probably pretty
easy to split it let's see if you're
right if you guessed the color yellow
you're correct let's say the condition
that gives us the maximum gain is yellow
so we will split the data based on the
color yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has to decreased
considerably however we still need some
splitting of both the branches to attain
an entropy value equal to zero so we
decide to split both the nodes using
height as the condition since every
branch now contains single label type we
can say that entropy in this case has
reached the least value and here you see
we have the giraffes the tigers the
monkey and the elephants all separated
into their own groups this tree can now
predict all the classes of animals
present in the dataset with a hundred
percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for his bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupiter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with very complicated machine
learning tools you almost always see the
numpy come in for your num your number
it's called number python it has your
mathematics in there in this case we
actually could take it out but generally
you'll need it for most of your
different things you work with and then
we're going to use pandas as pd that's
also a standard the pandas is a data
frame setup and you can liken this to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
our setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn import tree and that's just
the basic tree function is needed for
the decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my c drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where i stored the
data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
in an actual spreadsheet so you can see
what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1 000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head this is one of
the nice things when we did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
our print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that
let's just take a closer look at that
let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you wanna start with
the zero position and that is what the
data head does it pulls the first five
rows of data puts in a nice format that
you can look at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet or open office cal or trying
to look at a word doc where it's all
scrunched together and hard to read you
can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no and that's whether the
loan went default or not so we want to
start with one if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so it's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x x-trade or the y-train we
go ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropy called decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play with in
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three now the max depth
if you remember above when we were doing
the different graphs of animals means
it's only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves as five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits we'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use and
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case though we need to test out
the data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments and finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook is it
works as a command line for python we
can simply put the y predict e n to
print it i could just as easily put the
print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.6667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit's going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not so why random forest it's
always important to understand why we
use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts and instead of predicting the
overall data you're predicting the weird
stuff which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area and
they took a slightly different set of
statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing
which one fits better even though it's
missing that data let us dig deep into
the theory of exactly how it works
and let's look at what is a random
forest
random forest or random decision forest
is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as a final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switch from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy everything on the
decision tree and how it makes this
decision is based on entropy entropy is
a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set one and a data set two we just
split it in two and if you look at these
new
data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one
whatever comes in there it's going to
sort that data and it's going to say
okay if this data goes this direction
it's probably an apple and if it goes
into the other direction it's probably a
lemon so that brings us up to
information gain it is the measure of
decrease in the entropy after the data
set is split what that means in here is
that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision we should
have a name for the nodes above it and
they call those decision nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node
and this is where you have all of your
data and you have your first decision it
has to make or the first split in
information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit
and so let's create a problem statement
and the problem is we want to classify
the different types of fruits in the
bowl based on different features the
data set in the bowl is looking quite
messy and the entropy is high in this
case so if this bowl was our decision
maker it wouldn't know what choice to
make it has so many choices which one do
you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
and we have a label apple lemon grapes
apple lemon grapes and how do we split
the data we have to frame the conditions
to split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hardy
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at there
very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of
zero as you can see there's only one
kind of label left for this branch so no
further splitting is required for this
node however this node on the right is
still requires a split to decrease the
entropy further so we split the right
node further based on color if you look
at this if i split it on color that
pretty much cuts it right down the
middle it's the only thing we have left
in our choices of color and diameter too
and if the color is yellow it's going to
go to the right bowl and if it's false
it's going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there in this example last week my son
and i visited a fruit shop dad is that
an apple or a strawberry so the question
comes up what fruit do they just pick up
from the fruit stand after a couple of
seconds you could figure out that it was
a strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and already labeled as such
we already have a bunch of apples we
know our apples and are labeled as such
then once we train our model that model
then can be given the new data and the
new data is this image in this case you
can see a question mark on it and it
comes through and goes it's a strawberry
in this case we're using the support
vector machine model svm is a supervised
learning method that looks at data and
sorts it into one of two categories and
in this case we're sorting the
strawberry into the strawberry site at
this point you should be asking the
question how does the prediction work
before we dig into an example with
numbers let's apply this to our fruit
scenario we have our support vector
machine we've taken it and we've taken
labeled sample of data strawberries and
apples and we draw on a line down the
middle between the two groups this split
now allows us to take new data in this
case an apple and a strawberry and place
them in the appropriate group based on
which side of the line they fall in and
that way we can predict the unknown as
colorful and tasty as the fruit example
is let's take a look at another example
with some numbers involved and we can
take a closer look at how the math works
in this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set a female where
you have their height and weight 174 65
174 88 and so on and we'll need a sample
data set of the male they have a height
179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's go
ahead and put this on a graph so you
have a nice visual so you can see here
we have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw on two lines through the data in
the middle that separates them in from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls vm so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1d view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1d input and
transfer it to a two-dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1d when transferred to a two-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an svm for this type of data set
here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and documents so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or lambda
is a parameter that helps figure out
whether we're going to have a bias or
overfitting of the data whether it's
going to be overfitted to a very
specific instance or it's going to be
biased to a high or low value with the
svm it naturally avoids the overfitting
and bias problems that we see in many
other algorithms these three advantages
of the support vector machine make it a
very powerful tool to add to your
repertoire of machine learning tools now
we did promise you a used case study
we're actually going to dive into some
python programming and so we're going to
go into a problem statement and start
off with the zoo so in the zoo example
we have family members going to the zoo
we have the young child going dead is
that a group of crocodiles or alligators
well that's hard to differentiate and
zoos are a great place to start looking
at science and understanding how things
work especially as a young child and so
we can see the parents sitting here
thinking well what is the difference
between a crocodile and an alligator
well one crocodiles are larger in size
alligators are smaller in size snout
widths the crocodiles have a narrow
snout and alligators have a wider snout
and of course in the modern day and age
the father is sitting here thinking how
can i turn this into a lesson for my son
and he goes let a support vector machine
segregate the two groups i don't know if
my dad ever told me that but that would
be funny now in this example we're not
going to use actual measurements and
data we're just using that for imagery
and that's very common in a lot of
machine learning algorithms and setting
them up but let's roll up our sleeves
and we'll talk about that more in just a
moment as we break into our python
script so here we arrive in our actual
coding and i'm going to move this into a
python editor in just a moment but let's
talk a little bit about what we're going
to cover first we're going to cover in
the code the setup how to actually
create our svm and you're going to find
that there's only two lines of code that
actually create it and the rest of it is
done so quick and fast that it's all
here in the first page and we'll show
you what that looks like as far as our
data because we're going to create some
data i talked about creating data just a
minute ago and so we'll get into the
creating data here and you'll see this
nice correction of our two blops and
we'll go through that in just a second
and then the second part is we're going
to take this and we're going to bump it
up a notch we're going to show you what
it looks like behind the scenes but
let's start with actually creating our
setup i like to use the anaconda jupiter
notebook because it's very easy to use
but you can use any of your favorite
python editors or setups and go in there
but let's go ahead and switch over there
and see what that looks like so here we
are in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupiter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go and put our
code in there and one of the things i
like about the jupiter notebook is i go
up to view and i'm going to go ahead and
toggle the line numbers on to make it a
little bit easier to talk about and we
can even increase the size because this
is edited in this case i'm using google
chrome explorer and that's how it opens
up for the editor although anyone any
like i said any editor will work now the
first step is going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as np and matplot library dot pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python we need that
because part of the platform we're using
uses that for the numpy array and i'll
talk about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus the standard python array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np for numpy the map plot library
is how we're going to view our data so
this has you do need the np for the sk
learn module but the map plot library is
purely for our use for visualization and
so you really don't need that for the
svm but we're going to put it there so
you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're going to i'm going to
jump one ahead to line number four
that's the
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import make blobs and i told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the sk learning to makeup
data i personally don't want to go to
the zoo get in trouble for jumping over
the fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as i work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your your setup and you're not sure
about what data you're going to put in
there you can create this blob and it
makes it really easy to use and finally
we have our actual svm the sk learn
import svm on line three so that covers
all our imports we're going to create
remember i use the make blobs to create
data and we're going to create a capital
x and a lowercase y equals make blobs in
samples equals 40. so we're going to
make 40 lines of data it's going to have
two centers with a random state equals
twenties which each each group is going
to have 20 different pieces of data in
it and the way that looks is that we'll
have under x um an x y plane so i have
two numbers under x and y will be zero
one that's the two different centers so
we have yes or no in this case alligator
or crocodile that's what that represents
and then i told you that the actual sk
learner the svm is in two lines of code
and we see it right here with clf equals
svm.svc kernel equals linear and i set
sequel to 1 although in this example
since we are not regularizing the data
because we want to be very clear and
easy to see i went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish on the other side
that's our two sets of data they
represent one represents crocodiles and
one represents alligators and then we
have our measurements in this case we
have like the width and length of the
snout and i did say i was going to come
up here and talk just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see plt that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there and then look at this notation
i have the capital x and then in
brackets i have a colon comma 0. that's
from numpy if you did that in a regular
array you'll get an error in a python
array you have to have that in a numpy
array it turns out that our make blobs
returns a numpy array and this notation
is great because what it means is the
first part is the colon means we're
going to do all the rows that's all the
data in our blob we created under
capital x and then the second part has a
comma zero we're only going to take the
first value and then if you notice we do
the same thing but we're going to take
the second value remember we always
start with zero and then one so we have
column zero and column one and you can
look at this as our x y plots the first
one is the x plot and the second one is
the y plot so the first one is on the
bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and 10 and then the
second one x of the one is the 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 going up the left hand side s
equals 30 is just the size of the dots
we can see them and said little tiny
dots and then the c map equals
plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
fit was done in two lines of code a lot
of times will be a third line where we
regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i am giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width and length 5 6.
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see clf dot predict new data so the clf
and the dot predict part is going to
give us an answer and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see 0 1. so
predicted the first one the 3 4 is going
to be on the one side and the 5 6 is
going to be on the other side so one
came out as an alligator and one came
out as a crocodile now that's pretty
short explanation for the setup but
really we want to dug in and see what
it's going on behind the scenes and
let's see what that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
than we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here that
we go through a few steps and i'll move
this over to our editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that and
show you how not to redo that and then
we're going to go in there and add in
those lines we're going to see what
those lines look like and how to set
those up and finally we're going to plot
all that on here and show it and you'll
get a nice graph with the what we saw
earlier when we were going through the
theory behind this where it shows the
support vectors and the hyperplane and
those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 it has plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and i'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the top here of our new
section one two three and four is the
same code we had before and let's go
back up here and take a look at that
we're gonna fit the values on our svm
and then we're gonna plot scatter it and
then we're gonna do a plot show so you
should be asking why are we redoing the
same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is very standard note used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt it can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit 0 x limit 1
comma 30 and we've done the same thing
for the y space and then we're going to
go in here and we create a mesh grid and
this is a numpy command so we're back to
our numbers python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean with the line
space and the mesh grid we've taken x x
small s x x equals np line space and we
have our x limit 0 and our x limit 1 and
we're going to create 30 points on it
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis now this has nothing to do
with our evaluation it's all we're doing
is we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y and then
the mesh grid loops those all together
so it forms a nice grid so if we were
going to do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes and the mesh
grid combines them all so we take the yy
and the xx we created and creates the
full grid and we've set that grid into
the yy coordinates and the xx
coordinates now remember we're working
with numbi and python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then x 2 comma y 2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital yy and a
column of x's capital xx with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value z and the
z equals the clf that's our that's our
support vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a dot
decision function we're going to put the
x y in there so here we have all this
data we're going to put that x y in
there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the x x dot shape in here this literally
takes the xx resets it up connected to
the y and the z value lets us know
whether it is the left hand side is
going to generate three different values
the z value does and it'll tell us
whether that data is a support vector to
the left the hyperplane in the middle or
the support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so it's
900 points of data and we separate it
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital xx capital yy these have
been reshaped to fit those lines z is
the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the alphas just makes it kind of
see-through so it's only
0.5 of the value in there so when we
graph it the data will show up from
behind it wherever the lines go and
finally the line styles this is where we
set the two support vectors to be dash
dash lines and then a single one is just
a straight line that's what all that
setup does and then finally we take our
ax dot scatter we're going to go ahead
and plot the support vectors but we've
programmed it in there so that they look
nice like the dash dash line and the
dashed line on that grid and you can see
here when we do the clf dot support
vectors we are looking at column 0 and
column 1 and then again we have the s
equals 100 so we're going to make them
larger and the line width equals 1 face
colors equals none let's take a look and
see what that looks like when we show it
and you can see we get down to our end
result it creates a really nice graph we
have our two support vectors and dashed
lines and they have the near data so you
can see those two points or in this case
the four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyper plane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth we're going to
cover the k nearest neighbors like
referred to as k n n and k n is really a
fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp brother claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat
sharp claws length of ears and goes in
the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for it's one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how his neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals 5 i mean that's
what's the value we put in there so
we're going to talk about it how do we
choose a factor k k n algorithm is based
on feature similarity choosing the right
value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals a 7 we classify as a
triangle depending on what the other
data is around and you can see as the k
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer and
we jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get he's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using like this case
squares and triangles if it's even you
want to make your k value odd that helps
it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use knn when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in that says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at they were saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of k n n positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the knn
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different uh
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments i can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case i'm going to
it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see i have
a number of windows open up at the top
the one we're working in and since we're
working on the k n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and i'm
also going to go up here and click on
cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then i'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
i'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're going to import
the pandas as pd import numpy is np
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our trained test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between minus 1 and 1. and then
the actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so that we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick links of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a 0 in
there because they didn't have the data
and we'll take a look at that because
we're going to start replacing that
information with a couple of different
things and let's see what that looks
like so first we create a nice list as
you can see we have the values talked
about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals data set column dot
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also one that's
that you look for your nan a lot of
different options in here but the n a n
in num p n a n is what that stands for
is none it doesn't exist so the first
thing we're doing here is we're
replacing the zero with a numpy none
there's no data there that's what that
says that's what this is saying right
here so put the zero in and we're going
to play zeros with no data so if it's a
zero that means the person's well
hopefully not dead hope they just didn't
get the data the next thing we want to
do is we're going to create the mean
which is the integer from the data set
from the column dot mean where we skip n
a's we can do that that is a pandas
command there the skip n a so we're
going to figure out the mean of that
data set and then we're going to take
that data set column and we're going to
replace all the npn with the means why
did we do that and we could have
actually just taken this step and gone
right down here and just replaced zero
and skip anything where except you could
actually there's a way to skip zeros and
then just replace all the zeros but in
this case we want to go ahead and do it
this way so you could see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
then we're going to create the mean well
this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
that shows you can see you skipped a
bunch in the middle because that's what
it does if you have too many lines in
jupiter notebook it'll skip a few and go
on to the next in a data set let me go
and remove this and we'll just zero out
that and of course before we do any
processing before proceeding any further
we need to split the data set into our
train and testing data that way we have
something to train it with and something
to test it on and you're going to notice
we did a little something here with the
pandas database code there we go my
drawing tool we've added in this right
here
of the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we printed it
in here is outcome well that's not part
of the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here zero this is
actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column 8 and
you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the sk learn right
there and we simply put in our x and our
y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you see it i have to
look that up and then the test size test
size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any printout other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is 1 to 6 we're going to set that
all so that all the data is between -1
and 1. that's what that standard scalar
does keeps it standardized and we only
want to fit the scalar with the training
set but we want to make sure the testing
set is the x test going in is also
transformed so it's processing it the
same so here we go with our standard
scalar we're going to call it sc
underscore x for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our x train
equals sc underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the x
train variable and then our x test we're
also going to transform it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to go and run
this if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key columns it shouldn't be zero and
we replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we scaled the
data so all of our data going in no no
we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import math we
do math dot square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11.
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix y test
y predict so those are the two values
we're going to put in there and let me
go ahead and run that and print it out
and the way you interpret this is you
have the y predicted which would be your
title up here you could do let's just do
p-r-e-d
predicted across the top and actual
going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here and that column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero is the 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the f1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our f1 score
the f1
takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives
where if we go ahead and just do the
accuracy account and that's what most
people think of is it looks at just how
many we got right out of how many we got
wrong so a lot of people when you're
data scientist and you're talking to
other data scientists they're going to
ask you what the f1 score the f score is
if you're talking to the general public
or the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent it tells us it is a pretty fair
fit in the model what is k-means
clustering
k-means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm in this case you
don't have labeled data unlike in
supervised learning so you have a set of
data and you want to group them and as
the name suggests you want to put them
into clusters which means objects that
are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if k
is equal to two there will be two
clusters if k is equal to three three
clusters and so on and so forth that's
what the k stands for and of course
there is a way of finding out what is
the best or optimum value of k for a
given data we will look at that so that
is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about the
runs scored by the people ordered by the
player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to two and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from this centroid and the
distance from this center right this
point is taken and the distance is found
from this centroid and the center and so
on and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine the
central point or the actual centroid for
these two clusters so we have this one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning the centroid
is repeated till the repositioning stops
which means that the algorithm has
converged and we have the final cluster
with the data points and the centroids
so this is what you're going to learn
from this session we will talk about the
types of clustering what is k-means
clustering application of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is done
using distance measure so we will talk
about the common distance measures and
then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c d e f we start by
combining b and c form one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add bc to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is the top-down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have abcdef we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
into a b c d
e f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life
starting from academic performance
diagnostic systems search engines and
wireless sensor networks and many more
so let us take a little deeper look at
each of these examples academic
performance so based on the scores of
the students students are categorized
into a b c and so on clustering forms a
backbone of search engines when a search
is performed the search results need to
be grouped together the search engines
very often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of this formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance as the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root
we leave the square as it is and then we
have manhattan distance measure in case
of manhattan distance it is the sum of
the distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign
that many centroids so it picks randomly
that to start with randomly that many
points that are considered to be the
centroids of these clusters and then it
measures the distance of each of the
data points from these centroids and
assigns those points to the
corresponding centroid from which the
distance is minimum so each data point
will be assigned to the centroid which
is closest to it and thereby we have k
number of initial clusters however this
is not the final clusters the next step
it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the mean
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss
that is taken as the optimum value of k
so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y-axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to 1 which means all the
data points are in a single cluster the
within s value will be very high because
they are probably scattered all over the
moment you split it into two there will
be a drastic fall in the within ss value
that's what is represented here but then
as the value of k increases the decrease
the rate of decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be either 2 or 3 or at the most 4
but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two
centroids randomly so let's say c1 and
c2 are the centroids assigned randomly
now the distance of each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been randomly assigned points and
only thing that has been done was the
data points which are closest to them
have been assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned or
repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is
the repetitive process iterative process
and if the centroid doesn't change once
the centroid stops changing that means
the algorithm has converged and this is
our final cluster with this as the
centroid c1 and c2 as the centroids
these data points as a part of each
cluster so i hope this helps in
understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
central point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of these newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step 4 we repeat
step two
and three so we again calculate the
distance of x one
from
the centroid c one
c two c three and then c which is the
lowest value and assign x x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at it at
each of these steps so we randomly pick
k cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1
c3 and then we find which is the lowest
value right that's the minimum value we
find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2
x2 from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now
find the actual centroid for each group
so what has happened
as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values they need
not be equally distributed by the way
based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a real occasion so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in
step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in python notebook
using pattern notebook but before that
let's find out what's the problem that
we are trying to solve the problem
statement is let's say walmart wants to
open a chain of stores across the state
of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously the they will not make profit
but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct
groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign each of these points
to the centroids and then check whether
they are
the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this so we
have four distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
the centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart find the
best locations for the stores in florida
so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are learning
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a
part of the code then we are going and
creating blobs which are similar to
clusters now this is a very neat feature
which is available in scikit
scikit-learn make blobs is a nice
feature which creates clusters of data
sets so that's a wonderful functionality
that is readily available for us to
create some test data kind of thing okay
so that's exactly what we are doing here
we are using make blobs and we can
specify how many clusters we want so
centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually provides
now from
here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then
we create an instance of k means and we
specify the value of k this n underscore
clusters is the value of k remember k
means in k means k is basically the
number of clusters that you want to
create and it is a integer value
so this is where we are specifying that
so we have k is equal to four
and so that instance is created
we take that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to train the model here
there is no real training kind of thing
but that's the call okay so we are
calling fit and what we are doing here
we are just passing the data so x has
these values the data that has been
created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which uh basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster 1
this is 2 3 and so on or i will actually
start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe
and then for each of the observations it
will assign based on which cluster it
belongs to it will assign a value so
that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these
y underscore k means are with the
cluster numbers that have been assigned
for each observation so this is the
cluster number assigned for observation
1 maybe this is for observation 2
observation 3 and so on so we have how
many about i think 300 samples right so
all the 300 samples there are 300 values
here each of them the cluster number is
given and the cluster number goes from 0
to 3 so there are four clusters so the
numbers go from 0 1 2 3. so that's what
is seen here okay now so this was a
quick example of generating some dummy
data and then clustering that okay and
this can be applied if you have proper
data you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the cable so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many customers you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code
at each step what it is doing and then
we will see a couple of more examples of
how k-means clustering
can be used in maybe some real life
examples real life use cases all right
so in this case here what we are doing
is basically implementing k-means
clustering and there is a function or a
library calculates for a given two pairs
of points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign that
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid
the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process still the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case also with
that is actually convergence right so
for example the change is point zero
zero zero one we can consider that as
convergence otherwise what will happen
is this will either take forever or it
will be never ending so that's a small
flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned this is not
the most sophisticated implementation uh
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data x and the
number of clusters which is four
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k-means
clustering and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real-life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory uh so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm and this
will then create clusters
of only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors
and now we need to bring it down to 16
colors so we use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though the image quality is definitely
reduced a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let we load that
and this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and
this is the shape of this image which is
basically what is the shape is nothing
but the overall size right so this is
427 pixel by 640 pixel and then there
are three layers which is this three
basically is for rgb which is red green
blue so color image will have that right
so that is the shape of this now what we
need to do is data let's take a look at
how data is looking so let me just
create a new cell and show you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix
and each one has about for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are large the numbers are a large so we
need to normalize them to between 0 and
1 right so that's why we will basically
create one more variable which is data
which will contain the values between 0
and 1 and the way to do that is divide
by 255 so we divide china by 255 and we
get the new values in data so let's just
run this piece of code and this is the
shape so we now have also yeah what we
have done is we changed using reshape we
converted into the three-dimensional
into a two-dimensional data set and let
us also take a look at how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here
and take a look at how data is looking
all right so this is how data is looking
and now you see this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between zero and one
this is one of the things we need to do
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look so this is red against green
and this is red against blue there is uh
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything like
that now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look uh how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been
lost it pretty much looks like the
original image yes we can see that for
example here there is a little bit it
appears a little dullish compared to
this one right because we kind of took
off some of the finer details of the
color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so this is
the image now once again we can take a
look at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big so we will
much bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
does the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for with
the new just the 16 color so once again
as you can see this looks much richer in
color but at the same time and this
probably doesn't have as we can see it
doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done uh using
k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering we're going to cover
mathematics for machine learning so
today's agenda is going to cover data
and its types then we're going to dive
into linear algebra and its concepts
calculus statistics for machine learning
probability for machine learning
hands-on demos
and of course thrown in there in the
middle is going to be your matrixes and
a few other things to go along with all
this
data and as types
data denotes the individual pieces of
factual information collected from
various sources it is stored processed
and later used for analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information a lot of tech stuff money
dollar signs numbers
and then you have your performing
analytics to drive insights and
hopefully you have a nice share your
shareholders gather it at the meeting
and you're able to explain it in
something they can understand
so we talk about data types of data
we have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal and then
you have your quantitative or numerical
which is discrete or continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine but let's dive into this what
we mean by nominal nominal they are used
to label various uh
label our variables without providing
any measurable value
country gender race hair color etc it's
something that you either mark true or
false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not
so a lot of times when you're thinking
nominal data
labels
think of it as a true false kind of
setup and we look at ordinal this is
categorical data with a set order or a
scale to it
and you can think of salary range as a
great one
movie ratings etc you see here the
salary range if you have ten thousand to
twenty thousand number of employees
earning that rate is a hundred and fifty
twenty thousand to thirty thousand a
hundred and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket uh this is where
you have ten different buckets and you
to separate it into something that makes
sense into those 10 buckets
and so when we start talking about
ordinal a lot of times when you get down
to the brass bones again we're talking
true false
so if you're a member of the 10 to 20 k
range
so forth those would each be either part
of that group or you're not
but now we're talking about buckets and
we want to count how many people are in
that bucket
quantitative numerical data
falls into two classes discrete or
continuous and so data with a final set
of values which can be categorized class
strength questions answered correctly
and runs hit and cricket
a lot of times when you see this you can
think integer and a very restricted
integer i
you can only have a hundred questions um
on a test so you can it's very discrete
i only have a hundred different values
that it can attain
so think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open end or anything
like that
so discrete is very solid
simple to count
set number
continuous on the other hand continuous
data can take any numerical value within
a range
so water pressure weight of a person etc
usually we start thinking about float
values where they can get phenomenally
small in their in what they're worth
and there's a whole series of values
that falls right between discrete and
continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from
525.33 cents to
five hundred and eighty dollars point
sixty seven cents there's a lot of point
values in there it'd still be called
discrete but you start looking at it as
almost continuous because it does have
such a variance in it now we talked
about no we did we went over nominal and
ordinal
almost true false charts and we looked
at quantitative and numerical data which
were starting to get into numbers
discrete you can usually a lot of times
discrete will be put into it could be
put into true false but usually it's not
so we want to address this stuff and the
first thing you want to look at is the
very basic which is your algebra so
we're going to take a look at linear
algebra you can remember back when your
euclidean geometry we have a line well
let's go through this we have a linear
algebra is the domain of mathematics
concerning linear equations
and the representations in vector spaces
and through matrixes i told you we're
going to talk about matrixes
so a linear equation
is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10.
very linear 10x plus 12.4y equals z and
now you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them
and this we're talking about a linear
equation
in the vectors we have a plus b equals c
now we're starting to look at a
direction
and these values usually think of an x y
z plot
so each one is a direction and the
actual
distance of like a triangle a b is c
and then your matrix can describe all
kinds of things
i find matrixes
confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because of the magnitude
and the different things they're used
for
and a matrix is a chart
or a
you know think of a spreadsheet but you
have your rows and your columns
and you'll see here we have a times b
equals c
very important to know your counts uh so
depending on how the math is being done
what you're using it for making sure you
have the same rows and number of columns
or a single number there's all kinds of
things that play in that that can make
matrixes confusing
but really it has a lot more to do with
what domain you're working in are you
adding in
multiple polynomials where you have like
uh
a x squared plus b y plus you know you
start to see that can be very confusing
versus a very straightforward matrix
and let's just go a little deeper into
these because these are such primary
this is what we're here to talk about is
these different math uh mathematical
computations that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of one
is called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have a x plus b equals c which
is a one variable
we have two variable a x plus b y equals
c a x plus b y plus z c z equals d and
so forth but all of these
are to the power of one you don't see x
squared you don't see x cubed so we're
talking about linear equations that's
what we're talking about in their
addition if you have already dived into
say neural networks you should recognize
this a x plus b y plus c z
setup plus the intercept
which is basically your your neural
network each node adding up all the
different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula is your y equals mx plus
c
so you have your y
equals the m which is your slope
your x value plus c
which is your
y-intercept you kind of label it wrong
here
threw me for a loop but the the c would
be your y-intercept so when you set x
equal to 0 y equals c and that's that's
your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they just had a reverse
value of y when x equals zero equals the
y-intercept which is c and your slow
gradient line which is your m so it's
your y equals two x plus three
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems and then
of course the
one of the most important takeaways is
the slope gradient of the line
so the slope is very important that m
value
in this case we went ahead and solved
this
if you have y equals 2 x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice line graph here on
the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking m rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the first column similarly
a12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a
row one column two
uh first row and second column and so on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
i've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or i
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize
there's need to be some designation as
far as what row it's in and what column
it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have
two matrixes of two by 2 and you just
add each individual number in that
matrix and then when you get to the
bottom you have in this case the
solution is 12 10 plus 2 is 12 5 plus 3
is 8 and so on and the same thing with
subtraction now again you're counting
matrixes you want to check your
dimensions of the matrix
the shape you'll see shape come up a lot
in programming so we're talking about
dimensions we're talking about the shape
if the two shapes are equal
this is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up with a
very a slightly different setup going
now
if we look at our last one we're uh
we're like why
this always gets to me when we get to
matrixes because they don't really say
why you multiply matrixes
you know my first thought is one times
two four times three but if you look at
this we get one times two plus four
times three
one times three plus four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five if
you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation
and so we have if you remember we went
back up here for our multiple line
equations let's just go back up a couple
slides where we were looking at a two
variable so this is a two variable
equation ax plus b y equals c
and this is a way to make it very quick
to solve these variables and that's why
you have the matrix and that's why you
do
the multiplication the way they do
and this is the dot product of
one times two
plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
six times two plus three times three
times 3 plus 3 times 5 and it gives us a
nice little
14 23 21 and 33 over here which then can
be used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs
and then in matrix operations when
you're dealing with a lot of matrixes uh
now keep in mind multiplying matrixes is
different than finding the product of
two matrixes okay so we're talking about
multiplication we're talking about
solving uh for equations when you're
finding the product you are just finding
1 times 2. keep that in mind because
that does come up i've had that come up
a number of times where i'm altering
data and i get confused as to what i'm
doing with it
transpose flipping the matrix over is
diagonal comes up all the time where you
have you still have 12 but instead of it
being uh 12 8 it's now 12 14
8 21 you're just flipping the columns
and the rows
and then of course you can do an inverse
changing the signs of the values across
this main diagonal and you can see here
we have the inverse a to the minus 1 and
ends up with
instead of 12 8 14 12 it's now minus 22
minus 12. vectors
vector just means we have
a value and a direction
and we have down four numbers here on
our vector
in mathematics a one-dimensional matrix
is called a vector
so
if you have your x plot and you have a
single value that values along the
x-axis and it's a single dimension
if you have two dimensions you can think
about putting them on a graph you might
have x and you might have y and each
value denotes a direction and then of
course the actual distance is going to
be the hypothesis of that triangle
and you can do that with three
dimensionals x y and z
and you can do it all the way to nth
dimensions so when they talk about the k
means
for categorizing and how close data is
together they will compute that based on
the pythagorean theorem so you would
take
the square of each value add them all
together and find the square root and
that gives you a distance
as far as where that point is where that
vector exists or an actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value
to another one it makes a very easy
comparison versus comparing 50 or 60
different numbers
and that brings us up to i gene vectors
and i gene values
i gene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span while transformation
and igene values the scalar values that
are associated to the vectors
conceptually
you can think of the vector as your
picture you have a picture it's
two dimensions x and y and so when you
do those two dimensions and those two
values or whatever that value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it and so
if we take and we have a vector a
and that's a set value uh b is um your
is your you have a and b which is your
hygiene vector two is the i gene value
so we're altering
all the values by two that means we're
uh maybe we're stretching it out one
direction making it tall if you're doing
picture editing
that's one of the places this comes in
but you can see when you're transforming
your different information how you
transform it is then your hygiene value
and you can see here vector after line
transit transition
we have 3a a is the hygiene vector 3 is
the iogene value so a doesn't change
that's whatever we started with that's
your original picture and three
is skewing it one direction and maybe uh
b is being skewed another direction and
so you have a nice tilted picture
because you altered it by those by the
aging values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this i'm going
to go through my trusted anaconda into
my jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new
notebook called linear algebra
since we are working in python we're
going to use our numpy i always import
that as np or numpy array probably the
most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series i'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15 29 and
went and added a space there in between
so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on it
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when i run this
we have 10 15 29 and we get 30 24 which
is what you expect 10 plus 20 15 plus 9
you could almost look at this addition
as being
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a dot t
plus b dot t
remember that t flips them and so if we
do that we now get them
we now have 30 24 going the other way we
could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b i can also do a plus
b
dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 30 24 whether i
transpose a and b or transpose them both
at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors i can go a minus b
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section that's why i
don't have to put the print around it
and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main set up and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
and just put down scalar so you can
remember that
uh what we're talking about here is i
have
this array here u
and if i go a
times u
we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply it
by every value in here so 2 times 30 is
60 2 times 15.
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have what they call
dot product
and uh with this this is in a two
dimensional vectors it is equivalent of
two matrix multiplication remember we
were talking about matrix multiplication
uh where it is the
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
um
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our u and our v
and then we're going to go ahead and do
if we take
the values
and if you remember correctly
an array like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6.
we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the
np dot dot
of u comma
v
and we'll find when we do this we go and
run this
uh we're going to get
370 370.
so this is a strain multiplication where
they use it to solve
linear algebra uh when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our dot multiplication
and we did
addition earlier which is just your
basic addition
and of course the matrix you can get
very complicated on these or
in this case we'll go ahead and do
let's create two
complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of um you know 12
10 4 6 4 31. we'll just print out a so
you can see what that looks like here's
print
a
we print a out you can see that we have
2 by 3
layer matrix for a
and we can also put together
always kind of fun when you're playing
with print values
we could do something like this we could
go in here
there we go
we could print a we have it end with
equals a
run
and this kind of gives it a nice look
here's your matrix that's all this is
comma n means it just tags it on the end
that's all all that is doing on there
and then we can simply add in what is a
plus b and you should already guess
because this is the same as what we did
before there's no difference
we do a simple vector addition we have
12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus 8 is 18 and so
on
and just like we did the
matrix addition we can also do a minus b
and do our matrix subtraction
and we look at this uh we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus 8 um where are we
oh there we go 8 minus
confusing what i'm looking at i should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10 10 minus 8 is 2
4 minus 46 is minus 42 and so forth so
same as a subtraction as before we just
call it matrix subtraction it's
identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just one
number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication
and so simply if you have a single value
a and you have b which is your array we
can also do a times b
when we run that
you can see here we have 2 times 4 is 8.
5 times 4 is 20 and so forth you're just
multiplying the 4 across each one of
these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up
a little bit of a brain teaser is matrix
and vector multiplication
and so we're looking at this
we are
just doing regular arrays it doesn't
necessarily have to be a numpy array
we have a
which has our
array of arrays and b which is a single
array and so we can from here
do the dot
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the first value is that is you could
say it's like uh
we're doing the
this array b array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match when you get into
really complicated uh back end stuff
this becomes more common because you're
now you've got layers upon layers of
data and so you'll end up with a matrix
and a set of bolt vector matrices do you
want to
now keep in mind
that if you're doing data science a lot
of times you're not looking at this this
is what's going on behind the scenes so
if you're in
the scikit looking at sk learn where
you're doing linear regression models
this is some of the math that's hidden
behind the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the psi kit and if we can do
up here where we did a
matrix and vector multiplication we can
also do matrix two matrix multiplication
and if we run this where we have the two
matrixes uh you can see a very
complicated array that of course comes
out on there for our dot
and just to reiterate it we have our
transpose matrix which is your dot t
and so if we create a matrix a and we do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from
5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15 25
10 20 30 rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot
it also comes up a lot with xy plotting
when you put into pi plot you have one
format where they're looking at pairs
and numbers and then they want all of
x's and all y's so you know the
transpose is an important tool both for
your math and for plotting and all kinds
of things another tool that we didn't
discuss uh is your identity matrix
and this one is more definition
uh the identity matrix
we have here one where we just did two
so it comes down as one zero zero one
one zero zero zero one zero it creates a
diagonal of one and what that is is when
you're doing your identities you could
be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate
and of course when you have feature one
compared to feature one to itself it is
always
one
where
usually it's between zero one depending
on how well correlates so when we're
talking about identity matrix that's
what we're talking about right here is
that you create this preset matrix and
then you might adjust these numbers
depending on what you're working with
and what the domain is
and then another thing we can do
to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh
piece of this
puzzle here is an inverse
a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
it's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the uh
the website for
numpy
so given a square matrix a here's our
square matrix a which is 2 1 0 0 1 0 1 2
1. keep in mind 3 by 3 is square it's
got to be equal it's going to return the
matrix a inverse satisfying dot a
a inverse so here's our matrix
multiplication
um and then of course it equals the dot
yeah a inverse of a
with an identity shape of
a dot shaped 0. this is just reshaping
the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see what we end up with
is we end up with
an array 0.5 minus 0.5 and so forth with
our 2 1 1 going down 2 1 0 0 1 0 1 2 1.
getting into a little deep on the math
understanding
when you need this is probably really is
is what's really important when you're
doing data science
versus uh handwriting this out and
looking up the math and handwriting all
the pieces out you do need to know about
the linear algorithm inverse of a
so if it comes up you can easily pull it
up or at least remember where to look it
up you took a look at the algebra side
of it let's go ahead and take a look at
the calculus side of what's going on
here with the machine learning so
calculus oh my goodness and differential
equations you got to throw that in there
because that's all part of the
bag of tricks especially when you're
doing large neural networks but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already done for
you in the back end
so when it comes up you really do need
to understand from the data science not
data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation
so we talk about calculus
we're going to go ahead
and understand it by talking about cars
versus time and speed
so helps to calculate the spontaneous
rate of change
so suppose we plot a graph of the speed
of a car with respect to time so as you
can see here
going down the highway probably merged
into the highway from an on-ramp so i
had to accelerate so my speed went way
up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and i accelerate again
up to the speed limit
and
maybe peter's off up there so you can
look at this as as
the speed versus time i'm getting faster
and faster because i'm continually
accelerating and if i hit the brakes it
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect of time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
star point of x and the end point of
delta x
so we can calculate a simple
if you had x and delta x we could put a
line there and that slope of the line is
our acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but i don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points i want to know what across the
whole of what i'm working with
that's where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between x
and delta x it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
uh so the idea is instead of i mean if
you ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up
let's go back up the screen you divide
this area of this time period up into
maybe 10 sections and you'd use that and
you could calculate the acceleration
between each one of those 10 sections
kind of thing
and then we just keep making that space
smaller and smaller until delta x is
almost
infinitesimally small
and so we get a function of a
equals a limit as h goes to 0 of a
function of a plus h minus a function of
a over h and that is you're computing
the slope of the line
we're just computing that slope under
smaller and smaller and smaller samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral you can see down here we
have our nice uh integral sign looks
like a giant s
and that's what that means is that we've
taken this down to as small as we can
for that sampling uh so we're talking
about calculus we're finding the area
under the slope is the main process in
the integration
similar small intervals are made of the
smallest possible length of x plus delta
x where delta x approaches almost an
infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together uh so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times d of x
equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations um
changing w over change of time
equals change of w over change of z
the differential of z to dx differential
of x to dt it gets pretty complicated uh
it really translates into the
multivariate integration using double
integrals and so you have the the sum of
the sum of f of x y of d of a equals the
sum from c to d and a to b of f of x y d
x d y equals
the sum of a to b sum of c to d of f x
of y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math is usually calculus 1
calculus 2 and differential equations
so you're talking about three
full-length courses to dig into
and solve these math equations
what we want to take from here is we're
talking about calculus uh we're talking
about summing of all these different
slopes and so we're still solving a
linear
expression we're still solving
y equals m x plus b
but we're doing this for infinitely
small x's and then we want to sum them
up that's what this integral sign means
the
sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
uh multivariate differentiation using
the chain rule
uh when we come in here and we have the
change of w to the change of t equals
the change of w dz
uh and so forth that's what's going on
here that's what these means we're
basically looking for the area under the
curve which really comes to
how is the change changing speeds going
up how is that changing and then you end
up with a multiple layer so if i have
three layers of neural networks how is
the third layer changing based on the
second layer changing which is based on
the first layer changing and you get the
picture here that now we have a very
complicated uh multivariate integration
with integrals
the good news is we can solve this uh
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation
uh so the nice thing is that you don't
have to solve this on paper unless
you're a data analysis and you're
working on the back end of integrating
these formulas and building the script
to actually build them so we talk about
applications of calculus it provides us
the tools to build an accurate
predictive model
so it's really behind the scenes we want
to guess at what the change of the
change or the change is
that's a little goofy i i know i just
threw that out there it's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and global maxima
and this is really big uh we're going to
actually going to have a whole section
here on gradient descent because it is
really i mean i talked about neural
networks and how you can see how the
different layers go in there but
gradient descent is one of the most key
things for trying to guess the best
answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent
and before we open up the code let's
just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common is that this is going to
represent your error oops
error there we go error
ah hard to read there and i want to make
the error as low as possible
and so what i'm looking at it is i want
to find this line here
which is the
minimum value so we're looking for the
minimum
and it does that by
sampling there and then based on this it
guesses it might be someplace here and
it goes hey this is still going down
it goes here and then goes back over
here and then goes a little bit closer
and it's just playing a high low until
it gets to that spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error
and
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best output of it
that's simply
minus the value
so if you're looking for where the peak
is
this is the same as a negative for where
the valley is i'm looking for that
valley
uh that's all that is this is a way of
finding it so
the cool thing is um all the heavy
lifting's done um i actually
ended up putting together one of these a
while back is when i didn't know about
sidekick and i was just starting
boys a long while back
and
is playing high low how do you play high
low not get stuck in the valleys
figure out these curves and things like
that well you do that and the back end
is all the calculus and differential
equations to calculate this out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
uh so instead we're going to put
together the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun
uh some things we're going to note and
this is this is really important stuff
because when you start doing your data
science and digging into your machine
learning models
you're going to find
these things are stumbling blocks
the first one is current x where do we
start at
keep in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start
and we started at this because the
algorithm starts at x equals three
so we arbitrarily picked five learning
rate is uh how many bars to skip going
one where the other in fact i'm going to
separate that a little bit because these
two are really important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about
well here's our here's the function
we're going to use our
gradient of our function
2 times x plus 5 keep it simple so
that's the function we're going to work
with so if i'm dealing with increments
of 1000.1 is going to be a very long
time and if i'm dealing with increments
of 0.001
0.1
is going to skip over my answer so i
won't get a very good answer
and then we look at precision this tells
us when to stop the algorithm so again
very specific to what you're working on
if you're working with money and
you don't convert it into a float value
you might be dealing with 0.01 which is
a penny that might be your precision
you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size max iterations we want something to
cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions
and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than precision and
iters is less than max and max iters
let's say that 10 times fast
um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper
and then we also don't want to go past a
thou or whatever this is a million or
ten thousand uh running that's actually
pretty high we almost never do max
iterations more than like a hundred or
two 200
rare occasions you might go up to four
or five hundred if it's depending on the
problem you're working with uh so we
have our previous equals our current
that way we can track time wise
uh the current now equals the current
minus the rate times the formula of our
previous x
so now we've generated our new version
previous step size equals the absolute
current previous
so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get too far
and then we're just going to print the
local minimum occurs at
x on here and if we go ahead and run
this
you can see right here it gets down to
this point and it says hey
local minimum is minus
3.322 for this particular series we
created
this is created off of our formula here
lambda x2 times x plus 5. now
when i'm running this stuff
you'll see this come up a lot
in
with the sk learn kit
and one of the nice reasons of breaking
this down the way we did is i could go
over those top pieces uh those top
pieces are everything when you start
looking at these minimization tool kits
in built-in code
and so from
we'll just do it's actually
docs
dot
scipy.org
and we're looking at
the psi kit
there we go
optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value you have
the function that's going in this
function can be very complicated
so we used a very simple function up
here
it could be
there's all kinds of things that could
be on there and there's a number of
methods to solve this as far as how they
shrink down
and your x naught there's your there's
your start value so your function your
start value
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds
some of this it does automatically but
you really the big thing i want to point
out here is you need to have a starting
point you want to start with something
that you already know is mostly the
answer
if you don't then it's going to have a
heck of a time trying to calculate it
out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
ah so statistics well i guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an edel
class
so a bunch of stuff going on statistics
statistics concerns with the collection
organization analysis interpretation
and presentation of data
that is a mouthful
so we have from end to end
where does it come from is it valid what
does it mean how do we organize it
how do we analyze it then you gotta take
those analysis and interpret it into
something that people can use kind of
reduce it to understandable
and nowadays you have to be able to
present it if you can't present it then
no one else is going to understand what
the heck you did
so we look at the terminologies
there is a lot of terminologies
depending on what domain you're working
in
so clearly if you're working in um a
domain that deals with
viruses and t cells and and
how does you know where does that come
from you're studying the different
people then you can have a population
if you are working with
mechanical gear
you know a little bit different if
you're looking for the wobbling
statistics to know when to replace a
rotor on a machine or something like
that that can be a big deal you know we
have these huge fans that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
an interesting project that came up for
our city a while back
so population all objects are
measurements whose properties are being
observed uh so that's your population
all the objects it's easy to see it with
people because we have our population in
large
but in the case of the sewer fans we're
talking about how the fan units that's
the population of fans that we're
working with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with a conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample
sometimes you don't have a choice you
can only take a sample of what's going
on you can't
study the whole population
and a variable a metric of interest for
each person or object in a population
types of sampling
we have a probabilistic approach
selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of
probability and we'll go into a little
bit more deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified
and then you have a non-probabilistic
approach selecting samples based on the
subjective judgment of the researcher
rather than random selection it has to
do with convenience trying to reach a
quota
or snowball
and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
it says biased so you've got to be very
careful on that
so probabilistic sampling uh when we
talk about a random sampling we select
random size samples from each group or
category so we it's as random as you can
get we talk about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
uh so we kind of split it up this would
be like a time set up or our different
categories
and you might ask your question what is
a category or a group
if you look at i'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying
economics of different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from
they might need to be separated and so
uh and when i say separated i don't mean
separated from their place where they
live i mean as far as the analysis we
want to look at the different groups and
make sure they're all represented
so if we had like an eighty percent uh
of a group that is uh say hispanic and
or indian and also in that same area we
have twenty percent twenty percent who
are uh let's call our expatriates they
left america and they're nice and
your caucasian group
we might want to sample a group that is
representative of both
so we're talking about stratified
sampling and we're talking about groups
those are the groups we're talking about
and that brings us to stratified
sampling selecting approximately equal
size samples from each group or category
this way we can actually separate the
categories and give us an insight into
the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area so you
can see these are very very different
kind of
depends on what you're working with
as far as your data and what you're
studying
and so we can see here just a little bit
more we'd have selecting 25 employees
from a company of 250 employees randomly
don't care anything about them what
groups are in which office they're in
nothing
and we might be selecting one employee
from every 50 unique employees in a
company of 250 employees
and then we have selecting one employee
from every branch in the company office
so we have all the different branches
there's our group or categories by the
branch and the category could depend on
what you're studying so it has a lot of
variation on there
you see this kind of grouping and
categorizing is also used to generate a
lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is
then everybody assumes that's what it is
for everybody and so you've got to be
very careful of that it's very unethical
thing to kind of do
so types of statistics uh we talk about
statistics
we're going to talk about descriptive
and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up so we so we're
talking about a particular
setup
so we're talking about descriptive and
inferential uh statistics
the base of the word describe
is pretty solid you're describing the
data what does it look like with
inferential statistics we're going to
take that from the small population to a
large population so if you're working
with a drug company you might look at
the data and say these people were
helped by this drug
they did 80 better
as far as their health or 80 percent
better survival rate than the people
um
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are predicting how it's going to
affect the greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data so we have a measure of central
tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second
but one of them you can think of is
how it the data difference
differences you know what's the max min
range all that stuff is your spread
and anything that's just a single number
is usually your central uh tendencies
measure of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of
whatever's going on
and then your median
separates the higher half and the lower
half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points
so your mean might have some a couple
really big numbers that skew it
so that the average is much higher than
if you took those outliers out
where the median would by separating the
high from the low might give you a much
lower number you might look at and say
oh that's that's odd why is the average
so much higher than the median well it's
because you have some outliers or why is
it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value
this is really interesting if you're
studying economics and how people are
doing you might find that the most
common
income like in the u.s was uh 1.24 000 a
year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money and then you look at the median
income and you're like well the median
income is a little bit closer to the
average so it does create a very
interesting way of looking at the data
again these are all central tendencies
single numbers you can look at for the
whole spread of the data
and we look at the measure of central
tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a students in a classroom so here we
have the mean sum of the marks of the
students total number of students and as
we talked about the median
if we have
0 through 10
and we take half the numbers and put
them on one side of the line half the
numbers on the other side of the line
we end up with 5 in the middle and then
the mode what mark was scored by most of
the students in a test
in a simple case where most people
scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out
not so easy when you have different
areas where like you have like the um oh
let's go back to economy a little bit
more difficult to calculate if you have
a large group that scores that makes 30
and a slightly bigger group that makes
26 000. so what do you put down for the
mode
uh certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually a
different variations depending on what
you're doing
so now we're looking at a measure of
spread uh range what's the difference
between the highest and the lowest value
first thing you want to look at you know
it's uh we had everybody in the test
score between 60 and 100 percent
somebody got 100 or maybe 60 to 90
percent it was so hard that a lot of
people could not get 100 percent
um you have your
inter-quartile range quartiles divide a
rank ordered data set into four equal
parts
very common thing to do as part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in
data frames with pandas whether you're
working in scala whether you're working
in r
you'll see this come up where they have
range your min your max and then it'll
have your interquartile range how does
it look like in each quarter of data
variance measures how far each number in
the set is from the mean and therefore
from every other number in the set
so you have like a how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation
it is the measure of the variance or the
dispersion of a set of values from the
mean
and you'll usually see if i'm doing a
graph i might have the value graphed
and then based on the the error i might
graph the standard deviation in the
error on the graph as a background so
you can see how far off it is
so standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread marks of a
student out of a hundred we have here
from 50 to 63 or 50 to 90.
so the range maximum marks minimum marks
we have 90 to 45 and the spread of that
is 45 90 minus 45. and then we have the
interquartile range using the same marks
over there you can see here where the
median is and then there's the first
quarter the second quarter and the third
quarter based on splitting it apart by
those values
and to understand the variance and
standard deviation we first need to find
out the mean
so here's our you know calculating the
average there we end up approximately 66
for the average and then we look at that
the variance once we know the means we
can do equals the marks minus the mean
squared
why is it squared
because one you want to make sure it's
you don't have like if you if you're
putting all this stuff together you end
up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower
uh so you always see
the squared value and over the total
observations and so the standard
deviation equals the square root of the
variance which is approximately 16.
and if you were looking at
a predictable model you would be looking
at the deviation based on the error how
much error does it have
uh and that's again
really important to know if your if your
prediction is predicting something
what's the chance of it being way off or
just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the
tools as far as some of the basics for
doing your statistics and what we're
talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
python code
so you can get some little hands-on here
for that let's go back into our jupiter
notebook in python now almost all of
this you can do in numpy last time we
worked in numpy this time we're going to
go ahead and use pandas and if you
remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print
df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name jane
michael william rosie hannah sat on
their salaries on here and of course
instead of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total
we can do something very simple on this
like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
i go and do this print df
pick our column salary because we want
to find the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
and we go and print this out and you can
see that the
average income on here is 71 000.
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in
means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is
very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are they use the
two different words
there can be in some computation slight
differences but for the most part the
means is the average
and then the median
oops just put a
median here
do you have salary that way it displays
a little better we can see the median is
000. so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average
why because we have somebody in here
makes 189 thousand
darn you rosie for throwing off our
numbers
but that's something you'd want to
notice this is this is the difference
between these is huge and so is what is
the meaning behind that when you're
studying a populist and looking at
the different data coming in and of
course we also want to find out hey
what's the most uh common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at 50 000.
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making fifty thousand
the middle point is at fifty four
thousand so half the people are making
more than that
what that tells me is that if the most
common income is weight is below the
median
then
there's a few there's a scale there's a
lot of high salaries going up but
there's some really low salaries in
there
and so this trend which is very common
in statistics when you're analyzing
the economy in different people's income
is pretty common and the bigger
difference between these is also
very important when we're studying
statistics
and when you hear someone just say hey
the average income was you might start
asking questions at that point why
aren't you talking about the median
income why aren't you talking about the
mode the most common income what are you
hiding
uh and if you're doing these analysis
you should be looking at these saying
hey why are these discrepancies why are
these so different and of course with
any analysis it's important to find out
the minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply
dot min
i'll pull up your minimum and then dot
max pulls up the maximum
pretty straightforward on as far as um
translating it and knowing which you
know what the your lowest value which
your highest value is here
which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on no
mode uh note that it puts mode 0. like i
said there's a couple different ways you
can compute the mode
um although the standard one is pretty
good we can of course do the range which
is your max minus your min so now we
have a range of 149 000 between the
upper end and the lower end and you
might want to be looking at the
individual values on all of these but it
turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do df
salary describe and if we do this you
can see we have that there's seven
setups here's our mean
our standard deviation which we didn't
compute yet which would just be a dot
std
and you got to be a little careful
because when it computes it it looks for
axes and things like that
we have our minimum value and here's our
quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary uh so these are the these
are the basic statistics you can pull
them up and like just describe
this is a dictionary so i could actually
do something like um
in here i could actually go uh count and
run
and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information and
then split it up and depending on what
you need now if i just walked in and
gave you this information
in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep
that's what i would do anyway
so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here and we'll go ahead and
put it into a histogram and plot that
graph on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so
we do our map plot inline remember
that's a jupiter's notebook thing
a lot of the new version of the matplot
library does it automatically
but just in case i always put it in
there import matplot library pi plot is
plt that's my plotting
and then we have our data frame i don't
i guess i really don't need to respel
the data frame
maybe we could just remind ourselves
what's in it so we'll go ahead and just
print
df
that way we still have it
and then we have our salary df salary
salary.plot history title salary
distribution color gray
plot ax v line salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet
line style dash this is just all making
it pretty
what color dashed line line width of 2
that kind of thing
and the median and let's go ahead and
run this just so you can see we're
talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
um so here's the data here's our our
data frame print it out so you can see
it with the salaries we'll look at the
salary distribution and just look at
this the way the salary is distributed
you have our
in this case we did
let's see we had red for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean
and you can just see how it really
i mean here's our outlier here's our
person who makes a lot of money here's
the um average and here's the median um
and so as you look at this you can say
wow
based on the average it really doesn't
tell you much about what people are
really taking home all it does is tell
you how much money is in this you know
what the average salary is
so
some of the things you want to take away
in addition to this is that it's very
easy to plot um
an ax v line
these are these up and down lines for
your markers
and as you just display the data i mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated keeping it
simple is pretty straightforward i look
at this and i can see we have a major
outlier out here we can definitely do a
histogram and stuff like that
but you know pictures worth a thousand
words
what you really want to make sure you
take away is that we can do a basic
describe
which pulls all this information out and
we can print any of the individual
information from the describe
because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
um the mean value we can also do
describe mean so if you're doing a lot
of statistics
being able to
doesn't have the print on there so it's
only going to print the last one which
happens to be the mean
you can very easily reference any one of
these and then you can also if you're
doing something a little bit more
complicated and you don't need just the
basics you can come through and pull any
one of the individual
references from the from the pandas on
here so now we've had a chance to
describe our data
let's get into inferential statistics
inferential statistics allows you to
make predictions or inferences from data
and you can see here we have a nice
little picture movie ratings and
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in this study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked
35 chance of saying disliked or a 10 or
11 chance of can't say so that's real
basics of what we're talking about is
you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics
so let's look at point estimation
it is a process of finding an
approximate value for a population's
parameter like mean
or average from random samples of the
population
let's take an example of testing
vaccines for covid19
vaccines and flu bugs all that it's a
pretty big thing of how do you test
these out and make sure they're going to
work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population so here's a protected there's
our small group up here where we've
selected them we run medical trials on
them and then the results work for the
population
nice diagram with the arrows going back
and forth and the very scary coveted
virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very central is what they call
hypotheses testing
and the confidence interval which go
with that and then as we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem
hypothesis testing hypothesis testing is
used to measure the plausibility of a
hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now
when we talk about theorems
theory
hypothesis
keep in mind that if you are in a
philosophy class
theory
is the same as hypothesis where theorem
is a scientific
statement that is something that has
been proven
although it is always up for debate
because in science we always want to
make sure things are up to debate so
hypothesis is the same as a
philosophical class calling a theory
where theory in science is not the same
theory in science says this has been
well proven gravity is a theory
so if you want to debate the theory of
gravity try jumping up and down if you
want to have a theory about why the
economy is collapsing in your area
that is a philosophical debate
very important i've heard people mix
those up and it is a pet peeve of mine
when we talk about hypotheses testing
the steps involved in hypotheses testing
is first we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test and we
make a decision and so when you're
talking about hypothesis you're usually
trying to disprove it if you can't
disprove it
and it works for all the facts then you
might call that a theorem at some point
so in a use case uh let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day
rob took the opportunity to make chits
and wrote everyone's name on it so
here's our four people nick rob emlia
imlia and
summer now rick emilia and summer are
asking us to decide whether rob has done
some mischief in preparing the chits i.e
whether rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of rob getting the cleaning
job on first day second day third day
and so on till 12 days
the probability of rob getting the job
decreases every day ie his turn never
comes up then definitely he has done
some mischief while making the chits
so the probability of rob not doing work
on day one is uh three out of four
there's a point 75 chance that he didn't
do work
two days three-fourths times
three-fourths equals 0.56
three days you have three fourths three
fourths three fourths which equals point
four two
uh when you get to day twelve it's 0.032
which is less than 0.05
remember this 0.05 that comes up a lot
when we're talking about
certain values when we're looking at
statistics
rob is cheating as he wasn't chosen for
12 consecutive days that's a very high
probability when
on day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room so we come up to our
important important terminologies
we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomena or no association
among the groups
alternative hypothesis
contrary to the null hypothesis it
states whenever something is happening a
new theory is preferred instead of an
old one and so the two hypotheses go
hand in hand uh so your null this is
always interesting in and when talking
about data science and the math behind
it
it's about proving that the things have
no correlation null hypothesis says
these two have zero relation to each
other where the alternative hypothesis
says hey we found a relation this is
what it is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of finding the observed or
more extreme results when the null
hypothesis of a study question is true
and the t value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of t the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the t values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p value is derived from your t
value and you're looking for what they
call the five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so
digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug
and this is a good one because the null
value here isn't that you don't have any
drug the null value here is that it's
better than the existing drug the new
drug doesn't lower the blood pressure
more than the existing drug
now if we get that
that says our null hypothesis is correct
there is no correlation and the new drug
is not doing its job the alternative
hypothesis the new drug does
significantly lower the blood pressure
more than the existing drug
yay we got a new drug out there and
that's our alternative hypothesis or the
h1 or ha
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trial showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for
a 0.05 or 5 percent and the t value
comparing all the positive test results
and finding means of different samples
in order to test hypothesis so this is
specific to the test how what percentage
of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals
a confidence interval is a range of
values we are sure our true values of
observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food hence we can say that we
have a confidence interval of 2 300
where 95 percent of our values lie in
that data spread and this the graph
really helps a lot so you can start
seeing what you're looking at here we
have the 95 percent you have your peak
in this case it's a normal distributions
here the nice bell curve equal on both
sides it's not asymmetrical and 95 of
all the values lie within a very small
range and then you have your outliers
the 2.5 percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis uh we're
going to move into probability uh so you
have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
certainty can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence
score prediction how good you're going
to do in whatever
sport you're in weather prediction stock
prediction
if you've studied physics and chaos
theory even the location of the chair
you're sitting on has a probability that
it might move three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh i think we calculated as under one in
trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability
that we don't see them so we talk about
random variable a random variable is a
variable whose possible values are
numerical outcomes of a random phenomena
so uh we have the coin tossed how many
heads will occur in the series of 20
coin flips probably you know the on
average they're 10 but you really can't
know because it's very random how many
times a red ball is picked from a bag of
balls if there's equal number of red
balls and blue balls and green balls in
there how many times the sum of digits
on two dice
results are five each
so you know there's how often you're
gonna roll two fives on your pair of
dice
so in a use case uh let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice
and instead of looking at how many times
both dice for roll five let's go ahead
and look at a total sum of five and you
have in as far as your random variables
you can have a one four equals five four
one two three three two
so four of those rolls can be four if
you look at all the different options
you have four of those random rolls can
be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
uh you can see that we have 4 out of 36
chance every time you roll the dice that
you're gonna roll a total of five you
can have an outcome of five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating
we'll look a little closer at the math
behind that but let's just consider this
is one of the cases is rolling two dice
and gambling
there's also a binomial distribution it
is the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial so passing or failing an exam
winning or losing a game and getting
either head or tails so if you ever see
binomial distribution it's based on a
true false kind of setup you win or lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of football between
two clubs
barcelona and dortmund the teams will
have to play a total of four matches and
we have to find out the chances of
barcelona winning the series so we look
at the total games and we're looking at
five different games or matches
let's say that the winning chance for
barcelona is 75 percent or 0.75
that means that each game they have a 75
chance that they're going to win that
game and losing chances are 25 or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals 1. so that
accounts for 100 of the game probability
for getting k wins in in matches is
calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games and you want to know if i
play um how many wins in those five
games should i get what's a percentage
on those and the probability for getting
k wins and in matches is calculated by p
x equals k equals n c k p to the k q to
the n minus k
here p is the probability of success and
q is the probability of failure and so
we can do total games of n equals five
where k equals zero one two three four
five
p which is the chance of winning is
point 0.75 q the chance of losing equals
1 minus p
which equals 1 minus 0.075 which equals
0.25 the probability that barcelona will
lose all of the matches can then just
plug in the numbers
and we end up with a point zero zero
zero nine seven six five six two five so
very small chance they're going to lose
all their matches
and we can plug in uh the value for two
matches probability that barcelona
will win at least two matches is
0.0878 and of course we can go on to the
probability that barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and of course
four matches and so on and it's always
nice to take this information
and let's find the accumulated discrete
probabilities for each of the outcomes
where barcelona has won three or more
matches x equals three x equals four x
equals five
and we end up with the p equals 0.264
plus 0.395 plus 237 which equals 0.89
in reality
the probability of barcelona winning the
series is much higher than 0.75
and it's always nice to
put out a nice graph so you can actually
see the number of wins to the
probability and how that pans out
with our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean value and
this is some very important things so
much of the data we look at and when you
start looking at probabilities almost
always has a normalized look like the
graph in the middle but you do have left
skewed where the data is skewed off to
the left and you have more stuff
happening off to the left and you have
right skewed data
and so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that
mostly you end up with a normalized set
of data but you got to also be aware
that sometimes it's a skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice peak
and so being aware of this that you
might have a probability that fits
certain data but it has a lot of
outliers so you're if you have a really
high standard deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money
where if you have a very small deviation
you might be right on target and set to
become a millionaire
which leads us to the z-score z-score
tells you how far from the mean a data
point is it is measured in terms of
standard deviations from the mean around
68 percent of the results are found
between one standard deviation
around 95 percent of the results are
found between two standard deviations
and you read the symbols of course they
love to throw some greek letters in
there we have a mu minus two sigma mu is
just a quick way it's a kind of funky u
it just means the mean
uh and then the sigma is the standard
deviation and that's the o with the
little arrow off to the right or the
little
wagy tail going up the o with it with
the line on it
so mu minus two sigma
is your
uh 95 percent of the results are found
between two standard deviations
central limit theorem
this goes back to the skew if you
remember we were looking at the skew
values on this previous slide have left
skewed normalized and right skewed when
we're talking about it being skewed or
not skewed the distribution of the
sample means will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed
if you take large random samples from
the population with the mean mu and the
standard deviation sigma with
replacement and you can see here
of course we have our
mu minus two sigma and the spread down
here the mean the median and the mode
and so you're talking about very large
populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from
and the math behind it
if we're going to do all this we got to
jump into conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is the probability that the event will
occur
given the knowledge that an event b has
already occurred
and you'll see this as bayes theorem
b-a-y-e-s base
and this is red
i mean you have these funky looking
little
p
brackets a b
this is the probability of a being true
while b is already true
and you have the probability of b being
true when a is already true so p b of a
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of b being true
and we talk about bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do
x y equals j k and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math but it works with probabilities
which makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
eight or nine different studies going on
in different areas different people have
done the studies they brought them
together
if we look at today's covered virus the
virus spread
certainly the studies done in china
versus the studies the way they're done
in the u.s
that data is different in each of those
studies but if you can find a place
where it overlaps
where they're studying the same thing
together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of
one group and you want to find out more
about it so this formula is very
powerful and it really has to do with
the data collection part of the math and
data science and understanding where
your data is coming from and how you
going to combine different studies in
different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease due to smoking
and this is kind of interesting the way
they word this
let's say that according to medical
report provided by the hospital states
that around 10 percent of all patients
they treated suffered lung disease
so we have kind of a generic medical
report
they further found out
by a survey that fifteen percent of the
patients that visit them smoke
so we have ten percent that are lung
disease and um fifteen percent of the
patients smoke
and finally five percent of the people
continued smoke even when they had lung
disease uh not the brightest choice
but you know it is an addiction so it
can be really difficult to kick and so
we can look at the probability of a uh
prior probability of 10 people having
lung disease and then probability b
probability that a patient smokes is 15
percent
uh and the probability of b
if b then a the probability of a patient
smokes even though they have lung
disease is five percent
and probability of a is b probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together uh you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a of b probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 percent chance
hence there is a 3.33 chance that a
person who smokes will get a lung
disease
so we're going to pull up a little
python code i'm always my favorite roll
up the sleeves
keep in mind we're going to be doing
this
kind of like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create um
we'll get into another demo which shows
you some of the tools that are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set so we're
going to create a set with curly braces
this means that our set has
only unique values so you have a list
you have your tuples which can never
change and then you have
in this case the the set so four seven
you can't create a four seven comma four
it'll delete the four out so it's only
unique values
and if you use dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary where you
have a value and that value is assigned
to or that key is assigned to a value
so you could have a key value set up as
a dictionary so it's like a dictionary
without the value it's just the keys and
they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a
set of four seven
we can also take a list a regular
setup and i'm going to go ahead and just
throw in another number in here four
and run it
and you can see here if i take my list
one two three four four
and i convert it to a set
and here it is my set from list equals
set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and
print here is my set my set
uh three is in the set and then if you
do three in my set
that's going to be a logic function
uh and one in my set six is not in the
set and so forth if we run this
we get three is in the set true
one is in the set false because three
five seven is another one six is in the
set uh six is not in the set so not in
my set
you can also use this with the list we
could have just used three five seven
and it would have um the same response
on there is three and usually you do if
three is in but three in my set is still
works on just a regular list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember
one two three four five six and so we're
going to bring in the iteration tool and
import product as product
and i'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values
you can only have one value for each one
that's why they put it in a set and if
you remember from range it is up to
seven so this is going to be one two
three four five six
it will not include the seven and the
same thing for our dice b
and then we're gonna do is we're gonna
create a list
which is the product
of a and b so what's a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see
in this case when they say product
because it's an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two so we've now created a tuple of
all possible outcomes of the dice where
dice a is
one two three one to six and dice b is
one to six and you can see one to one
one to two one to three and so forth
you remember we had a slide on this
earlier where we talked about
the different all the different outcomes
of a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit we can do in dice equals two
dice faces one two three four five six
another way of doing we did before and
then we can create an event space where
we have a set which is the product of
the dice faces
repeat equals in dice and we'll go and
just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here and print them all out like
we had before
we can just go through for outcome and
event space outcome and equals
so the event space is creating
a sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it stacks them versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something um
let's go print
since we have the end printing with a
comma that just means it's just gonna
it's not gonna hit the return going down
to the next line
uh and we'll go ahead and do the links
of our event space that'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course if i get carried away with
my typing of length uh we'll print it
twice and it'll give me an error
so we have 36 different possible
variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like
what about the multiple of 3 what if we
want to have
the probability of the multiple three in
our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space of x y
equals outcome
if x plus y
remainder 3. so we're going to divide by
3 and look at the remainder and it
equals 0.
then it's a favorable outcome we're
going to pop that outcome on the in
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set not necessary
because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of three one plus two is three
five plus four is nine which divided by
three is three and so forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length
of our
f outcome
so we can see what that looks like
there we go
and of course i did forget to add the
print in the middle because we're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if i run
this you can see um
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of three
and we can easily conv compute the
probability of this
by simply taking the length
of our favorable outcome over the length
of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there
probability
last line so we just type it in we end
up with a 0.3333 chance
that's roughly a third
and we want to make this look nice so
let's go ahead and put in another line
there the probability of getting the sum
which is a multiple of three is
point three three three three
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it
you can see we just have a huge amount
of choices
so it just goes on and on down here and
we can look at
the length of the event space
and we have over
7776 choices that's a lot of choices
and if we want to ask the question like
we did above uh
what is the sum where the sum is a
multiple of five but not a multiple of
three
we can go through all of these different
options and then uh you can see here uh
d1 d2 d3 d4 d5 equals the outcome
and if you add these all together and
the
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero
but the remainder is also of a division
by three is not equal to zero
so the multiple of five is equal to zero
but the multiple three is not we can
just append that on here and then we can
look at that uh favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
6 and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll
a multiple of 5 when you add them
together
but not a multiple of 3.
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
0.11625 or 11.62 percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated math
right here on probabilities
it's just how many options do you have
and how many of those are you possibly
going to be able to come up with with
the solution you're looking for
and this leads us to a confusion matrix
a confusion matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the true values are known
and so you'll see in the left we have
the predicted and the actual
and we have a negative uh false negative
positive true positive
um and then we have false positive and
true negative and you can think of this
as your predicted model what does that
mean that means if you divided your data
and you used two-third of it to create
the model
you might then test it against an actual
case for the last third to see how well
it comes out how many times was it
true positive versus
false positive it gave a false positive
response
and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal you
don't want to give a false positive so
you might adjust your model accordingly
so you don't have a false positive say
with a covavirus test it'd be better to
have a false negative and they go back
and get retested than to have 30 false
positives where then the test is pretty
much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision
actual result of a person's medical
report is compared with the prediction
made by the machine learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a
false positive i mean a false negative
in other words you don't want to have it
tell you that you don't have cancer when
you do so that would be something you'd
really be looking for in this particular
domain you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in there's a real famous case
study where they have the imagery and
all the measurements they take and
there's about 36 different measurements
they take
and then if you run the
a basic model you want to know just how
accurate it is how many negative results
do you have that are either telling
people they have cancer that don't or
telling people that don't have cancer
that they do and then we can take these
numbers and we can feed them into our
accuracy our precision and our recall
so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your total um true where you
got the right results you add them
together the true positive the two
negative
over all the results so what percentage
of them were accurate versus what were
wrong
we talked about precision is a metric to
measure how many of the correctly
predicted cases are actually turned out
to be positive
uh so we have a precision on true
positive
again if you're talking about like covid
testing with the viruses uh you really
want this to be a high number you want
this true
that to be the center point where you
might have the opposite if you're
dealing with a cancer where you want no
false negatives
so this is your metric on here precision
is your test positive
true positive plus
false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model
uh so test positive is the test positive
plus the
false negative on there and we'll want
to go ahead and do a demo on the naive
bayes classifier before i get too far
into a naive bayes classifier because
we're going to pull it from the sk learn
or the scikit
let's go ahead kind of an interesting
page here for classifiers when you go
into the sk learn kit there's a lot of
ways to do classification and i'll just
zoom up in here so you can see some of
the titles
there's everything from the nearest
neighbor linear
but we're going to be focusing on the
naive bayes over here
and this is just a sample data set that
they put together and you can see how
some of these have a very different
output
the naive bayes remember is set up as
probably the most simplified uh
calculator or set of predictions out
there
and so what we've been talking about
with the true false and stuff like that
where there's a
and then a belief that there is a
independent assumption between the
features where the features are very
assumed to have some kind of connection
uh then we can go ahead and use that for
the prediction and so that's what we're
using is a naive bayes classifier versus
many of the other classifiers that are
out there
for this we're going to use the social
network ads it's a little data set on
here
and let me go and just open that up the
file
here we go it has user id gender age
estimated salary uh purchased
and so we have you can see the user id
mail 19
estimated salary 19 000
and purchase zero so it's either gonna
make a purchase or not
so look at that last one zero one we
should be thinking of binomials we
should be thinking of a simple naive
bayes classifier kind of setup
so if we close this out we're going to
go ahead and import our numpy as np
we're going to nice to have a good
visual of our data so we'll put in our
matplot library
here's our pandas our data frame
uh and then we're going to go ahead and
import the data set and the data set's
going to be we're going to read it from
the social network ads.csv then we're
going to print the head just so you can
see it again
even though i showed you it in the file
and x equals the data set i location
two three values and y is going to be
the 4 column 4. let me just run this
it's a little easier to go over that
you can see right here we're going to be
looking at
0 1 2 as age
and estimated salary so 2 3
and that's what i location just means
that we're
looking at the number versus a regular
location a regular location you'd
actually say age and estimated salary
and then column four is did they make a
purchase they purchased something
uh so those are the three columns we're
going to be looking at when we do this
and we've gone ahead and imported these
and
imported the data so now our data set is
all set with this information in it
and we'll need to go ahead and split the
date up so we need our from the sk learn
model selection we can import train test
split
this does a nice job we can set the
random state so randomly picks the data
and we're just going to take uh 25 of
it's going to go into the test our x
test and our y test and the 75 will go
to x train and y train
that way once we
create our model we can then have data
to see just how accurate or how well it
has performed with our prediction
the next step in pre-processing our data
is to go ahead and do feature scaling
now a lot of this to start to look
familiar if you've done a number of the
other modules and setup you should start
noticing that we
bring in our data we take a look at what
we're working with
we go ahead and split it up into
training and testing
in this case we're going to go ahead and
scale it scale it means we're putting it
between a value of minus one and one
uh or someplace in the middle ground
there
this way if you have any huge set you
don't have this huge
setup if we go back up to here where
salary the salary is
20 000 versus age 35.
well there's a good chance with a lot of
the back end math that 20 000 will skew
the results and the estimated salary
will have a higher impact than the age
instead of balancing them out and
letting the calculations weigh them
properly
and finally we get to actually create
our naive bayes model
um and then we're going to go ahead and
import the gaussian naive bayes
and the gaussian is is the most basic
one that's what we're looking at now it
turns out though if you go to the sk
learn kit
they have a number of different ones you
can pull in there there's a
bernoulli i've never used that one
categorical
complement and here's our gaussian
so there's a number of different options
you can look at
gaussian when you come to the naive
bayes is the most commonly used
so we're talking about the naive bayes
that's usually what people are talking
about when they when they're pulling
this in
and one of the nice things about the
gaussian if you go to their website
to sk learn the naive bayes gaussian
there's a lot of cool features one of
them is you can do partial fit on here
that means if you have a huge amount of
data you don't have to process it all i
want you once you can batch it into the
gaussian nb model and there's many other
different things you can do with it as
far as fitting the data and how you
manipulate it
we're just doing the basics so we're
going to go ahead and create our
classifier we're going to equal the
gaussian in b
and then we're going to do a fit we're
going to fit our training data and our
training solution so x train y train
and we'll go ahead and run this and it's
going to tell us that it ran the code
right there
and now we have our trained classifier
model
so the next step is we need to go ahead
and run a prediction we're going to do
our y predict equals the
classifier.predict
x test so here we fit the data and now
we're going to go ahead and predict
and now we get to our confusion matrix
so from
the sk learn matrix metrics you can
import your confusion matrix
just as saves you from doing all the
simple math that does it all for you
and then we'll go ahead and create our
confusion metrics with the y test and
the y predict so we have our actual
and we have our predicted value
and you can see from here this is the
chart we looked at here's predicted so
true positive false positive false
negative true negative
and if we go ahead and run this there we
have it 65 3 7 25
and in this particular prediction we had
65 or predicted the truth as far as a
purchase they're gonna make a purchase
and we guessed three wrong
and then we had 25 we predicted would
not purchase and seven of them did so
there's our our confusion matrix
at this point if you were with your
shareholders or a board meeting um you
would start to hear some snoozing if
they were looking at the numbers and you
say hey here's my confusion
matrix
so let's go ahead and visualize the
results
we're going to pull from the matplot
library colors import listed color map
and this is actually my machine is going
to throw an error because
this is being
because of the way the setup is i have a
newer version on here than when they put
together the demo
and we need our x set and our y set
which is our x train and y train
and then we'll create our x1 x2
and we'll put that into a grid
and we set our x at minimum stop and our
x at max stop
and if you come all the way over here
we're going to step .01 this is going to
give us a nice line uh is what that's
doing and then we're going to plot the
contour
plot the x limit plot the y limit
and put the scatter plot in there let's
go ahead and run this uh to be honest
when i'm doing these graphs there's so
many different ways to do that there's
so many different ways to put this code
together
to show you what we're doing it's a lot
easier to pull up the graph and then go
back up and explain it
so the first thing we want to note here
when we're looking at the data
is this is the training set
and so we have those who didn't make a
purchase we've drawn a nice area for
that
that's defined by the naive bayes setup
and then we have those who did make a
purchase the green and you can see that
some of the green drops fall into the
red area and some of the red dots fall
into the green
so even our training set isn't going to
be a hundred percent
we couldn't do that
and so we're looking at our different
data coming down
uh we can kind of arrange our x1 x2 so
we have a nice plot going on and we're
going to create the
contour
that's that nice line that's drawing
down the middle on here with the red
green
that's where that's what this is doing
right here with the reshape and notice
that we had to
do the dot t if you remember from numpy
if you did the numpy module
you end up with pairs you know x
x1 x2 x1 x2 next row and so forth you
have to flip it so it's all one row you
have all your x1 and all your x2s
so that's what we're kind of looking for
right here on this setup
and then the scatter plot is of course
your scattered data across there we're
just going through all the points that
puts these nice little dots on to our
setup on here and we have our estimated
salary and our h and then of course the
dots are did they make a purchase or not
and just a quick note this is kind of
funny you can see up here where it says
x set y set equals x train y train which
seems kind of a little weird to do
this is because this is probably
originally a definition uh so it was its
own module that could be called over and
over again and which is really a good
way to do it because the next thing
we're going to want to do is do the
exact same thing
but we're going to visualize the test
set results
that way we can see what happened with
our test group our 25 percent
and you can see down here we have the
test set
and it
if you look at the two
graphs next to each other this one
obviously has
75 percent of the data so it's going to
show a lot more
this is only 25 of the data you can see
that there's a number that are kind of
on the edge as to whether they could
guess by age and income they're going to
make a purchase or not
but that said it still is pretty clear
it's pretty good as far as how much the
estimate is and how good it does
now
graphs are really effective
for showing people what's going on but
you also need to have the numbers and so
we're going to do from sklearn we're
going to import metrics
and then we're going to print our
metrics classification port from the y
test and the y predict
and you can see here we have precision
precision of zeros is 90 there's our
recall
0.96 we have an f1 score and a support
and we have our precision the recall on
getting it right
and then we can do our accuracy the
macro average and the weighted average
so you can see it it pulls in
pretty good as far as how accurate it is
you could say it's going to be about 90
percent is going to guess correctly
that that they're not going to purchase
and we had an 89 chance that they are
going to purchase
and then the other numbers as you get
down
have a little bit different meaning but
it's pretty straightforward on here
here's our accuracy
and here's our micro average and the
weighted average and everything else you
might need and if you forgot the exact
definition of accuracy
it is the
true positive true negative over all of
the different setups
precision is your true positive over all
positives true and false
and recall is a true positive over true
positive plus false negative
and we can just real quick flip back
there
so you can see those numbers on here uh
here's our precision here's our recall
and here's our accuracy on this
we're going to cover reinforcement
learning today and what's in it for you
we'll start with why reinforcement
learning we'll look at what is
reinforcement learning
we'll see what the different kinds of
learning strategies are that are being
used today in computer models under
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement
we'll cover important terms specific to
reinforcement learning
we'll talk about markov's decision
process and we'll take a look at a
reinforcement learning example well
we'll teach a tic-tac-toe how to play
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us
further the data provided might not be
reliable learning from a small subset of
actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if i'm taking one
step forward and left
what happens if i pick up a 50-pound
object how does that change how a robot
would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here learned how to walk
this is going to slow the growth that
technology is capable of machines need
to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climate
mountain
real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment and we can
adjust for it and kind of explore and
play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well there's a couple of them that
can be used or integrated to see how it
goes
is what we're talking about with
reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is a sub-branch of machine
learning that trains the model to return
an optimum solution for a problem by
taking a sequence of decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another the robot is given a
scenario must arrive at a solution by
itself the robot can take different
paths to reach the destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important is we're
looking for unique solutions
we want the best solution but you can't
find it unless you try it
so we're looking at
our different
systems our different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks
there's all kinds of things in between
decision trees
the data provided is labeled data with
output values specified
and this is important because we talk
about supervised learning you already
know the answer for all this information
you already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so you're supervised
learning you already know that
the outcome for tomorrow for you know
going back a week you're looking at
stock you can already have like the
graph of what the next day looks like so
you have an answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves problems by mapping labeled input
to known output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and unsupervised
learning is really interesting because
it's now taking part in many other
models they start with and you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning as part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions
used to solve association with
clustering problems unlabeled data is
used no supervision solves problems by
understanding patterns and discovering
output
so you can look at this and you can
think
some of these things go with each other
they belong together so it's looking for
what connects in different ways and
there's a lot of different algorithms
that look at this
when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up
of what unsupervised learning is how it
can pick out say
the area of a donut
one model will see the area of the donut
and the other one will divide it into
three sections based on this location
versus what's next to it so there's a
lot of stuff that goes in with
unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market in machine learning or
growing market it's very it's very
infant stage
as far as how it works and what's going
to be capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors used to solve
reward based problems
no predefined data is used no
supervision
follows trail and error problem solving
approach
so again we have a random first you
start with a random i try this it
works and this is my reward doesn't work
very well maybe or maybe doesn't even
get you where you're trying to get it to
do and you get your reward back and then
it looks at that and says well let's try
something else
and it starts to play with these
different things finding the best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years
so these are really good to know
we have the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual uh entity that has however
you're doing it whether using a neural
network or a
cue table or whatever combination
thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment
the training situation that the model
must optimize to is called its
environment
and you can see here i guess we have a
robot who's trying to get chest full of
gems or whatever and that's the output
and then you have your action this is
all possible steps that can be taken by
the model and it picks one action and
you can see here it's picked three
different routes to get to the chest of
diamonds and gems
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this uh if you're
playing like a video game
this is the screen you're looking at so
when you go back here
the environment is a whole
game board so if you're playing one of
those mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on uh but then you have your
current position where are you on that
game board what's around that what's
around you
if you were talking about a robot
the environment might be moving around
the yard
where it is in the yard and what it can
see what input it has in that location
that would be the current position
condition returned by the model and then
the reward uh to help the model move in
the right direction it is rewarded
points are given to it to appraise some
kind of action
so yeah you did good or didn't do as
good trying to maximize the reward and
have the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
state
this is part of the model what what is
your action that you're you're going to
take what's the policy you're using to
have an output from your agent
one of the reasons they separate
policy as its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options
and then the policy well how am i going
to pick the best based on those
predictions i'm going to guess at
different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works
let's go ahead and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog
that we want to train
so the dog would be like the agent so
you have your your puppy or whatever
and then your environment is going to be
the whole house or whatever it is where
you're training them and then you have
an action we want to teach the dog to
fetch
so action equals fetching
and then we have a little biscuit so we
can get the dog to perform various
actions by offering incentives such as a
dog biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself
uh so you have b you know so we start
off with fetching it goes oh i get a
biscuit for that it tries something else
you get a handshake or begging or
something like that and it goes oh this
is also reward based and so it kind of
explores things to find out what will
bring is biscuit
and that's very much like how a
reinforced model goes as it
looks for different rewards how do i
find can i try different things and find
a reward that works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explorer's environment
this quality of model is called
exploration so there's a little
randomness going on in exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
markov's decision process is a
reinforcement learning policy used to
map a current state to an action where
the agent continuously interacts with
the environment to produce new solutions
and receive rewards
and you'll see here's all of our
different uh
vocabulary we just went over we have a
reward our state our agent our
environment interaction and so even
though the environment kind of contains
everything
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment is
going to put out a reward in state that
goes into the agent
the agent then looks at this state or it
looks at the reward usually
first and it says okay i got rewarded
for whatever i just did or it didn't get
rewarded
and it looks at the state
and then it comes back and if you
remember from
policy the policy comes in
and then we have a reward the policy is
that part that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and says
hey
what's a good action that will probably
be similar to what i did or
sometimes they're completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today
and so a lot of them actually have
templates
based on this you can pull in and start
using
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works
uh you can see your environment
sends it says hey this is the agent did
this if you're a character in a game
this happened and it shoots out a reward
in a state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says i'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment it affects the
environment the environment then changes
depending on what the action was
and then it has a new state and a new
reward that goes back to the agent
so in the diagram shown we need to find
the shortest path between node a and d
each path has a reward associated with
it and the path with a maximum reward is
what we want to choose
the nodes a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node
a to b
is an action reward is a cost of each
path and policy is each path taken
and you can see here a can go to b
or a can go to c right off the bat or
can go right to d
and if explored all three of these
you would find that a going to d was a
zero reward
a going to c and d would generate a
different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here
and so when we start looking at this
diagram you start to realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see
and so they take up a lot of work uh or
a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems
and we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in the tic-tac-toe game
but you can see here uh once it's gone
through these and it's explored it's
gonna find the a c d
is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
reinforcement learning
demo
in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe game you will be playing
this game against the machine learning
model
and we'll go ahead and we're doing it in
python so let's go ahead and go through
i always not always actually have a lot
of python tools let's go through
anaconda which will open up a jupiter
notebook it seems like a lot of steps
but it's worth it to keep all my stuff
separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the jupiter
notebook for doing python
so here's our anaconda navigator i open
up the notebook which is going to take
me to a webpage and i've gone in here
and created a new python folder in this
case i've already done it and enabled it
to change the name to tic-tac-toe and
then for this example we're going to go
ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then pickle is just a
nice way sometimes for
storing different information different
states that we're going to go through on
here
and so
we're going to create a class called
state we're going to start with that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here
don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here
it looks like there's going to be a lie
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class state
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it um
we have our board
it's a tic tac toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board
uh we have player one player two
uh is end we're gonna create a board
hash
uh we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just gonna store some information
in there symbol player equals one
um so there's a few things going on as
far as the initialization
uh then something simple we're just
going to get the hash
of the board you get the information
from the board on there which is columns
and rows we want to know when a winner
occurs uh so if you get three in a row
that's what this whole section here is
for
uh let me go ahead and
scroll up a little bit
and you can get a copy of this code if
you send a note over to simply learn
we'll send you over
this particular file and you can play
with it yourself and see how it's put
together i don't want to spend a huge
amount of time on this because this is
just some real general python coding
but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows
and you add them together and if it
equals three three in a row same thing
with columns
diagonal so you gotta check the diagonal
that's what all this stuff does here is
it just goes through the different areas
actually let me go ahead and put
there we go
um and then it comes down here and we do
our sum and it says true
uh minus three just says did somebody
win
or is it a tie
so you gotta add up all the numbers on
there anyway just in case they're all
filled up
and next we also need to know available
positions um these are ones that don't
no one's ever used before
this way when you try something or the
computer tries something uh it's not
going to give it an illegal move that's
what the available positions is doing
then we want to update our state
and so you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there we
can
pick the row and column in there
and again
i mean this is a lot of code uh so
really it's kind of a thing you'd want
to go through and play with a little bit
and just read through it get a copy of
it a great way to understand how this
works
and here is a given reward um so we're
going to give a reward result equals
self winner
this is one of the hearts of what's
going on here
is we have a result a self.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result that the result equals one here's
our feedback
uh if it doesn't equal one then it gets
a zero so it only gets a reward in this
particular case
if it wins
and that's important to know because
different
systems of reinforced learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example with a
three by three board
imagine if you're playing a video game
certainly you only have so many actions
but your environment is huge you have a
lot going on in the environment and
suddenly a reward system like this
is going to be just
it's going to have to change a little
bit it's going to have to have different
rewards and different setup and there's
all kinds of advanced ways to do that as
far as weighing you add weights to it
and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you actually get a reward in this
case you get the reward at the end of
the game
and i'm spending just a little bit of
time on this this is an important thing
to note but there's different ways to
add up those rewards it might have like
if you take a certain path
the first reward
is going to be weighed a little bit less
than the last reward because the last
reward is actually winning the game or
scoring or whatever it is
so this reward system gets really
complicated in some of the more advanced
setups
in this case though
you can see right here that they give a
0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value so
rewards again that's like key it's huge
how do you
feed the rewards back in
then we have a board reset that's pretty
straightforward it just goes back and
resets the board to the beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things while it's learning
it's going to do it by trial and error
so you have to keep resetting it and
then of course there's the play we want
to go ahead and play rounds equals 100
depends on what you want to do on here
you can set this
different you obviously set that to
higher level but this is just going to
go through and you'll see in here
that we have player 1 and player 2.
this is this is the computer playing
itself
uh one of the more powerful ways to
learn to play a game
or even learn something that isn't a
game is to have two of these models
that are basically trying to beat each
other and so they always they keep
finding explore new things this one
works for this one so this one tries new
things it beats this we've seen this in
um chess i think was a big one where
they had the two players in chess with
reinforcement learning uh it was one of
the ways they trained one of the top
computer chess playing algorithms
uh so this is just what this is it's
going to choose an action it's going to
try something and the more it try stuff
the more we're going to record the hash
we actually have a board hash where they
self get the hash
set up on here where it stores all the
information
and then once you get to a win
one of them wins it gets the reward
uh then we go back and reset and try
again and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is we're going to
play with a human so we'll get a chance
to come in here and see what that looks
like
when you put your own information in
and then it just comes in here and does
the same thing it did above it gives it
a reward for its things
or sees if it wins or ties
looks at available positions all that
fun of fun stuff
and then finally we want to show the
board
so it's going to print the board out
each time
really
as an integration is not that exciting
what's exciting
in here is one looking at this reward
system whoops play one more up the
reward system is really the heart of
this how do you reward the different
setup
and the other one is when it's playing
it's got to take an action
and so
what it chooses for an action is also
the heart of reinforcement learning how
do we choose that action
and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is
in
today's technology is
figuring this out
how do we reward it and how do we guess
the next best action so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state
which is kind of like what's going on
we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
and we want to go ahead and create our
agent on this place our player so each
one is let me go and grab that
until we look at a class player
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state
that it can look at and reward
so we want to take a look at this we
have name
self state this is class player and when
you say class player we're not talking
about a human player we're talking about
just
the computer players
and this is kind of interesting so
remember i told you depending on what
you're doing there's going to be a decay
gamma
explorate
these are what i'm talking about is how
do we train it um
as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one to see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it the 10's gonna count more than the
first step
uh and here's our we're gonna get the
board information coming in and then
choose an action this was the second
part that i was talking about that was
so important
so once you have your training going on
we have to do a little randomness and
you can see right here is our np random
uniform so it's picking out a
random number
take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is
um and so choosing the action
this one you can see we're just doing
random states um choice length of
positions action position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board uh for p in positions
it's actually storing the different
boards each time you go through
so it has a record of what it did so it
can properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash
state what's the last date append it to
the
to our states on here
here's our feedback
rewards the reward comes in and it's
going to take a look at this and say is
it none
what is the reward and here is that
formula remember i was telling you about
up here
that was important because it has
decay gamma times the reward
this is where
as it goes through each step
and this is really important this is
this is kind of the heart of this of
what i was talking about earlier
you have step one
and this might have a reward of two
you have step two i should probably
should have done abc this has a step
three
step four
and so on until you get to step in
and this might have a reward of ten
so reward a ten
we're going to add that but we're not
adding
let's say this one right here
let's say this reward here right before
10 was
um let's say it's also 10 it just makes
the
math easy
so we had 10 and 10. we had 10 this is
10 and 10 n whatever it is but it's time
it's 0.9
uh so instead of putting a full 10 here
we only do 9. that's a
0.9
times
10.
and so this formula
as far as the decay times the reward
minus the cell state value
it basically adds in it says here's one
or here's two i'm sorry i should have
done this abc would have been easier
so the first move goes in here and it
puts two in here
then we have our self
set up on here you can see how this gets
pretty complicated in the math but this
is really the key is how do we train
our states and we want the the final
state the win to get the most points if
you win you get most points
and the first step gets the least amount
of points
so you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now where i
was need to sum up my rewards and i want
to sum them up going in reverse and i
want to find the answer in reverse kind
of an interesting
play on the mind when you're trying to
figure this stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here
save the policy
load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the state
to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that up
and then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human player
and the human player is going to be a
little different
in that
you choose an action row and column
here's your action
if action is
if action in positions meaning positions
that are available
uh you return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it returns
the action up here
and feed forward
again this is because it's a human
at the end of the game bat propagate and
update state values
this part isn't being done because
it's not programming
the model the model is getting its own
rewards
so we've gone ahead and loaded this in
here
so here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up p1 player 1 uh p2 player 2
and then we're going to send our players
to our state so now it has p1 p2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50 000 rounds now we can probably
do a lot less than this and it's not
going to get the full results in fact
you know what uh let's go ahead and just
do five
just to play with it because i want to
show you something here
oops
somewhere in there i forgot to load
something
there we go
i must have forgot to run this run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there's actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning
uh so now i've only set this up
with um
see where we go in here i've only set
this up to train
five times
and the reason i did that is we're going
to
come in and actually play it and then
i'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
there we go and then you make it through
a run and we're going to go ahead and
save the policy
so now we have our player 1 and our
player 2 policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're gonna come in here and
we're gonna do uh player one is gonna be
the computer experience rate zero load
policy one
human player human and we're gonna go
ahead and play this i remember i only
went through it
just one round of training in fact
minimal training and so it puts an x
there and i'm going to go ahead and do
row 0
column 1.
you can see this is very
basic on here
and
so i put in my zero and then i'm going
to go zero block it zero zero
and you can see right here it let me win
uh just like that i was able to win zero
and
human winds
so i only trained it 5 times we're going
to run this again
and this time
instead of 5 let's do 5 000 or 50 000 i
think that's what the guys in the back
had
and this takes a while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart
look how simple this game is we're
talking about a three by three set of
columns
and so for me to train it on this
i could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker
you could build a quick queue table with
almost all the different options on
there
and
you would probably get a the same result
much quicker
we're just using this as an example
so when we look at reinforcement
learning you need to be very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network
where you're doing you set the neural
network to a learning increment of one
so every time it goes through it learns
and then you do your actions you pick
from the learning
uh setup and you actually try actions on
the learning setup until you get the
what you think is going to be the best
action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes i mean that is just
a huge amount of work it's going to do
let's go ahead and skip ahead here give
it a moment it's going to take a
minute or two to go ahead and run
now to train it
we went ahead and let it run and it took
a while this just took
i got a pretty powerful processor and it
took about five minutes plus to run it
and we'll go ahead and
run our player set up on here oops it
brought in the last
whoops i brought in the last round so
give me just a moment to re
do the policy save there we go i forgot
to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for p1
as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner i'm going to go
ahead and go one one which is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you ever played tic-tac-toe you know the
computer has me but we'll go ahead and
play it out
row zero
column two
there it is and then it's gone here and
so i'm going to go ahead and go row zero
one
two no zero one there we go and column
zero
that's where i want it
oh and it says okay you your action
there we go boom uh so you can see here
we've got a didn't catch the win on this
it said tie
kind of funny that didn't catch the win
on there
but if we play this a bunch of times
you'll find it's going to win more and
more the more we train it the more the
reinforcement happens
this lengthy training process
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning
as this changes reinforcement learning
will be one of the more powerful
packages evolving over the next decade
or two
in fact i would even go as far as to say
it is the most important machine
learning tool and artificial
intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple tic tac
toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language
if you're translating a language or
something from one language to the other
so much of it is lost if you don't know
the context it's in what's the
environments it's in and so being able
to attach environment and context and
all those things together is going to
require reinforcement learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the tic tac toe board it's kind of fun
to play with run it you can test it out
you can do
you know test it for different
values you can switch from p1 computer
where we loaded the policy one to load
the policy two and just see how it
varies there's all kinds of things you
can do on there a quick uh recap so
we're going to go back and do a
reinforcement learning recap and you'll
remember we have our agent our action or
environment and our reward
and the state
and so reinforcement learning is a
branch of machine learning that trains a
model to come to an optimum solution for
a problem
by taking decisions by itself
so we look at it we analyze the data
make decisions solve problems
it consists of an environment which an
agent will interact with to learn to
reach a goal or perform an action
and you see here we have the dog
and the action equals fetching
and the first thing
you're going to notice here and i'll
talk a little bit more about this
is that our action is kind of a
singularity uh the action isn't a
regression type model where we're
looking at float numbers
or we're trying to predict something uh
or doing a reinforcement learning where
we're trying to guess the value of the
stock market where you have
five point three three five dollars and
thirty three cents this is very a little
bit different and uh you'll see why q
learning is so powerful but also where
it falls short
uh the agent is also given reward if the
action performed by it is bringing is
closer to the goal is leading to the
goal this is done to train the model in
the right direction we have a reward of
a hopefully a doggy cookie and action
equals fetching so it gets a reward it
gets to go fetch the ball
reinforcement learning can be divided
based on whether the machine uses a
model to learn or learns by itself
so reinforcement learning it's model
based learn the model given model
and you can think of neural networks i
think are the most common right now used
for reinforcement learning there
certainly are a lot of other options out
there
but you have
this black box and you go back and you
send the error back up and it trains it
based on how much of an error the error
could be computed based on maybe a
maximum reward
subtraction or something like that so
the closer you get to
the maximum reward the better
and so we talk about a model free
you have your policy optimization and
your q learning
and
this is kind of the cool thing about q
learning is it can do it's very powerful
on certain things making it very quick
and easy to do a reinforcement learning
so what is q learning q learning is
reinforcement learning policy which will
fill the next best action given a
current state it chooses this action at
random and aims to maximize the reward
and so you can see here's our standard
reinforcement learning graph
by now if you're doing any reinforcement
learning
you should
be familiar with this where you have
your agent your agent takes an action
the action affects the environment
and then the environment sends back the
reward or the feedback and the state
it's the new state the agent's in where
is it at on the chess board where is it
at in the video game
um if your robots out there picking
trash up off the side of the road where
is it at on the road
consider an ad recommendation system
usually when you look up a product
online
you get ads which will suggest the same
product over and over again
using q learning
we can make an ad recommendation system
which will suggest related products to
our previous purchase
the reward will be if user clicks on the
suggested product
and again you can see
you might have a lot of products on your
web advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
hundred people clicking on ads
and you click on one of the ads it might
go in there and say okay this person
clicked on this ad
what is the best set of ads based on
clicking on this ad or these two ads
afterwards based on where they are
browsing
so let's go ahead and look at some
important terms we talk about q learning
we have states the state s represents
the current position of an agent in an
environment
the action the action a is the step
taken by the agent when it is particular
state
rewards for every action the agent will
get a positive or negative reward
and again when we talk about states
we're usually not with when you're using
a q table you're not usually talking
about float variables you're talking
about true false
and we'll take a closer look at that in
a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating state and can't take a new
action
this might be if you're playing a video
game your character stepped in and is
now dead or whatever
q values used to determine how good an
action a taken at a particular state s
is q a of s
and temporal difference a formula used
to find the q value by using the value
of the current state and action and
previous state in action
and various i mean there's bellman's
equation which basically is the equation
that
kind of covers what we just looked at in
all those different terms
the bellman equation is used to
determine the values of a particular
state and deduce how good it is to be in
take that state
the optimus the optimal state will give
us the highest optimal value
factor influencing q values the current
state and action that's your sa so your
current state and your action
then you have your previous date in
action which is your s
i guess prime i'm not sure how how they
reference that s prime a prime so this
is what happened before
uh then you have a reward for action so
you have your r reward and you have your
maximum expected future reward
and you can see there's also a learning
rate put in there and a discount rate
so we're looking at these just like any
other model we don't want to have an
absolute
final value on here we don't want it to
if you do absolute values instead of
taking smaller steps
you don't really have that approach to
the solution you just have it jump and
then pretty soon if you jump one
solution out that's what's going to be
the new solution whichever one jumps up
really high first
kind of ruining the whole idea of doing
a random selection i'll go into the
random selection in just a second steps
in q learning
step one create an initial q table with
all values initialized to zero
again we're looking at
zero one
so are you you know here's our action we
start we're an idol we took a wrong
action we took a correct action and end
and then we have our actions fetching
sitting and running
of course we're just using the dog
example and choose an action and perform
it update values in the table and of
course when we're choosing an action
we're going to kind of do something
random and just randomly pick one so you
start out and you sit and you have then
uh
then depending on that
action you took you can now update the
value for sitting after you start from
start to sitting
get the value of the reward and
calculate the value the value q value
using the bellman equation
and so now we attach a reward to sitting
and we attach all those rewards we
continue the same until the table is
filled with or an episode ends
any and my image is going to come back
to the random side of this and there's a
few different formulas i use for the
random
setup to pick it i usually look whatever
q model i'm using
do their standard one because someone's
usually gone in and done the math
for the optimal
spread
but you can look at this if i have
running has a reward of 10 sitting as a
reward is seven fetching has a reward of
five
um
just kind of without doing like a a
means to you know using the bell curve
for the means value and like i said
there's some math you can put in there
to pick so that you're more like so that
running has even a higher chance
but even if you were just going to do an
average on this
you could do an average a random number
by adding them all together
so you get 10 plus 7 plus 5 is
22 you could do 0 to 22
or 0 to 21 but 1 to 22
1 to 5 would be fetching
and so forth you know the last 10.
so you can just look at this as what
percentage are you going to go for that
particular option
and then that gets your random setup in
there and then as you slowly increment
these up
uh you see that
if your idle where's one here we go
sitting at the end
if you're at the end of wherever you're
at sitting gets a reward of one
where's a good one on here oh wrong
action running for a wrong action gets
almost no reward
so that becomes very very less likely to
happen but it still might happen it
still might have a percentage of coming
up
and that's where the random programming
and q learning comes in the below table
gives us an idea of how many times an
action has been taken and how positively
correct action or negatively wrong
action it is going to affect the next
state
so let's go ahead and dive in and pull
up a little piece of code and see what
this looks like
[Music]
in python
in this demo we'll use q learning to
find the shortest path between two given
points
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
if you've seen my videos before
i like to do it in the
anaconda jupiter notebook
setup just because it's really easy to
see and it's a nice demo
and so here's my anaconda this one i'm
actually using uh python36 environment
that i set up in here
and we'll go ahead and launch the
jupiter notebook on this
and once we're in our jupiter notebook
which has the kernel loaded with python3
we'll go ahead and create a new python3
folder in here
and we'll call this
q
learning
and to start this demo
let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's
imported
and like a lot of these uh model
programs when you're building them you
spend a lot of time putting it all
together
and then you end up with this really
short answer at the end
uh and we'll we'll take a look at that
as we come into it so we go ahead and
start with our location to state uh so
we have
l1 l2 these are our nine locations one
to nine and then of course the state is
going to be 0 1 2 3 4. it's just a
mapping of our location to a integer on
there and then we have our actions our
actions are simply
moving from
one location
to another so i can go to i can go to
location zero i can go to location one
two three four five six seven eight uh
so these are my actions i can choose
these are the locations of our state
and if you remember earlier i mentioned
uh um
that the limitation is that you you
don't want to put in
um a continually growing table because
you can actually create a dynamic cue
table where you continually add in new
values as they arise
because
if you have float values this just
becomes infinite and then your memory in
your computer is gone or you know does
it's not going to work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the q uh
t learning setup
but there are ways to use it in
conjunction with other systems
and so you might look at
uh well i do um i've been doing some
work in stock
um and one of the questions that comes
out is to buy or sell the stock
and the stake coming in
might be um you might take a concrete
way called buckets
um where anything that you predict is
going to return more than a certain
amount of money
um the error for that stock that you've
had in the past you put those in buckets
and suddenly you start putting creating
these buckets you realize you do have a
limited amount of information coming in
you no longer have a float number you
now have
bucket one two three and four
and then you can take those buckets
put them through a q learning table and
come up with the best action which stock
should i buy it's like gambling stock is
pretty much gambling if you're doing day
trading you're not doing long term
um investments and so you can start
looking at it like that a lot of the
current feeds say that the best
algorithms used for day traders redoing
it on your own
is really to ask the question do i want
to trade the stock yes or no and now you
have it in a q learning table and now
you can take it to that next level and
you can see where that can be a really
powerful tool at the end of doing a
basic linear regression model or
something
what is the best investment and you
start getting the best reward on there
and the so if we're gonna have rewards
these rewards we just create
um it says uh if basically if you're uh
this should match our cue table because
it's gonna be uh you have your state and
you have your action across the top if
you remember from the dog and so we have
whatever state we're in going down and
then the next action and what the reward
is for it
and of course if you were actually doing
a
something more connected your reward
would be based on
the actual environment it's in
and then we want to go ahead and create
a state to location
so we can map the indexes
so just like we defined our rewards
we're going to go and do state to
location
and you can see here it's a dictionary
setup for location state and location to
state with items
and
we also need to
define what we want for learning rates
you remember
we had our two different rates
as far as like learning from the past
and learning from the current so we'll
go ahead and set those to
0.75 and the alpha set to 0.9 and we'll
see that when we do the formula
and of course any of this code send a
note to our simplylearn team they'll get
you a copy of this code
on here let's go ahead and pull
there we go
on the next two sections
um
since we're going to keep it
short and sweet
here we go so let's go ahead and create
our agent um so our agent is going to
have our initialization where we send it
all the information uh we'll define
ourself gamma equals gamma we could have
just set the gamma rate down here
instead of submitting it
it's kind of nice to keep them separate
because you can play with these numbers
on our self alpha
then we have our location state we'll
set that in here we have our choice of
actions
we're going to go ahead and just embed
the rewards right into the agent
so obviously this would be coming from
somewhere else
instead of from
self-generated and then a self state to
location equals our state to location
dictionary
and we go ahead and create a q learning
table and i went ahead and just set the
q learning table up to um
zero to zero what what what the setup is
uh location to state how many of them
are there
and this just creates an array of zero
to zero setup on there
and then the big part is the training we
have our rewards new equals a copy of
self.rewards
ending state equals the self-location
state in location so this is whatever we
end up at rewards new equals ending
state plus ending state equals 999 just
kind of goes
to a dead end
and
we start going through iterations
and we'll go ahead um let's do this
uh so this we're going to come back and
we're going to call call it on here
let me just erase that
switch it to an arrow
there we go
so what we're doing is we're going to
send in here to train it we're going to
say hey
i want to iterate through this a
thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be
instead of iterating you might have your
external environment and they're going
back and forth and you iterate through
outside of here
but just for ease of use our agent is
going to come in here and iterate
through this
sometimes i'll put this iteration in
here
and i'll have it call the environment
and say hey this is what i did what's
the next state and the environment does
this thing right in here as i iterate
through it
uh and then we want to go ahead and pick
a random state to start with
that's what's going on here you have to
start somewhere
um and then you have your playable
actions we're going to start with just
an empty thing for playable actions and
we'll fill that up
so that's what choices i have
and so we're going to iterate through
the rewards matrix to get the states
directly reachable from the randomly
chosen current state assign those states
to a list named playable actions
and so you can see here we have a range
nine i usually use length of whatever
i'm looking at which is our locations
or states as they are
we have a reward so we want to look at
the current the rewards uh the new
reward
is our
is in our chart here of rewards
underscore new uh current state
um
plus j uh j being what is the next state
we want to try
and so we go ahead and do our playable
actions and we append j
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better reward
and then of course we go ahead and
choose our next state
so we have our random choice playable
actions
and if you remember
i mentioned on this let me just go ahead
and let's do a free form
when we were talking about the next
state
this right here just does a random
selection
instead of a random
you might do something where
whatever the best selection is
which might be option
three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a bell curve
like this oops
and we start looking at these averages
and these spreads
or we can just add them all together and
pick the one that kind of goes in all of
those so those are some of the options
we have in here we just go with the
random choice that's usually where you
start play with it
and then we have our
reward section down here
and so we want to go ahead and find well
in this case the temporal difference
uh so you have your rewards new
plus the self gamma and this is the
formula we were looking at
this is bellman's equation here
so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that
and we can add it all together
this is of course our
maximum expected future setup in here
so this is all of our our bellman's
equation that we're looking at here and
then we come up in here and we update
our q table that's all this is on this
one
that's right here we have
self-cue current state next date and we
add in our alpha because we don't want
to we don't want to train all of it at
once in case there's slight difference
is coming in there we want to slowly
approach the answer
and then we have our route equals the
start location
and next location equals start location
so we're just incrementing we took a
step forward
and then finally
remember i was telling you how we're
going to do all this and just have some
simple thing at the end or just
generates a simple path
we're going to go ahead and get the
optimal route we want to find the best
route in here
and so we've created a definition for
the optimal route down here
scroll down for that
and we get the optimal route we go ahead
and put the information in including the
q table self
start location in location next location
route q
and it says while next location is not
equal to in location so while we can
still go
our start location equals self location
to state start location so we already
have our best value for the start
location
uh the next state looks at the q table
and says hey what's uh the next one with
the best value and then the next
location we go ahead and pull that in
and we just append it that's what's
going on down here
and then our start location equals the
next location and we just go through all
the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this
and now that we have our cue table our
cue agent loaded
we're going to go ahead and take our q
agent
load them up with our alpha gamma that
we set up above
along with the location step action
reward state to location
and
our goal is to plot a course between l9
and l1
and we're going to go through a hundred
a thousand iterations on here
and so when i run that it runs pretty
quick
why is this so fast
if you've been running neural networks
and you've been doing all these other
models you sit here and wait a long time
well we're a very small amount of data
these are all integers these aren't
float values there's not a the math is
not heavy on the on the processing end
and this is where q tables are so
powerful
if you have a small amount of
information coming in
you very quickly
get an answer off of this even though we
went through it a thousand times to
train it and you'll see here we have l
nine eight five two and one and that's
based on our reward table we had set up
on there and this is the shortest path
going between these different
setups in here
and if you remember on our reward table
you can see that if you start here you
can go to here there's places you can't
go that's how this reward table was set
up so i can only go to certain places
so kind of a little maze set up in there
and you can play with it this is really
fun
set up to play with
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like i was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup and model and predictions where
you put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action
long as you can take that course into
action and
reduce it down to a yes no
or if you're using text
you can use a one hot encoder which word
is next there's all kinds of things you
can do with a cue table
depending on just how much information
you're putting in there
so that wraps up our demo in this demo
we've found the shortest distance
between two paths based on whatever
rules or state rewards we have to get
from point a to point b and what
available actions there are the
principal component analysis we're going
to cover dimensionality reduction
principle component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties pca example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and have some hands-on demo on
the pca and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company b-packs iso max and they
have the item the tire the axle an order
id a price number and a quantity in
order to predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data
it might give them a higher weight than
they would if it was just once we want
to get rid of that redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it why would we want to store two
whole extra columns when we added into
that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good
clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
uh leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four it
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it principle component analysis
so what is it
uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result
we have the different colors all lined
up so what we're going to take a look at
is let's say we have a picture here uh
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space maybe from up here again
we have the back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data it's not
you really can't do it by what you think
is going to be the best we need to have
some kind of mathematical formula so
it's consistent and so it makes sense in
the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the most common ones out
there where they have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen
in the petals and they have width and
they have length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the
width-to-length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris
pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the x y
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get two principal components namely pc1
and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
pc2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back-end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more
valuable this gives you an idea though
that when we're talking about this we're
talking about the perspective which
would help in understanding how pca
analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under a pca
and important terminologies are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions
and that's talking about features
there's usually when you're running a
business you're talking 25 26 27
different features minimal and then you
have the principal component new
variables that are constructed as linear
combinations or mixtures of the initial
variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the ratio instead
which is a single number versus two
separate numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point how those points fall
onto the line important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense
you're not going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principal components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2 we want to make sure
that pc1 does not equal pc2 we don't
want to have the same two principal
points
when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers
increase
this is important to understand
if you're going to create
one
principle component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talk about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector is like a
translation for
moving the data
from x equals 1 to x equals 2 or
whatever altering it and the ign value
is the final value that we generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them lie within similar
boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on
and so if we do i was set up like this
we should see all those different
features as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values and
the i gene vectors
iogene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value that are
extracted from the covariance table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
i gene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change
the vector b
to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so when we have like multiple
variables how do we calculate that new
variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has igen
vectors of the components that we decide
to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns or variables
now for this matrix we would construct a
variable space with as many dimensions
as the variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k-dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm it represents the maximal
variance direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc one this value is
known as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python
scripting i'm going to use the anaconda
navigator and i will be in python 3.6
for this example
i believe there's even like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our
jupiter i'm in chrome and we go ahead
and create a new python 3.
and for ease of use
our team in the back was nice enough to
put this together for me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing i like to do
whenever i'm looking at
any new setup
uh well you know what let's do let's do
the libraries first we're going to do
our basic libraries which is matplot
library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
our data frame pd numpy our numbers
array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook matplot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but i put
it in there either anyway just because
i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is
let's take a look at the description
let's go in here and pull up the
description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different
measurements are taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target
names
run that
yeah so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9
in other words is this
a dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data
and you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right and
that's all you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're gonna use our pandas
and we're gonna go ahead and do our data
frame it's going to equal cancer data
columns equals cancer feature equals
feature names so remember up here we
already loaded the the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture mean perimeter
i don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because
like many of the data that most of the
data that comes in half the time we
don't even know what we're looking at
we're just handed a bunch of stuff as a
data scientist going what the heck is
this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from we want to just look at the data
and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
is difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now
i haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
premodeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead
let me go and run this code
uh so the code for this
is
from sklearn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals 2
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals two
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be um well the biggest one is your
components how many components do you
want
uh which you have to put in there pretty
much
and then you also might look at the svd
solver it's on auto right now but you
can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
there we go
to our methods
if you notice we have fit
and we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the describe setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it
we've already looked at our
minimum maximum we've already looked at
what's in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course i have examples of it down here
if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full or randomize there's different
things it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us what's going on here
we've taken 30 features i think i said
36 or something like that but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and uh
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and
we're just gonna use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of
one these are two different
perceptions we're using
uh and then
you'll see right here c for color cancer
equals target
and so remember we have zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principle component second
principal component and we'll go ahead
and run this
and you can see here
instead of having a chart one of those
heat maps with 30 different
columns in it
we can look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area was clumped
together
where it's going to be b9
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something
in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps
and we're not going to have a clear
result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently
versus going in and saying just cutting
into the can into the cancer so the body
absorbs it and it dissipates versus uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here in that middle line
where the overlap is going to be huge
that's domain specific uh going back to
the data we can see here
clearly by using these two components we
can easily separate these two classes
so the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object and
so we talk look at that we can go ahead
and do look at the pca components this
is in our model we built we've trained
it we can run that and you can see
here's the actual components uh it's the
two components have each have their own
array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what
so in this numpy matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down i'll play already got it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is uh
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and
and set it up for us we want and so
we're just going to do the see the
seaborne heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right
we have a scale so we can see we have
the dark colors all the way to the
really light colors which are what's
really shining there this is like the
primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map and the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is
um on some of this
uh so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean and what
you want to change to get a better
result
regularization in machine learning
so our agenda on this one is fitting the
data
understanding linear regression
bias and variance
what is overfitting
what is underfitting and those are like
the biggest things right now in data
science is overfitting and under fitting
what does that mean
and what is regularization and then
we'll do a quick hands-on demo to take a
look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data and we talk about what
is data fitting it's a process of
plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go in a little deeper on there
so we might have in this case just the
two dimensions we have an efficiency of
the car and we have the distance
traveled in 1 000 kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship and a linear
relationship
very specifically linear means line
the line used to represent the
relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have linear relationship
linear regression
so let's start with how linear
regression works a linear regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car
versus the distance traveled and you can
see this nice straight line drawn
through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line it now becomes a
plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to this linear kind of drawing a
line through your data and finding what
fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example uh
let's say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw l1 and l2 and we're going
to kind of guess which one we think is
the best fit
and which claim to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line l1
and each data point and add them all and
find the mean distance
and i want you to think about that when
we
square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus 2 squared is 4 2 squared
is 4. so we're removing what side of the
line it's on and we're just looking for
the error in this case the mean distance
of each of the little dotted lines you
see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called mean square error or
loss function
and we talk about loss how far off are
we that's what we're really talking
about what did we miss when we have a
positive distance and a negative
distance and of course when we square it
it is neither it just becomes a positive
error
and so we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as mse
if i look in a code and i'm going
through my python code and i see mse i
know that's a mean squared error
and we take all the dotted lines and we
calculate this error and we add them all
together and then we average it or find
the means
and in this case
they ran a demo on this and it was uh
1127.27
for our l1 line
now we find the loss function for line
l2 in a similar fashion and we get the
mean square error to be 6397
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for l1 than l2
hence l1 is the best fit line
this process describes a lot of machine
learning processes it was we're going to
keep guessing and get as close as we can
to find the right answer we have to have
some way to invite algorithm has limited
flexibility to learn from data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have the two different
setups
bias you can think is very generalized
where variance is very specific
uh and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and over simplify the
model
therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar trends
and uh with bias if you over simplify it
so much you're going to miss
your
local
uh if if you have like a really
good fit you're going to miss it you're
you're going to just kind of guess what
the average is and that's what your
answer is going to be
with variance a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data as a bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have high error rates on test data and i
want you to think about this
when we're talking about a bias
the error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of
getting an average we're not really
fitting it close
with variance we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to nail it every time if you're
doing categorical testing that's a car
that's a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants
suddenly a
truck has to have certain features
and it might have to be red
because you had so many red pictures so
if it has if it's an 18 wheeler it has
to be red if it's blue then it has to be
a bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something and it cannot get the right
answer unless it gets a very specific
data and we see that so that as you're
testing it your models
and you programmed it you got to look
for
how i trained it what is coming out and
if it's not if it's not looking good on
either bias or if it's not looking good
on the training
or on the test data then your bias then
you're biasing your data
if it really looks good on the training
data then that's going to be your
variance you've over fitted the data
and those are very important things to
know when you are building your models
in regression of any kind or any kind of
setup for predicting
so in dark games if all the data found a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall in
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual
predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting
when we talk about overfitting it's a
scenario where the machine learning
model tries to learn from the details
along with the noise and the data tries
to fit each data point on the curve
you can see that
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever it's
fitted every point on the data stream
there's no average there's no
two points that might have that you know
why might have two different answers
because uh if the wind blows a certain
way
in the efficiency of your car maybe you
have a headwind so your car might alter
how efficient it is as it goes and so
there's going to be this variance on
here and this says no you can't have any
variance with you know the this is it's
going to be exactly this it can't be any
you can't be the same speed or the same
car and have a slightly different
efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
so you'll get like a really high error
on here
and so
reasons for overfitting
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data and it's so important it's so
important that if you have if you have
some kind of
something wrong with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data maybe they
use in medical different measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus hospital
b or even off of machine a and machine b
that's testing something and those those
numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance
again wind is a good example i was
talking about that with the car
you may have a hundred tests but because
the wind's blowing it's all over the
place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data is going to
also cause this problem you only have a
few points and you try to plot
everything
the model is too complex
this comes up a lot we put too many
pieces together and how they interact
can't even be tracked
and so you have to go back back break it
up and find out actually what correlates
and what doesn't
so
what is underfitting
a scenario where machine learning models
can either learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point
and you can see here we have our
efficiency of our car and our line drawn
and it's just going to be way off for
both the training and the predicting
data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue you've got to clean your data
the model has a high bias
we've seen this in all kinds of things
from
[Music]
the most common is the driving cars to
facial identification
or whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have
five people from india and 10 people
from
africa and 20 people from the u.s you
created a bias
because it's looking at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when it needs a slight
shift to it for other reasons
so what is a good fit
a linear curve that best fits the data
is neither overfitting or under fitting
models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting lines
going up and down every point is trying
to be include gluted underfitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that um
error coming through regularization is
taking the guess work out you're looking
at this graph and you're going oh which
one is that really over fit or is that
under fit that's pretty hard to tell
so we talk about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent overfitting or
under fitting
so what that means
in this case we're going to go ahead and
take a look at a couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the ridge regularization
and the lasso regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the
mlp the multi-layered positron in the sk
learn module you could bring in the
ridge module and you can bring in the
lasso module
so when we talk about
ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals
lambda times the sum of w
squared or the absolute value of w
depending on how you're doing it now
remember we talked about error whether
we either square it or we absolute value
it
because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our
in this case the lambda is going to be
the penalty for the errors we've thrown
in a greek character for you just to
confuse everybody
and w is the slope of the curve of the
line
so uh we're going to look at this and
we're going to draw a line this is going
to be like a linear regression model so
if you had in sk learned you could
import just a standard linear regression
model
it would plot this line across whatever
data we're working on
and we look at this of course we're just
extrapolating this i know they use some
specific data but you don't want to get
into the actual domain
and so for a linear regression line
let's consider two points that are on
the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero
considering the two points on the line
we'll go ahead and do lambda equals 1.
we'll set our w is going to be 1.4
then the cost function equals 0 plus 1
times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
so
really don't get caught up too much in
the math on this other than
understanding um that this is something
that's very easy for a computer to
calculate and if you ever see the loss
plus the plus the lambda times w the sum
of w squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through of the two
points we end up with the 0.0.62
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and i find this true on a lot of data i
work with i'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso mars
regression model for fitting um
especially dealing with a lot of like uh
stock markets daily
setup they come out slightly better you
get a slightly better
fit
and so we have our lasso we just talked
about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute value and so if
you remember this is where ridge
regression changes where's my ridge
regression model
we're squaring the value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of this of the squared individuals
um and here is our
lambda symbol again penalty for errors
and w equals the slope of the curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like i said i use these two
models a lot uh the ridge and this is
important this is
this is kind of the meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use some of
it is you just do it a bunch of times
and then you figure it out
ridge regularization is useful when we
have many variables with relatively
smaller data samples
the model does not encourage convergence
towards zero but is likely to make them
closer to zero and prevent overfitting
the lasser regularization model is
preferred when we are fitting a linear
model with fewer variables
so in the la in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as we measured
the different leaf pieces uh you might
be doing the measurements on the cancer
project which has 36 different variables
um so as we get down to the iris with
four variables lasso lar will probably
work pretty good where you might use the
ridge regularization with more model
with if you have something significantly
larger
and it encourages the coefficients of
the variables to go towards zero because
of the shape of the constraint which is
an absolute value
and with any of this we want to go ahead
and
do a demo and lasso and ridge regression
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like in our code and bring up our
jupiter notebook we'll start with our
imports pandas is pd import numpy is np
import matplot library as plt
um sklearn we're going to import our
data sets it's kind of more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together
uh we have our sklearn model selection
we're going to import our train test
split for splitting our data up
and then we'll bring in our linear
regression model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up
and then load our data set we're just
talking about that
you could just
have imported the load boston and boston
data set in there instead of loading all
the data sets
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and see what we got here
let me just go and pop that down there
and go and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
boston
data we're going to look we put it into
our pandas data frame
the boston data set and then the boston
columns we want to see what's going on
with them
we have our target
we have the house price
etc and so our x equals boston
eye location
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want eye location if
you're going to pull data we used to be
able to leave this off
but it does something different it
creates a slice versus a direct
setup so make sure using that eye
location and the i the output so this is
all just bringing our data together
and we can see here if we do uh we print
the boston
panda's head
we can see here all of our different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the x and the y
the x is
everything
except for the last column
where y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column and then y is all the rows
but just the last column so y is our
house price
and the x is the
crimsian industry chas knox and all
these other different statistics they've
collected for house sales in boston
there we go oops control
so we'll go ahead and split our data
x train and our x test y train y test
equals the train test split which we
imported
and we have our boston you could have
easily used the x and y on here as
opposed to boston
eye location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 of the data and put it
in as a test
uh and then we'll go ahead and run this
need an extra drink there uh so we have
our train and test and then of course
the print the train data shape
i love doing this kind of thing whenever
i'm working with this data print out the
shape
make sure everything looks correct so
that we have 127 by 13 and 127 by one
379 by 13 they should match and if
they're if the the data sets are not
quite matching
then you know something's wrong and
you're going to get all those errors i
don't know how many times i've gone
through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird has
happened when i'm cleaning the data
this is pretty straightforward and
simple because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple linear regression model
and we'll call this lreg lrag linear
regression and we're going to go ahead
and fit that linear regression model to
x-train and y-train
then we'll generate the prediction on
the test set
so here's our l-reg y predict
with our x-test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error mse i told you you'll see mse used
a lot
people use it in variables and things
like that it's pretty common and we get
our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see these
kinds of numbers coming up
uh but if it's not it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo uh
and then we're gonna go ahead and plot
these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at and you can see
here um
we plot the coefficient scores on here
and we
the guys in the back did a great job
putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns
you can see here
uh your nox has like just a huge
coefficient
when i look at a table like this i look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change and what has huge changes
and that flags you for all kinds of
things as you're working with the data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score so now we want to take these and
and
bring them down as much as we can
and for that we're going to work with
the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going we're going to
import our ridge model
the red regression from the sk learn
library or the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our ridge
r equals alpha equals one and i
mentioned that earlier um
when i work with the ridge model you'll
see alpha equals one if you set alpha
equal to zero that's a standard linear
regression model so you have alpha
equals one two three four and you
usually use one two or three four and a
standard integer on there
and we'll go ahead and fit the ridge
model on there with our x train and our
y train data
generate a prediction for that
for our x test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this should all
look familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now
if i jump up and down between these two
you'll get a headache ah
you'll still see the knox value let's
just look at the knocks because that was
the biggest value it's a minus nine here
and if we go back up here the nox value
is a minus eighteen so right off the bat
i'm seeing a huge change
um in the biggest coefficient there
uh so if we're going to do that nice
setup we want to go ahead and just print
it and see what that looks like
here we go and we've
set up our plot subplots and again the
team put together some nice colors so it
makes it look good
we're doing an x bar based on the
columns
and our
l regress coefficients color equals
color x spine bottom and so forth
so just put together a nice little graph
and you're starting to see
one this
when you compare this if you put on the
same graph as this one up here this is
up here minus 18.
this is at minus 9.
and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above
the same thing with these values here
they might look the same but they're
actually all
almost half the value on here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look uh very similar as
far as what we worked on before
and i'm just going to print that on here
and run it
and again let's go up to uh knox
look where nox is it's all the way down
to zero
and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient it's minus 0.8 and really
here's our
22.73
let me go up here
um
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number
uh 16.69
and so we look at this uh if i was
running this in doing a working on a
project with this i would look at these
numbers i start with the 16.69
come down here and compare it to
16.78
6 9 is better than 7 8.
so from the very beginning we might
start looking at this first model for
overall
predicting
but there's other factors involved we
might know that
the nox value is central and the other
ones aren't quite as good and so we
might start looking at just certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have
a certain meaning to us and so forth and
so you look at all those different
items in there again but the bottom
dollar is our first model did better
than our other two models our mean
square error on the test set
continues to
come down on this
today we're going to look at feature
selection in machine learning
what's in it for you the need for
feature selection
what is feature selection
feature selection methods
feature selection statistics
so the need for feature selection to
train a model we collect huge quantities
of data to help the machine learn better
consider a table which contains
information on old cars the model
decides which cars must be crushed for
spare parts and when we talk about huge
quantities of data there they save
everything from people's favorite cat
pictures to
and you can imagine there's so much data
out there even in a company they'll save
all these little pieces of information
about people and companies and
corporations
you need some way to sort through
because if you try to run your models on
all of it
you'll end up with these very clunky
models and they might have issues which
we'll talk about later but in this case
we're talking about cars and crushing
but not all this data will be useful to
us some classes or part of the data may
not contribute much to our model and can
be dropped and you can see right here we
have who was the owner of the car
in our data a car will not be crushed
based on its previous owner
so yeah that's kind of a clear cut you
can see that why would i care who owned
the car before once it's in the junkyard
and we're crushing the cars we're not
going to really care about that
so here we have dropped the owner column
as it does not contribute to the model
having too much unnecessary data can
cause the model to be slow the model may
also learn from this irrelevant data and
be inaccurate
so feature selection is a process of
reducing the input variable to your
model by using only relevant data and
getting rid of the noise in the data
consider the database given below a
library wants to donate some old books
to make place in their shells for new
books we want to train a model to
automate this task
in this case the color of the book does
not matter and keeping it can cause a
model to learn to donate books based on
color we can remove this as a feature
using feature selection we can optimize
our model in several ways
and so the number one is to prevent
learning from noise and overfitting
that's actually the huge one because we
we don't want it to give us the wrong
prediction and that means also improved
accuracy
so instead of giving us a wrong
prediction we also want it to be as
close to the right answer as we can get
and we want to reduce the training time
it's an exponential growth in some of
these models so the each feature you add
in increases that much
more training time we talk about feature
selection methods uh we put together a
nice little flow chart that shows the
various methods used for feature
selection
and you have your basic feature
selection and then there is supervised
and unsupervised
under supervised there's intrinsic
wrapper method filter method
so we talk about unsupervised feature
selection refers to the method which
does not need the output label class for
feature selection and that was uh you
can see here under super unsupervised we
don't have i mean that's really a
growing market right now
unsupervised learning and so feature
selection is the same thing
supervised feature selection refers to
the method which uses the output label
class for the feature selection and if
you remember we looked at three
different
we have intrinsic wrapper and filter
method so we're going to start with the
filter method on this now remember
we know what the output is so we're
going to be looking at that output to
see how well it's doing versus the
features in this method features are
dropped based on their relation to the
output or how they are correlating to
the output
you can see here we have a set of
features selecting best feature learning
algorithm and then performance
and so we want to find out which feature
correlates to the performance on the
output consider the example of book
classifier here we drop the color column
based on simple deduction
and that kind of sums it up in the in a
nutshell as we want to filter out things
that clearly do not go with what we're
looking for we look at the wrapper
method in the wrapper method we split
our data into subsets
and train a model using this based on
the output of the model we add and
subtract features and train the model
again
and you can see here in the wrapper
method we have a set of features we
generate a subset we run it through the
algorithm and we see how each one of
those subset of features performs
consider the book data set by using the
wrapper method we would use a subset of
different features to train the machine
and adjust the subset according to the
output and so you can see here let's say
we take a name a number of times red and
we run just those and we look at the
output and if we looked at them with all
four inputs and look at the output we'd
see quite a different variation in there
and we might say you know what condition
of the book and color really doesn't
affect what we're looking for and you
can see here we've run it on condition
of the book and color
depending on the output of the model we
will choose our final set of features
these features will give us the best
result for our model
and it might come up that the name
number of times red is probably pretty
important
the intrinsic method
this method combines the qualities of
both filter and wrapper method to create
the best subset
the model will train and check the
accuracy of different subsets and select
the best among them we kind of looked at
a little overview of some of the stuff
some of the common feature selection
algorithms based on which method they
belong to are given below
and you'll see is primarily under
supervised there's not like i said a lot
of unsupervised methods and the ones
that are usually used these methods
and finds a way to create a supervised
connection between the data
and we talk about supervised methods we
have our filter method which we talked
about and it uses like the pearson's
coefficient
t squared anova coefficient those are
all under the filter method and in the
wrapper method
recursive feature elimination so
remember we're choosing a subset and we
want to go through there and look at
each one so you're just doing a lot of
loops or recursive calculations to see
which one works best and which ones
don't have an impact on the output
and there's a lot of genetic algorithms
to go with this too on the wrapper
method and how they evaluate it and with
the intrinsic method there's the two
main ones we're looking at is the lasso
regularization
the lasso algorithms are basically your
standard
regression model so it's finding out how
these
different methods fit together and which
ones have the best
add together to have the least amount of
error
the other one used in the intrinsic
method is the decision tree it says hey
if this one is this one produces this
result this one produces this result yes
no which way do we go based on the input
and the output variables we can choose
our feature selection model so you have
your numeric input coming in you have a
numeric output
if you use the pearson's correlation
coefficient or spearman's rank
coefficient
you can then
select what features you're going to
feed into that specific model and you
maybe have a numerical input and a
categorical input so we're going to be
looking more at a nova correlation
coefficient or kindle's rank coefficient
and if you have a core categorical input
and a numerical output we might be
looking at anova correlation coefficient
in kindle's rank coefficient
so based on the input and the output
variables we can choose our feature
selection model and you can see we have
categorical to categorical we might be
looking at the chi-squared test
contingency tables and mutual
information let's go and take a look and
see uh in the python code what we're
talking about here
and i'm going to go ahead and use for my
ide the jupiter notebook in the and they
always launch it out of anaconda on here
and we'll go ahead and go up here and
create a new python 3 module
and we'll call it
feature
select
and since we're in python we're going to
be working mainly with your numpy your
pandas your matplot library so we have
our number array our data frame setup
which goes with the number array the
numpy the pandas data frame and then we
want to go ahead and graph everything so
we're going to import these three
modules
and then we put together some data
we're going to read this in it's kobe
bryant i guess he's a basketball player
our guys in the back we have a number of
them guys
both we have a lot of men and women so
it's probably a misnomer our team in the
back
they have a some of them have a liking
for basketball and they know who kobe
bryant is and they want to learn a
little bit more about kobe bryant and
what's going in for what whatever is
going on with his game
in basketball so we're going to take a
look at him
and once we import the data we can see
what columns are available
original features count so we can see
how many features there are
the length of it and we'll actually have
a list of them and then print just
the data head the top five rows
and so when we do this
we can see from the csv file
we have 25 original features
our original features are your action
type combine shot type game event id and
so forth there's a lot of features in
here that they're recorded on all of his
shots this is we talk about like a
massive amount of data
i mean
people are sitting there and they record
all this stuff and they import this
stuff for different reasons
but depending on what we want to look at
do we really want all those features
maybe the question we're going to ask is
what's the chance of him making any one
specific shot
in right from the beginning we can look
at the some of these things and say team
name uh team name probably i don't know
maybe it does matter because the other
team might be really good at defense uh
game date maybe we don't really want to
look at the game date team id definitely
not of importance in any of this so we
look at this we have 25 features and
some of these features just really
don't matter to us
we also have location x location y
latitude and longitude i'm guessing
that's the same data we've actually
imported the
the very similar data maybe they're
slightly zoned differently
but as far as our program we don't want
to repeat data some of the models when
you repeat data into them and this is
true for most models create a huge bias
they weigh that data over other data
so just at a glance these are the things
we're looking at we want to find out
well how do we get this these features
down and get rid of this bias and all
these
extraneous features that we don't really
want to
spend time running our models on and
programming on
and as i pointed out there's a location
x a location y latitude and longitude
let's take a look at that and see what
we're looking at here we'll go ahead and
create a plot of these
and we'll just plot we'll do a scatter
plot of location x and location y
and then we'll do a
scatter plot of
data lawn data lat which is probably
longitude and latitude
and the scatter plot let's go ahead and
actually put a little title here
location and scatter on there and we'll
just go ahead and plot these and when
you look at this uh coming in
these two graphs are pretty identical
except they're flipped
and so when we look at the location from
which they're shooting from
they're probably the same and at this
point we can say okay we can get rid of
one of these sets of datas we don't need
both x and y and latitude and longitude
because it's the same data coming in and
as we look at this particular data the
latitude longitude we might also ask
does it really make a difference which
side of the chord you're on whether
you're on the left side or the right
side
and so we might go ahead and explore
instead of looking at this as
x y we might look at it as a distance
and an angle and we can easily compute
that and you can see we can create our
data distance equals location x
plus the location y squared standard
euclidean geometry or
triangular geometry
hypotenuse squared equals the each side
squared
and then once we've done that
we can also compute the angle
so the data angle is based on the arc
tangent
and so forth on here so this is all this
is we're just going to compute the angle
here
and then set that up
pi over 2 to get our angle
and we'll go ahead and run that
and you'll see some errors run come up
and that's because when we took slices
over here we took a slice of a slice
there's ways to fix that but it's really
not important for this example
so if you do see that you want to start
looking up here for
instead of data location x of uh
not location x0
this would be like
i believe the term is ilo dot ilocation
if this was
this is in pandas
so there's different things in there but
for this it doesn't really matter these
are just warnings that's all they are
and then let's combine our remaining
minutes and seconds column into one
there's another one so if you remember
up here we're trying to get rid of these
columns
do we really need let me see if i can
find it on here there we go there's our
minutes remaining
um and then they had
what was it it was uh minus remaining
and seconds column so there's also a
seconds column on here
let me see if i can find that one
this is where it really gets kind of
crazy because here's our seconds
remaining so you can see that here's our
minutes remaining this gets crazy when
you're looking at hundreds of these
features
and you can see that if if i'm going to
say
write a model that's going to predict a
lot of this and i want it to run in this
case it's a basketball and how good his
shots are as the data comes in let's say
i want to have it run on your phone
if i'm running it across hundreds of
features
it's gonna just hang up on your phone
where if i can get it down to just a
handful
we'll actually be able to come in here
and run it on a smaller device and not
use up as much memory
or processing power
so we'll go ahead and take data
remaining time here
and data minutes remaining times 60 plus
data seconds remaining so we're just
going to combine those
and we'll go ahead and reprint our data
so we can see what we got
um
coming across we have our action type
combined and this is we do this a lot uh
we want to take a look at oops i got so
so zoomed in let me see if i can zoom
out just a little bit
there we go
boom
all right so we come up here you can see
that we now have our distance our angle
remaining time which is now just a
number
uh that computes both the minutes and
seconds together
and we still have we've
we've been adding columns i thought you
said we're supposed to subtract columns
right
um we're going to delete the obsolete
columns when we get to them so we're
just filtering out and this is a filter
method we're just filtering through the
things
that we really
don't need and next let's go ahead and
explore
team id and team name
let me just go ahead and run that and if
you look at this we have los angeles
lakers and then they have the team id
here and they're unique
there's not that's not really anything
that's going to come up
because that's
this particular
athletes
works for that team so it's the same on
every line so there's another thing we
can filter out on there team id and t
name is just useless the whole column
contains only one value each and
it's pretty much useless
let's go ahead and take a look at match
up an opponent that's an interesting one
and we see here that we have
the lal versus por and the opponent is
por and ind
again here's a lot of duplicate
information
so this basically contains the same
information on here
again we're filtering all this stuff out
and this is because we're only looking
at one athlete and this might change if
you're looking at multiple athletes that
kind of thing now these are easy to see
we might have something that looks more
like this
we might have something where we're
looking at the distance which we
computed and the shot distance are they
the same thing
and what we can do is we can plot that
and plot them against each other on here
and we see it just draws a nice straight
line
and so
again we're looking at the same
information
so again we're repeating stuff and we
really don't want to be running our
model on
repeat information on here so again it
contains the same information so now
let's look at the shot zone area
shot zone basic shot zone range
so now we're looking at the zones and
what does that mean and we'll go ahead
and and do this also in a scatter plot
in this case we're going to just create
three of these side by side so we're
going to create
our plot figure side 20 by 10
and then we're going to define our
scatter plot by category feature and
we're going to do each one
set up on here give it a slightly
different color and so our shot zone
area is going to be plot
subplot 131 scatter 131 is how that's
read by the way
meaning that
it's number one
um we have three across
and this is the first one down so one
one one our scatter plot by category is
going to be the shot zone area we're
going to plot that
and then we're going to do the
shot zone basic and then the shot zone
range and you just push them through our
definition so each of those areas go
through and you'll see one three one one
three two one three three
again it's a one by three
setup and then it's just a place on each
one and so we look at this we can see
that
these shots uh they map out the same so
it's very again redundant information
that should be intuitive
when we're looking at this
in these color graphs
it kind of helps you start looking at
something you it's very intuitive like
this is you start to realize that some
of the stuff
you'll be looking for in data you might
not understand
and you'll see these circular patterns
where they match or they mostly match
and you start to realize
when you're looking at these that
they're repetitive data and then you
want to explore them more closely
depending on what domain you're working
in so we look at these we look at them
and they look just like the regions of
the court but we already have stored
this information in angle and distance
columns so we've seen this image before
we go back up here
and here's our the similar image
and repeating that image is down here
and so let's go ahead and drop some of
this in this stuff so now let's drop all
the useless columns
and we can drop the shot id team id team
name shot zone area shot zone range shot
zone basic
the match up
the longitude and latitude because we're
putting that into distance
seconds remaining minutes remaining
because we combine that into one column
shot distance because we have just
distance on there location x location y
the game event id game id all this stuff
is just being dropped on here and we'll
just go ahead and loop through our drops
and this is a nice way of doing this
because as you're playing with this
this kind of data
putting your list into one setup helps
because then you're just running it
through an iteration
and you can come back and change it you
might be playing with different models
and do this with models you might be
looking at all kinds of different things
that you can drop and add in as you test
these out and again we're working in the
filter method so this is a lot of human
interaction with the data and it takes a
lot of critical thinking to look at this
stuff and say what matches and what
doesn't
and so we look at the remaining features
let me go ahead and just run this
the original to the new count we had 25
features now we have 11 features you can
see that right there we just circle that
there's our 25 and there's uh old new
now we're down to 11. so we've cut it
down to less than half
and you can just see
the actual different information on here
and the remaining time
at this point we filtered it through and
then we'd move into the next process
which would be to run our model on this
and maybe we would drop
some of the features and see if it runs
better or worse and what happens
that's kind of would be the next step on
there versus the filter setup and that
would be one of the other setups
depending on which algorithm you use
so that wraps up our demo on
filter the feature selection and going
through and seeing how these different
features are being repeated in this
particular in a basketball
setup hi everyone today we have a really
interesting topic for you
in this video we'll be analyzing the
upcoming united states presidential
election using twitter sentiment
analysis in python
in the course of this session
we will understand in brief about the
upcoming election the candidates
fighting the 2020 u.s election and throw
light on the result of the 2016 u.s
election we look at the election
forecast by some of the popular news
agencies as well as pole analysis
websites such as 538
before we begin
i want to make it clear that this video
is solely for learning purposes
we had simply learned to not lean
towards any party in the united states
or are biased towards any candidate
the analysis is based on what people
have tweeted and we will understand the
mood and sentiment of the public
the main objective of this video is to
help you understand how to extract
tweets from twitter handles using python
libraries
store it in a csv file and perform
textual analysis
the results obtained are purely based on
the data that we have collected
let's begin
the battle for the 2020 u.s presidential
election has begun with the 59th united
states presidential election scheduled
to be held on the 3rd of november 2020
this will decide who will be in the
white house for the next four years
all 435 seats in the united states house
of representatives 35 of the 100 seats
in the united states senate and office
of the president of the united states
will be contested
both the republican party and the
democratic party have nominated their
respective president and vice
presidential candidates
the incumbent president donald trump is
the republican nominee
while the 47th vice president of the
united states joe biden is the
democratic party's nominee
the current vice president mike pence is
the republican party's vice presidential
nominee and is running for a second term
in office
senator kamala harris of california was
chosen by joe biden as his running mate
on 11th of august 2020.
now let's see the results of the last
u.s presidential election in 2016.
the republican ticket of businessman
donald trump and indiana governor mike
pence had defeated the democratic ticket
of former secretary of state hillary
clinton and u.s senator from virginia
tim kaine
donald trump received a total of 304
electoral votes while hillary clinton
got 227 electoral votes
a significant number of central states
in the united states were swept by the
republican party
it was surprising to see that donald
trump getting nearly 46.4 popular vote
as compared to hillary clinton who got
48.5 votes
donald trump's victory came after
crucial wins in the battleground streets
of florida ohio iowa north carolina and
pennsylvania
will donald trump be re-elected to the
white house or are we going to see a new
president and vice president of the
united states is the big question
let's see what our pollsters have to say
and what has been their forecast for the
upcoming election
according to 538
donald trump has not gained ground since
the final debate on 22nd of october
at this moment joe biden is favored to
win the election and he leads in both
national and state pools
the economist is analyzing polling
economic and demographic data to predict
the u.s elections
their model thinks joe biden is very
likely to beat donald trump in the
electoral college as per their forecast
joe biden has 96 percent chance of
winning the electoral college and this
99 chance of biden
winning the most votes the democrats
have 75 chance of controlling the senate
while the republicans have around 25
percent
the democrats are highly likely to keep
their majority in the house of
representatives now according to the
guardian
joe biden is leading donald trump in the
national polls for the presidential
election
but to keep in mind this does not
guarantee the democratic candidate joe
biden's victory
hillary clinton also had a clear lead
over donald trump in the polls for
almost the entire 2016 campaign she
ended up losing the electoral college
now the bbc forecast tells that biden is
leading national presidential polls with
51 percent
he has hovered around 50 in recent
months and has had a 10 point lead on
occasions
so clearly joe biden is set to be the
next u.s president
let's wait and watch what happens on the
3rd of november
the voters of america will decide on 3rd
of november whether donald trump remains
in the white house for another 4 years
let's perform a twitter sentiment
analysis to understand the sentiments of
people tweeting about donald trump and
joe biden by tagging them in their
tweets
we have our code implemented already
i'll run through each line of code and
explain our analysis in detail
the objective is to check the polarity
of each tweet to figure out if it's
positive negative or neutral we'll
compare the tweets of donald trump and
joe biden to see who people are favoring
the most
finally we learn to create a word cloud
i have already extracted the tweets and
stored them in two separate csv files
it takes some time to fetch 10 000
tweets hence it won't be possible for me
to show it to you live
if you want to know how we extracted the
tweets for donald trump and joe biden
then please put your email ids in the
comments section of the video we'll
share the code file and the source file
with you
now you would need to install the 2p
library fetch the twitter keys and
access tokens and then authenticate the
twitter api
i've extracted 5000 tweets each for
donald trump and joe biden converted
into a data frame and stored it in a csv
file
so let me open and show you both the
files
so here is my data set for donald trump
on the top you can see trump underscore
data 5000 which means there are 5000
tweets here
the first column
has the number of tweets it starts from
zero and goes all the way to 4999
the next column
is the text column which has the content
of the tweet
you can see
they have tagged at the rate real donald
trump
there are links as well there are
special characters like emoticons
and the third column is the user
which means
it's the username
who had put that tweet similarly
i have another data for biden
you can see these are
for joe biden
and here you can see the content they
have tagged kamala harris also
similarly we have the username
now let me take you straight to my
jupyter notebook where i have
implemented the code
okay so first and foremost let's import
all the required libraries so we have
the numpy library for numerical
computation then we have the pandas
library for data manipulation next we
are importing two libraries matplotlib
and c bond for data visualization
then we have
text blob and word cloud
to get the sentiment and to build the
word cloud
and finally we are importing the plotly
library for creating graphs
let me run this cell
in the current cell we'll import the
data sets using read underscore csv
function present in the pandas library
so i have passed in my location where
the data file is so i placed it on my
desktop
and
the index underscore col parameter or
column parameter refers to the columns
to be used as the row labels of the data
frame here 0 indicates that the first
column will be used
as row labels
let me run it
okay now we have imported both the data
files
let me go ahead and
print the shape of one of the data
frames
so i'll write print
let's say we'll check the shape of
biden data frame so i'll write print
biden dot
shape
i'll hit shift enter
you can see there are 5000 rows and
there are two columns one is the text
column and the next column is the user
column
now let me
go ahead and print the head of the data
sets
so the head function will return the
first five rows
i'll write
trump
dot head
you can see these are the first
five rows from the trump
data frame and similarly if you want to
check for biden i can write biden dot
head
you can see it here
now you can also use the info method
so let me
show you that you can write drum dot
info
and this is the result so it tells there
are 5000 entries from 0 to
4999 there are two columns
these are the number of
rows
and similarly you have the data types
okay
moving ahead in the next cell i am
displaying the
200th tweet present in the trump data
frame so i have my data frame name
mentioned then i have my text column
and inside one more square bracket i
have put 200 which means i want to see
what's there in the 200th row
if i hit enter
so you can see this was the tweet fake
fake president
next
let me show you
the tweet number 1000 for biden
so i'll write
biden
and inside square brackets i'll give the
text column
and
the number is
if i hit shift enter
so this is the tweet
now
the text blob function
is used in natural language processing
the sentiment property returns a named
tuple in the form of sentiment
in brackets polarity and subjectivity
let's check the sentiment of the 200th
tweet made for donald trump
if i hit shift enter
you can see this was the polarity
now minus
0.399 means
the polarity was negative and you can
see the subjectivity is around
0.933
similarly let's check for biden's tweet
number 1000
so i'll write
text
blob which is my function name
and inside brackets i'll give biden
then
pass in my column name that is text
and
i'll give the row number which is 1000
and then i'll give the
parameter
or the attribute sentiment
if i hit shift enter you can see the
polarity and the subjectivity
now moving ahead
here
i have defined a function that will add
another column called polarity to our
two data frames trump and biden
let me run this
okay
in the next cell
i have used the apply function that will
return the polarity based on the tweets
you can see we have the apply function
this might take some time to run it okay
we are done now
let me now display the top five rows of
the data frame
so
what i'll do is i'll click on this cell
go to insert and
i'll hit
insert cell below
let's do one more
okay now here
i'll display the head of the data frame
once again so that you can see the
polarity column added
you can see it here
so for donald trump
we have the polarity you can see the
tweet and the polarity
now 0.0 which means these are neutral
minus is negative and anything
that's in positive value
indicates it's a
positive tweet or it has positive
polarity
similarly let's see for biden
i'll write biden dot head
okay so here you can see the
polarity for biden
now this point five means it's a
positive tweet
okay now
i want to create another column called
expression where we will classify the
tweets as positive negative or neutral
based on the polarity value
so i have used the np dot where function
and the condition we have here is
if polarity is greater than zero it's a
positive tweet
else if it is less than zero it's a
negative to it and if the polarity is
equal to zero it means it's a neutral
tweet
let me run this
okay
so here you can see we have the column
called expression and it has classified
the polarity based on negative
neutral
as well as positive
similarly let's do the same for biden
data frame as well
okay
before moving ahead if you want to get
access to the source code and the data
sets we have used in this demo then
please put your email address in the
chat section
we'll send it to you via mail
also please subscribe to simply launch
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply loan
in the next cell of code
we have another function that will
basically help us creating a bar plot
based on the expression column from both
the data frames
so this is my user defined function name
and it has two parameters reviews and
title
you can see we have
grouped the expression column and found
out the count using the count function
then we have created or converted it
into a list
similarly
below you can see here
we have defined the
color for the bars using rgb values
now let me run it
okay
so we have successfully created our user
defined function
now let me go ahead and call the
function
and pass in my two parameters reviews
and title so here we have the function
name
and
under reviews we have the data frame
name trump and the title we have given
is analysis for trump
let me run this
okay
so you can see we have a horizontal
bar plot on the top you can see the
title of the plot which is analysis for
trump
and
as per the tweets it has classified as
positive neutral or negative
if i hover over you can see there were 2
831 neutral tweets
1211 positive tweets and similarly there
were
958 negative tweets for donald trump
now
let me call that function once again so
i'll write
exp underscore graph
which is my function name
then i'll pass in my
parameters this time i'll take biden and
the title i'll put is
analysis
for
biden
if i run it
okay you can see the plot for biden now
if i hover over
there were 1290 positive tweets for
biden
and
747 negative tweets
okay
let's scroll down
now let me check the number of rows that
have polarity equal to 0
the number of rows that have polarity
less than 0 and greater than 0 for both
the data frames using the
dot shape attribute
so first we have
for trump now equal to equal to 0 means
we are checking the total number of
neutral tweets
you can see the result
now let's check for biden we have the
result below
let me run it
okay
now
we'll drop those columns that have a
polarity equal to zero from both the
data frames and display the shape
you can see
we have the condition mentioned
and we have also used the drop function
so all the neutral tweets will be
deleted
and i'm printing the shape of the data
frame
there you go
so out of the 5000 tweet it has deleted
all the neutral tweets or dropped all
the neutral treats and this is the final
result
in the current cell
we have defined another function called
balanced underscore data
now this will help us get an equal
number of rows and columns and delete a
specified number of rows
let me run it all right
now
i'll call that function to delete 169
rows from the trump's data frame and 37
rows from biden's data frame this will
help us subset the data frames
you can see
we have now
2000 tweets from each of the data frames
up next we'll create some visualizations
to analyze the textual data
so first i'm using the c bond library
and creating
a distribution plot for donald trump
if i hit shift enter
you can see this is the distribution
plot this
there are bars at the back and there's a
trend line
okay
similarly let me now create a box plot
so this is
a box plot here you can see there are
some outliers
now let me add
a few cells below so that i can show
that plot for biden
so i'll write sns
dot
i'll use the function
dist plot
and under this plot i'll give
biden underscore
subset
and
i'll pass in my column that is polarity
let me run it
so this is the distribution plot for joe
biden
and now
let me also create the box plot so i'll
use the
c bond library and the box plot function
i'll pass in my data frame which is
biden underscore subset
and i'll give my column name that is
polarity
i'll run it
so here you can see the box plot for joe
biden
let me tell you how you can create a
cross table using the group by function
so before coming to this cell of code
let me insert cell above
okay
now using group by function you can
create a cross table
so i'll use
the trump underscore subset data frame
and
then i'll give my group by function
inside group by function i'll give
my expression column
and i'll
count the number of expressions
if i run this
you can see this is a cross table
similarly
you can do it for
joe biden as well
i'll just replace the
names i'll write biden
and the rest is the same
you can see
this is the cross table for biden
underscore subset
now moving ahead
let's find the polarity percentage for
negative and positive tweets to do this
i have defined a function called
poll underscore
percent
and we have two parameters declared
subset and total
let me run this
okay
now here
i am calling the above defined function
and printing the polarity percentage for
biden and trump
and i have mentioned my two parameters
subset
and the total number
so these are the values moving ahead
now let's create a bar graph that will
show the negative and positive polarity
percentage for donald trump and joe
biden
let me hit shift enter
you can see we have a
really good bar graph now if i hover the
mouse cursor you can see
donald trump had 27.825
percent of positive tweets
and
22.17 negative
similarly joe biden had
31.6 positive tweets
and
18.4 negative tweets
now we want to find the public sentiment
based on trump and biden tweets
let me run this two cells first
okay
now for donald trump the total positive
polarity is a combination of trump's
total positive percentage and biden's
negative percentage
similarly
for joe biden the total positive
polarity is a combination of biden's
total positive percentage and
trump's negative percentage
let me run this
you can see the result here
next
let's plot a horizontal bar graph to
visualize the public sentiment
we have our x and y labels defined
we also have set our bar colors with the
help of rgb values
and we have the title as well
if i go up you can see this is the
public sentiment
so
26.88
is the percentage that is in favor of
joe biden and for donald trump you have
23.11
now coming down
now in the next cell of code
we have a user defined function that
will basically plot a table which has
the most positive tweets for donald
trump and joe biden
the condition we are checking is that
the polarity should be equal to one
so if it's close to one or equal to one
which means
the tweet has positive polarity
let me run it
okay
now let me go ahead and call the
function now
let me scroll over to the top
you can see
these are the top five positive tweets
for donald trump
and
here you can see the top five positive
tweets for joe biden
likewise let's check the polarity for
most negative tweets here the condition
will be the polarity should be
equal to minus 1 which means it's highly
negative
let me run it
okay
now
let's go ahead and call the function
negative tweets so i'll write n e g
underscore
tweets
and then inside bracket i'll give my
parameters
which is trump underscore subset
and then
i'll give my title as
negative
tweets for
donald trump
okay
now
let's copy this
we'll also check for joe biden so i'll
just replace this with
biden
and let's say
negative tweet for
joe biden
let's run it
okay
if i go on top here you can see
the top
negative tweets for donald trump and
similarly we have the
top five negative tweets for
joe biden
all right
finally
let's see how to create a word cloud
now word cloud is a method to show which
words are most frequently occurring
among the given text
i have defined a function called
word cloud you can see here and it has
two parameters data and title
inside
the built-in function or the word cloud
function we have
mentioned the max font size
the maximum words
scale value there's also background
color which is white
okay
let's run it
now this will create
a word cloud
so let me go ahead and
call the word cloud function and pass in
the arguments
so i'll write
word cloud which is my user defined
function
and i'll give my parameters trump
underscore subset
comma
i'll give my title as
word
cloud
for
donald trump
let's see donald trump tweet
replies
okay
similarly
let's
do it for joe biden
write word cloud
biden underscore subset
and then i'll give the title as
word
cloud
for
joe biden
to it
replies
okay
let me run it
there you go
you can see we have a nice
word cloud
so on the top you can see the title
which says word cloud for donald trump
tweet replies
so here you can see
some of the words like real donald trump
then there's precedent
love
right
all these
similarly if i scroll down you can see
the word cloud for joe biden tweet
replies you can see there's the handle
joe biden
falls there are some
other words like do taxes believe even
will
it's fact
and you can see kamala had his name here
okay now that brings us to the end of
this demo on twitter sentiment analysis
using text data
you learned how to classify tweets and
find the polarity
we also looked at how to create
interesting visualizations
with this data and understood the mood
of the public
finally you saw how to create a word
cloud that had the most frequently
occurring words in the tweets today
we'll talk about interview questions for
machine learning now this video will
probably help you when you're attending
interviews for machine learning
positions and attempt here is to
probably consolidate 30 most commonly
asked questions and to help you in
answering these questions we tried our
best to give you the best possible
answers but of course what is more
important here is rather than the
theoretical
knowledge you need to kind of add to the
answers or supplement your answers with
your own experience so the responses
that we put here are a bit more generic
in nature so that if there are some
concepts that you are not clear this
video will help you in kind of getting
those concepts cleared up as well but
what is more important is that you need
to supplement these responses with your
own practical experience okay so with
that let's get started so one of the
first questions that you may face is
what are the different types of machine
learning now what is the best way to
respond to this there are three types of
machine learning if you read any
material you will always be told there
are three types of machine learning but
what is important is you would probably
be better off emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of machine
learning which is supervised and
unsupervised and then there is a third
type which is reinforcement learn so
supervised learning is where
you have some historical data and then
you feed that data to your model to
learn now you need to be aware of a
keyword that they will be looking for
which is labeled data right so if you
just say past data or historical data
the impact may not be so much you need
to emphasize on labeled data so what is
label data basically let's say if you
are trying to do train your model for
classification you need to be aware of
for your existing data which class each
of the observations belong to right so
that is what is labeling so it is
nothing but a fancy name you must be
already aware but just make it a point
to throw in that keyword labeled so that
will have the right impact okay so that
is what is supervised learning when you
have existing labeled data which you
then use to train your model that is
known as supervised learning and
unsupervised learning is when you don't
have this label data so you have data it
is not labeled so the system has to
figure out a way to do some analysis on
this okay so that is unsupervised
learning and you can then add a few
things like what are the ways of
performing uh supervised learning and
unsupervised learning and what are some
of the techniques so supervised learning
we we perform or we do
regression and classification and
unsupervised learning uh we do
clustering and clustering can be of
different types similarly regression can
be of different types but you don't have
to probably elaborate so much if they
are asking
for uh just the different types you can
just mention these and just at a very
high level but if they want you to
elaborate give examples then of course i
think there is a different question for
that we will see that later then the
third so we have supervised then we have
unsupervised and then reinforcement you
need to provide a little bit of
information around that as well because
it is sometimes a little difficult to
come up with a good definition for
reinforcement learning so you may have
to little bit elaborate on how
reinforcement learning works right so
reinforcement learning works in in such
a way that it basically has two parts to
it one is the agent and the environment
and the agent basically is working
inside of this environment and it is
given a target that it has to achieve
and
every time it is moving in the direction
of the target so the agent basically has
to take some action and every time it
takes an action which is moving uh the
agent towards the target right towards a
goal a target is nothing but a goal okay
then it is rewarded and every time it is
going in a direction where it is away
from the goal then it is punished so
that is the way you can
explain and
this is used primarily or very very
impactful for teaching the system to
learn games and so on examples of this
are basically used in alphago you can
throw that as an example where alphacore
used reinforcement learning to actually
learn to play the game of go and finally
it defeated the co-world champion all
right this much of information that
would be good enough okay then there
could be a question on overfitting so
the question could be what is
overfitting and how can you avoid it so
what is overfitting so let's first try
to understand the concept because
sometimes overfitting may be a little
difficult to understand overfitting is a
situation where the model has kind of
memorized the data so this is an
equivalent of memorizing the data so we
can draw an analogy so that it becomes
easy to explain this now let's say
you're teaching a child about
recognizing some fruits or something
like that okay and you're teaching this
child about recognizing let's say three
fruits apples oranges and pineapples
okay so this is a small child and for
the first time you're teaching the child
to recognize fruits then so what will
happen so this is very much like that is
your training data set so what you will
do is you will take a basket of fruits
which consists of apples oranges and
pineapples okay and
you take this basket to this child and
there may be let's say hundreds of these
fruits so you take this basket to this
child and keep showing each of this food
and then first time obviously the child
will not know what it is so you show an
apple and you say hey this is apple then
you show maybe an orange and say this is
orange and so on and so forth and then
again you keep repeating that right so
till that basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
and then the process what has happened
the child has pretty much memorized
these so even before you finish that
basket right by the time you are halfway
through the child has learnt about
recognizing the apple orange and
pineapple now what will happen after
halfway through initially you remember
it made mistakes in recognizing but
halfway through now it has learned so
every time you show a fruit it will
exactly hundred percent accurately it
will identify it will say the child will
say this is an apple this is an orange
and if you show a pineapple it will say
this is a pineapple right so that means
it has kind of memorized this data now
let's say you bring another basket of
fruits and it will have a mix of maybe
apples which were already there in the
previous set but it will also have in
addition to apple it will probably have
a banana or maybe another fruit like a
jackfruit right so this is an equivalent
of your test data set which the child
has not seen before some parts of it it
probably has seen like the apples it has
seen but this banana and jackfruit it
has not seen so then what will happen in
the first round which is an equivalent
of your training data set towards the
end it has 100 it was telling you what
the fruits are right apple was
accurately recognized orange was
accurately recognized and pineapples
were accurately recognized right so that
is like a hundred percent accuracy but
now when you get another a fresh set
which we're not part of the original one
what will happen all the apples maybe it
will be able to recognize correctly but
all the others like the jackfruit or the
banana will not be recognized by the
child right so this is an analogy this
is an equivalent of overfitting so what
has happened during the training process
it is able to recognize or reach 100
accuracy maybe very high accuracy okay
and we call that as very low loss right
so that is the technical term so the
loss is pretty much zero and accuracy is
pretty much hundred percent whereas when
you use testing there will be a huge
error which means the loss will be
pretty high and therefore the accuracy
will be also low okay this is known as
overfitting this is basically a process
where training is done training
processes it goes very well almost
reaching 100 accuracy but while testing
it really drops down now how can you
avoid it so that is a extension of this
question there are multiple ways of
avoiding overfitting there are
techniques like what you call
regularization that is the most common
technique that is used for
avoiding overfitting and within
regularization there can be a few other
subtypes like dropout in case of neural
networks and a few other examples but i
think if you give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like trick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set in machine learning model and
how is the split done so the question
can be like that so in machine learning
when we are trying to train the model so
we have a three-step process we train
the model and then we test the model and
then once we are satisfied with the test
only then we deploy the model so what
happens in the train and test is that
you remember the labeled data so let's
say you have 1000 records with labeling
information now one way of doing it is
you use all the thousand records for
training and then maybe right which
means that you have exposed all these
thousand records during the training
process and then you take a small set of
the same data and then you say okay i
will test it with this okay and then you
probably what will happen you may get
some good results all right but there is
a flaw there what is the flaw this is
very similar to human beings it is like
you are showing this model the entire
data as a part of training okay so
obviously it has become familiar with
the entire data so when you are taking a
part of that again and you are saying
that i want to test it obviously you
will get good results so that is not a
very accurate way of testing so that is
the reason what we do is we have the
label data of this thousand records or
whatever we set aside before starting
the training process we set aside a
portion of the data and we call that
test set and the remaining we call as
training set and we use only this for
training our model now the training
process remember is not just about
passing one round of this data set so
let's say now your training set has 800
records it is not just one time you pass
this 800 records what you normally do is
you actually as a part of the training
you may pass this data through the model
multiple times so this thousand records
may go through the model maybe 10 15 20
times till the training is perfect till
the accuracy is high till the errors are
minimized okay now so which is fine
which means that your that is what is
known as the model has seen your data
and gets familiar with your data and now
when you bring your test data what will
happen is this is like some new data
because that is where the real test is
now you have trained the model and now
you are testing the model with some data
which is kind of new that is like a
situation like a realistic situation
because when the model is deployed that
is what will happen it will receive some
new data not the data that it has
already seen right so this is a
realistic test so you put some new data
so this data which you have set aside is
for the model it is new and if it is
able to accurately predict the values
that means your training has worked okay
the model got trained properly but let's
say while you're testing this with this
test data you're getting lot of errors
that means you need to probably either
change your model or retrain with more
data and things like that now coming
back to the question of how do you split
this what should be the ratio there is
no fixed
number again this is like individual
preferences some people split it into 50
50 50 test and 50 training some people
prefer to have a larger amount for
training and a smaller amount for test
so they can go by either 60 40 or 70 30
or some people even go with some odd
numbers like 65 35 or
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something that the
ratio has to be this you can go by your
individual preferences all right then
you may have questions around data
handling data manipulation
or what you call data management or
preparation so these are all some
questions around that area there is
again no one answer one single good
answer to this it really varies from
situation to situation and depending on
what exactly is the problem what kind of
data it is how critical it is what kind
of data is missing and what is the type
of corruption so the whole lot of things
this is a very generic question and
therefore you need to be little careful
about responding to this as well so
probably have to illustrate this again
if you have experience in doing this
kind of work in handling data you can
illustrate with example saying that i
was on one project where i received this
kind of data these were the columns
where data was not filled or these were
the this many rows where the data was
missing that would be in fact the
perfect way to respond to this question
but if you don't have that obviously you
have to provide some good answer i think
it really depends on what exactly the
situation is and there are multiple ways
of handling the missing data or corrupt
data now let's take a few examples now
let's say you have data where some
values in some of the columns are
missing and you have pretty much half of
your data having these missing values in
terms of number of rows okay that could
be one situation another situation could
be that you have records or data missing
but
when you do some initial calculation how
many records are correct or how many
rows or observations as we call it has
this missing data let's assume it is
very minimal like 10
okay now
between these two cases how do i so
let's assume that this is not a mission
critical situation and in order to fix
this 10 percent of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also time and
money right so
it is not so mission critical and it is
okay to let's say get rid of these
records so obviously one of the easiest
ways of handling the data part or
missing data is remove those records or
remove those observations from your
analysis so that is the easiest way to
do but then the downside is as i said in
as in the first case if let's say 50
percent of your data is like that
because some column or the other is
missing so it is not like every in every
place in every row the same column is
missing but you have in maybe ten
percent of the records column one is
missing and another ten percent column
two is missing another ten percent
column three is missing so on and so
forth so it adds up to maybe half of
your data set so you cannot completely
remove half of your data set then the
whole purpose is lost okay so then how
do you handle then you need to come up
with ways of filling up this data with
some meaningful value right that is one
way of handling so when we say
meaningful value what is that meaningful
let's say for a particular column you
might want to take a mean value for that
column and fill wherever the data is
missing fill up with that mean value so
that when you're doing the calculations
your analysis is not completely way off
so you have values which are not missing
first of all so your system will work
number two these values are not so
completely out of whack that your whole
analysis goes for a task right there may
be situations where if the missing
values instead of putting mean may be a
good idea to fill it up with the minimum
value or with a zero so or with the
maximum value again as i said there are
so many possibilities so there is no
like one correct answer for this you
need to basically talk around this and
illustrate with your experience as i
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
question okay so
then the next question can be how can
you choose a classifier based on a
training set data size so again this is
one of those questions uh where you
probably do not have like a
one-size-fits-all answer first of all
you
may not let's say
decide your classifier based on the
training set size maybe not the best way
to decide the type of the classifier and
even if you have to there are probably
some thumb rules which we can use but
then again every time so in my opinion
the best way to respond to this question
is you need to try out few classifiers
irrespective of the size of the data and
you need to then decide on your
particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so
you will never be able to just by if
somebody defines a problem to you and
somebody even if they show the data to
you or tell you what is the data or even
the size of the data i don't think there
is a way to really say that yes this is
the classifier that will work here no
that's not the right way so you need to
still
you know test it out get the data try
out a couple of classifiers and then
only you will be in a position to decide
which classifier to use you try out
multiple classifiers see which one gives
the best accuracy and only then you can
decide then you can have a question
around confusion matrix so the question
can be explained confusion matrix right
so confusion matrix i think the best way
to explain it is by taking an example
and drawing like a small diagram
otherwise it can really become tricky so
my suggestion is to take a piece of pen
and paper and
explain it by drawing a small matrix and
confusion matrix is about to find out
this is used especially in
classification
learning process and when you get the
results and our model predicts the
results you compare it with the actual
value and try to find out what is the
accuracy okay so in this case let's say
this is an example of a confusion matrix
and
it is a binary matrix so you have the
actual values which is the labeled data
right and which is so you have how many
yes and how many no so you have that
equation and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many know
right so the total actual values the
total yes is 12 plus 130 and they are
shown here and the actual value those
are 9 plus 3 12 okay so that is what
this information here is so this is
about the actual and this is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 plus 3 15 yeses and
no are one plus nine ten nodes okay so
this is the way to look at this
confusion matrix okay and
out of this what is the meaning convey
so there are two or three things that
needs to be explained outright the first
thing is for a model to be accurate the
values across the diagonal should be
high like in this case right that is one
number two the total sum of these values
is equal to the total observations in
the test data set so in this case for
example you have 12 plus 3 15 plus 10 25
so that means we have 25 observations in
our test data set okay so these are the
two things you need to first explain
that the total sum in this matrix the
numbers is equal to the size of the test
data set and the diagonal values
indicate the accuracy so by just by
looking at it you can probably have a
idea about is this uh an accurate model
is the model being accurate if they're
all spread out equally in all these four
boxes that means probably the accuracy
is not very good okay now how do you
calculate the accuracy itself right how
do you calculate the accuracy itself so
it is a very simple mathematical
calculation you take some of the
diagonals right so in this case it is 9
plus 12 21 and divided by the total so
in this case what will it be let me take
a pen so your your diagonal values is
equal to if i say d is equal to 12 plus
9 so that is 21 right and the total data
set is equal to right we just calculated
it is 25 so what is your accuracy it is
21 by your accuracy is equal to 21 by 25
and this turns out to be about 85
percent right so this is 85
so that is our accuracy okay so this is
the way you need to explain draw diagram
give an example and maybe it may be a
good idea to be prepared with an example
so that it becomes easy for you don't
have to calculate those numbers on the
fly right so a couple of uh hints are
that you take some numbers which are
with which add up to 100 that is always
a good idea so you don't have to really
do this complex calculations so the
total value will be 100 and then
diagonal values you divide once you find
the diagonal values that is equal to
your percentage okay all right so
the next question can be a related
question about
false positive and false negative so
what is false positive and what is false
negative now once again the best way to
explain this is using a piece of paper
and pen otherwise it will be pretty
difficult to explain this so we use the
same example of the confusion matrix
and
we can explain that so a confusion
matrix looks somewhat like this and
when we just take yeah it looks somewhat
like this and we continue with the
previous example where this is the
actual value this is the predicted value
and
in the actual value we have 12 plus 1 13
yeses and 3 plus 9 12 nos and the
predicted values there are 12 plus 3 15
yeses and
1 plus 9 10 nos okay now this particular
case which is the false positive what is
a false positive first of all the second
word which is positive okay is referring
to the predicted value so that means the
system has predicted it as a positive
but the real value so this is what the
false comes from but the real value is
not positive okay that is the way you
should understand this term false
positive or even false negative so false
positive so positive is what your system
has predicted so where is that system
predicted this is the one positive is
what yes so you basically consider this
row okay now if you consider this row so
this is this is all positive values this
entire row is positive values okay now
the false positive is the one which
where the value actual value is negative
predicted value is positive but the
actual value is negative so this is a
false positive right and here is a true
positive so the predicted value is
positive and the actual value is also
positive okay i hope this is making
sense now let's take a look at what is
false negative false negative so
negative is the second term that means
that is the predicted value that we need
to look for so which are the predicted
negative values this row corresponds to
predicted negative values all right so
this row corresponds to predicted
negative values and what they are asking
for false so this is the row for
predicted negative values and the actual
value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is the way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right 9 is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then
you might have a question like what are
the
steps involved in the machine learning
process or what are the three steps in
the process of developing a machine
learning model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model happens is like this so first of
all you try to understand the problem
and try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably decide
that there is one particular algorithm
which is most suitable usually it
happens through trial and error process
but at some point you will decide that
okay this is the model we are going to
use okay so in that case we have the
model algorithm and the model decided
and then you need to do the process of
training the model and testing the model
and this is where if it is supervised
learning you split your data the label
data into training data set and test
data set and you use the training data
set to train your model and then you use
the test data set to check the accuracy
whether it is working fine or not so you
test the model before you actually put
it into production right so once you
test the model you're satisfied it's
working fine then you go to the next
level which is putting it for production
and then in production obviously new
data will come and
the inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values whether it is
regression or classification now so this
can be an iterative process so it is not
a straightforward process where you do
the training through the testing and
then you move it to production now so
during the training and test process
there may be a situation where because
of either overfitting or things like
that the test doesn't go through which
means that you need to put that back
into the training process so that can be
an iterative process not only that even
if the training and test goes through
properly and you deploy the model in
production there can be a situation that
the data that actually comes the real
data that comes with that this model is
failing so in which case you may have to
once again go back to the drawing board
or initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will deteriorate so
that is again a recursive process so
once in a while you need to keep
checking whether the model is working
fine or not and if required you need to
tweak it and modify it and so on and so
forth so net net this is a continuous
process of
tweaking the model and testing it and
making sure it is up to date then you
might have question around deep learning
so because deep learning is now
associated with ai artificial
intelligence and so on so can be as
simple as what is deep learning so i
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and
then obviously the question would be
then what is the difference right so
deep learning you need to mention there
are two key parts that interviewer will
be looking for when you are defining
deep learning so first is of course deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
so machine learning is still the bigger
let's say uh scope and deep learning is
one part of it so then what exactly is
the difference deep learning is
primarily when we are implementing these
our algorithms or when we are using
neural networks for doing our training
and classification and regression and
all that right so when we use neural
network then it is considered as deep
learning and the term deep comes from
the fact that you can have several
layers of neural networks and these are
called deep neural networks and
therefore the term deep
deep learning the other difference
between machine learning and deep
learning which the interviewer may be
wanting to hear is that in case of
machine learning the feature engineering
is done manually what do we mean by
feature engineering basically when we
are trying to train our model we have
our training data right so we have our
training label data and
this data has several let's say if it is
a regular table it has several columns
now each of these columns actually has
information about a feature right so if
we are trying to predict the height
weight and so on and so forth so these
are all features of human beings let's
say we have census data and we have all
this so those are the features now there
may be probably 50 or 100 in some cases
there may be 100 such features now all
of them do not contribute to our model
right so we as a data scientist we have
to decide whether we should take all of
them all the features or we should throw
away some of them because again if we
take all of them number one of course
your accuracy will probably get affected
but also there is a computational part
so if you have so many pictures and then
you have so much data it becomes very
tricky so in case of machine learning we
manually take care of identifying the
features that do not contribute to the
learning process and thereby we
eliminate those features and so on right
so this is known as feature engineering
and in machine learning we do that
manually whereas in deep learning where
we use neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably
will add value to your response all
right so the next question is what is
the difference
between or what are the differences
between machine learning and deep
learning so here this is a quick
comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
missions to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and
it needs only a small amount of data for
training and then works well on low end
systems so you don't need large machines
and most features need to be identified
in advance and manually coded so
basically the feature engineering part
is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural
lines so that is the key differentiator
between machine learning and deep
learning and usually deep learning
involves a large amount of data and
therefore the training also requires
usually the training process requires
high-end machines because it needs a lot
of computing power and the machine
learning features are the or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end-to-end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of a question
then you might get a question around the
uses of machine learning or some real
life applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but
the meaning is how exactly is machine
learning used or actually supervised
machine learning it could be a very
specific question around supervised
decision learning so this is like give
examples of supervised machine learning
use of supervised machine learning in
modern business so that could be the
next question so there are quite a few
examples or quite a few use cases if you
will for supervised machine learning the
very common one is email spam detection
so you want to train your application or
your system to detect between spam and
non-spam so this is a very common
business application of supervised
machine learning so how does this work
the way it works is that you obviously
have historical data about of your
emails and they are categorized as spam
and not spam so that is what is the
labeled information and then you feed
this information or the all these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have label data you already have emails
which are tagged as spam or not spam and
then you use that to train your model
right so this is one example now there
are a few industry specific applications
for supervised machine learning one of
the very common ones is in healthcare
diagnostics in healthcare diagnostics
you have these images and you want to
train models to detect whether from a
particular image whether it can find out
if the person is sick or not whether a
person has cancer or not right so this
is a very good example of supervised
machine learning here the way it works
is that existing images it could be
x-ray images it be mri or any of these
images are available and they are tagged
saying that okay this x-ray image is
deflective or the person as an illness
or it could be cancer whichever illness
right so it is tagged as defective or
clear or good image and defective
something like that so we come up with a
binary or it could be multi-class as
well saying that this is defective to 10
percent this is 25 and so on but let's
keep it simple you can give an example
of just a binary classification that
would be good enough so
you can say that in healthcare
diagnostics using image we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when new
image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so i think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
unsupervised then so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
part of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of diagnostic images we can
just let's say take x-ray images now
there are actually millions of x-ray
images available all over the world but
the problem is they are not labeled so
their images are there but whether it is
effective or whether it is good and
information is not available along with
it right in a form that it can be used
by a machine which means that somebody
has to take a look at these images and
usually it should be like a doctor and
then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where
semi-supervised learning comes into play
so what happens is there is a large
amount of data maybe a part of it is
labeled then we try some techniques to
label the remaining part of the data so
that we get completely labeled data and
then we train our model so i know this
is a little long winding explanation but
unfortunately there is no
quick and easy definition for
semi-supervised machine learning this is
the only way probably to explain this
concept
we may have another question as
what are unsupervised machine learning
techniques or what are some of the
techniques used for performing
unsupervised machine learning so it can
be worded in different ways so how do we
answer this question so unsupervised
learning you can say that there are two
types clustering and association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is
clustering then association you can i
think the best way to explain
association is with an example in case
of association you try to find out how
the items are linked to each other so
for example if somebody bought
maybe a laptop the person has also
purchased a mouse so this is more in an
e-commerce scenario for example so you
can give this as an example so people
who are buying and laptops are also
buying the mouse so that means there is
an association between laptops and mouse
or maybe people who are buying bread are
also buying butter so that is a
association that can be created so this
is unsupervised learning one of the
techniques okay all right then we have
very fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so machine
learning these are the two main types of
machine learning supervised and unsized
and in case of supervised and again here
probably the key word that the person
may be wanting to hear is labeled data
now very often people say we have
historical data and if we run it it is
supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot use it for supervised
learning so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
label okay so when we have labeled data
for training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have label data then we use unsupervised
learning and there are different
algorithms available to perform both of
these types of trainings so
there can be another question a little
bit more theoretical and conceptual in
nature this is about inductive machine
learning and
deductive machine learning so the
question can be what is the difference
between inductive machine learning and
deductive machine learning or
somewhat in that manner so the exact
phrase or exact question can vary they
can ask for examples and things like
that but that could be the question so
let's first understand what is inductive
and deductive training inductive
training is induced by somebody and you
can illustrate that with a small example
i think that always helps so whenever
you're doing some explanation try as
much as possible as i said to give
examples from your work experience or
give some analogies and that will also
help a lot in explaining as well and for
the interviewer also to understand so
here we'll take an example or rather we
will use an analogy so inductive
training is when we induce some
knowledge or the learning process into a
person without the person actually
experiencing it okay what can be an
example so we can probably tell the
person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage right so this is
inductive learning compared to that what
is deductive learning so here you draw a
conclusion or the person draws
conclusion out of experience so we will
stick to the analogy so compared to the
showing a video let's assume a person is
allowed to play with fire right and then
he figures out that if he puts his
finger it's burning or if throw
something into the fire it burns so he
is learning through experience so this
is known as deductive learning okay so
you can have applications or models that
can be trained using inductive learning
or deductive learning all right i think
uh probably that explanation will be
sufficient
the next question is are knn and k means
clustering similar to one another or are
they same right because the letter k is
kind of common between them okay so let
us take a little while
k being common between them k n is
completely different k means clustering
is completely different k n n is a
classification process and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k means clustering is
actually
unsupervised okay when you have k and n
when you want to implement k n which is
basically k nearest neighbors the value
of k is a number so you can say k is
equal to 3 you want to implement k n n
with k is equal to 3 so which means that
it performs the classification in such a
way that how does it perform the
classification so it will take three
nearest objects and that's why it's
called nearest neighbor so basically
based on the distance it will try to
find out its nearest objects that are
let's say three of the nearest objects
and then it will check whether the class
they belong to which class right so if
all three belong to one particular class
obviously this new object is also
classified as that particular class but
it is possible that they may be from two
or three different classes okay so let's
say they are from two classes and then
if they are from two classes now usually
you take a odd number you assign a odd
number to so if there are three of them
and two of them belong to one class and
then one belongs to another class so
this new object is assigned to the class
to which the two of them belong now the
value of k is sometimes tricky whether
should you use three should you use five
should you use seven that can be tricky
because the ultimate classification can
also vary so it's possible that if
you're taking k as three the object is
probably in one particular class but if
you take k is equal to five maybe the
object will belong to a different class
because when you are taking three of
them probably two of them belong to a
class one and one belong to class two
whereas when you take five of them it is
possible that only two of them belong to
class one and three of them belong to
class two so which means that this
object will belong to class two right so
you see that so it is the class
allocation can vary depending on the
value of k now k means on the other hand
is a clustering process and it is
unsupervised where what it does is the
system will basically identify how the
objects are how close the objects are
with respect to some of their features
okay and but the similarity of course is
the the letter k and in case of k means
also we specify its value and it could
be three or five or seven there is no
technical limit as such but it can be
any number of clusters that you can
create okay so based on the value that
you provide the system will create that
many clusters of similar objects so
there is a similarity to that extent
that k is a number in both the cases but
actually these two are completely
different processes
we have what is known as naive bayes
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive bayes is the name of
the person who found this
classifier in order to develop this
classifier which is not 100 true base is
the name of the person bayes is the name
of the person but naive is not the name
of the person right so naive is
basically an english word and that has
been added here because of the nature of
this particular classifier naive bayes
classifier is a probability based
classifier and
it makes some assumptions that presence
of one feature of a class is not related
to the presence of any other feature of
maybe other classes right so which is
not a very strong or not a very what do
you say accurate assumption because
these features can be related and so on
but even if we go with this assumption
this whole algorithm works very well
even with this assumption and that is
the good side of it but the term comes
from that so that is the explanation
that you can
then there can be question around
reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement
learning or it can be any game so the
best way to explain this is again to
talk a little bit about what
reinforcement learning is about and then
elaborate on that to explain the process
so first of all reinforcement learning
has an environment and an agent and the
agent is basically performing some
actions in order to achieve a certain
goal and this goals can be anything
either if it is related to game then the
goal could be that you have to score
very high score a high value high number
or it could be that your number of lives
should be as high as possible don't lose
life so this could be some of them more
advanced examples could be for driving
the automotive industry self-driving
cars they actually also make use of
reinforcement learning to teach the car
how to navigate through the roads and so
on and so forth that is also another
example now how does it work so if the
system is basically there is an agent
and environment and every time the agent
takes a step or performs a task which is
taking it towards the goal the final
goal let's say to maximize the score or
to minimize the number of lives and so
on or minimize the debts for example it
is rewarded and every time it takes a
step which goes against that code right
contrary or the reverse direction it is
penalized okay so it is like a carrot
and a stick system now how do you use
this to create a game of chess or to
create a system to play a game of chess
now the way this works is and this could
probably go back to this alphago example
where alphago defeated a human champion
so the way it works is in reinforcement
learning the system is allowed for
example in this case we are talking
about chess so we allow the system to
first of all watch playing a game of
chess so it could be with the human
being or it could be the system itself
there are computer games of chess right
so
either this new learning system has to
watch that game or watch a human being
play the game because this is
reinforcement learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent works on that
so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to start playing
the game so it pretty much starts from
scratch okay and as it moves forward it
it's at right at the beginning and the
system really knows nothing about the
game of chess okay so initially it is a
clean slate it just starts by observing
how you're playing so it will make some
random moves and keep losing badly but
then what happens is over a period of
time so you need to now allow the system
or you need to play with the system not
just one two three four or five times
but hundreds of times thousands of times
maybe even hundreds of thousands of
times and that's exactly how alphago has
done it played millions of games between
itself and the system right so for the
game of chess also you need to do
something like that you need to allow
the system to purchase and then learn on
its own over a period of repetition so i
think you can probably explain it to
this much to this extent and it should
be
sufficient
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming into picture so the
question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem i would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm i am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably
let's say limit the number of algorithms
but now within the classification
algorithms you have decision trees you
have svm you have logistic regression is
it possible to outright say yes so for
this particular problem since you have
explained this now this is the exact
algorithm that you can use that is not
possible okay so we have to try out a
bunch of algorithms see which one gives
us the best performance best accuracy
and then decide to go with that
particular algorithm so in machine
learning a lot of it happens through
trial and error there is no real
possibility that anybody can just by
looking at the problem or understanding
the problem tell you that okay in this
particular situation this is exactly the
algorithm that you should use then the
questions may be around application of
machine learning and this question is
specifically around how amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does the recommendation
engine work so this is basically the
question is all about so the
recommendation engine again works based
on various inputs that are provided
obviously something like uh you know
amazon a website or e-commerce site like
amazon collects a lot of data around the
customer behavior who is purchasing what
and if somebody is buying a particular
thing they are also buying something
else so this kind of association right
so this is the unsupervised learning we
talked about they use this to associate
and link or relate items and that is one
part of it so they kind of build
association between items saying that
somebody buying this is also buying this
that is one part of it then they also
profile the users right based on their
age their gender their geographic
location they will do some profiling and
then when somebody is logging in and
when somebody is shopping kind of the
mapping of these two things are done
they try to identify obviously if you
have logged in then they know who you
are and your information is available
like for example your age may be your
agenda and where you're located what you
purchased earlier right so all this is
taken and the recommendation engine
basically uses all this information and
comes up with recommendations for a
particular user so that is how the
recommendation engine work all right
then the question can be uh something
very basic like when will you go for
classification versus regression right
when do you do classification instead of
regression or when you use
classification instead of regression now
yes so so this is basically going back
to the understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values and other is the
continuous values so for regression if
you are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if you
are trying to find some discrete values
you use classification and then you need
to illustrate what are some of the
examples so classification is like let's
say there are images and you need to put
them into classes like cat dog elephant
tiger something like that so that is a
classification a problem or it can be
that is a multi-class classification
problem it could be binary
classification problem like for example
whether a customer will buy or he will
not buy that is a classification binary
classification it can be in the weather
forecast area now weather forecast is
again a combination of regression and
classification because on the one hand
you want to predict whether it's going
to rain or not that's a classification
problem that's a binary classification
right whether it's going to rain or not
rain however you also have to predict
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow right now temperature is a
continuous value you can't answer the
temperature in a yes or no kind of a
response right so what will be the
temperature tomorrow so you need to give
a number which can be like 20 degrees 30
degrees or whatever right so that is
where you use regression one more
example is stock price prediction so
that is where again you will use
regression so these are the various
examples so you need to illustrate with
examples and make sure you include those
keywords like discrete and continuous so
the next question is more about a little
bit of a design related question to
understand your concepts and things like
that so it is how will you design a spam
filter so how do you basically design or
develop a spam filter so i think the
main thing here is he is looking at
probably understanding your concepts in
terms of what is the algorithm you will
use or what is your understanding about
difference between classification and
regression
and things like that and the process of
course the methodology and the process
so the best way to go about responding
to this is we say that okay this is a
classification problem because we want
to find out whether an email is a spam
or not spam so that we can apply the
filter accordingly so first thing is to
identify what type of a problem it is so
we have identified that it is a
classification then the second step may
be to find out what kind of algorithm to
use now since this is a binary
classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as i said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support vector missions for
example svm so we will kind of list down
a few of these algorithms and we will
say okay we want we would like to try
out these algorithms and then we go
about taking your historical data which
is the labeled data which are marked so
you will have a bunch of emails and then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used or rather
the model actually
so and you actually will have three
models let's say you are trying to test
out three algorithms so you will
obviously have three models so you need
to try all three models and test them
out as well see which one gives the best
accuracy and then you decide that you
will go with that model okay so training
and tests will be done and then you zero
in on one particular model and then you
say okay this is the model will you use
we will use and then go ahead and
implement that or put that in production
so that is the way you design a spam
file the next question is about random
forest what is random forest so this is
a very straightforward question however
the response you need to be again a
little careful while we all know what is
random forest explaining this can
sometimes be tricky so one thing is
random forest is kind of in one way it
is an extension of decision trees
because it is basically nothing but you
have multiple decision trees and
trees will basically you will use for
doing if it is classification mostly it
is classification you will use the trees
for classification and then you use
voting for finding the the final class
so that is the underlyings but how will
you explain this how will you respond to
this so first thing obviously we will
say that random forest is one of the
algorithms and the more important thing
that you need to probably the
interviewer is waiting to hear is
ensemble learner right so this is one
type of ensemble learner what is
ensemble learner ensemble learner is
like a combination of algorithms so it
is a learner which consists of more than
one algorithm or more than one maybe
models okay so in case of random forest
the algorithm is the same but instead of
using one instance of it we use multiple
instances of it and we use so in a way
that is a random forest is an ensemble
learner there are other types of
ensemble learners where we have like we
use different algorithms itself so you
have one maybe logistic regression and a
decision tree combined together and so
on and so forth or there are other ways
like for example splitting the data in a
certain way and so on so that's all
about ensembl we will not go into that
but random foreign i think the
interviewer will be happy to hear this
word ensemble learners and so then you
go and explain how the random forest
works so if the random forest is used
for classification then we use what is
known as a voting mechanism so basically
how does it work let's say your random
forest consists of 100 trees okay and
each observation you pass through this
forest and each observation let's say it
is a classification problem binary
classification 0 or 1 and you have 100
trees now if 90 trees say that it is a 0
and 10 of the trees say it is a 1 you
take the majority you may take a vote
and since 90 of them are saying 0 you
classify this as 0 then you take the
next observation and so on so that is
the way uh random forest works for
classification if it is a regression
problem but somewhat similar but only
thing is instead of vote what we will do
is sorry in regression remember what
happens you actually calculate a value
right so for example you're using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
100 trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
forest right so you have outputs of
individual trees which are a part of
this forest but then you need to find
the final output of the forest itself so
how do you do that so in case of
regression you take like an average or
the mean of all the 100 trees right so
this is also a way of reducing the error
so maybe if you have only one tree and
if that one tree makes a error it is
basically 100 percent wrong or 100 right
right but if you have on the other hand
if you have a bunch of trees you are
basically mitigating that
reducing that error okay so that is the
way random forest works so the next
question is considering the long list of
machine learning algorithms how will you
decide on which one to use so once again
here there is no way to outright say
that this is the algorithm that we will
use for a given data set this is a very
good question but then the response has
to be like again there will not be a one
size fits all so we need to first of all
you can probably shorten the list in
terms of by saying okay whether it is a
classification problem or it is a
regression problem to that extent you
can probably shorten the list because
you don't have to use all of them if it
is a classification problem you only can
pick from the classification algorithms
right so for example if it's a
classification you cannot use linear
regression algorithm there or if it is a
regression problem you cannot use svm or
maybe now you can use svm but maybe a
logistic regression right so to that
extent you can probably shorten the list
but still you will not be able to 100
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that i am going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on what the problem is
you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accuracy and based on that you
choose that particular algorithm okay
all right then they can be questions
around bias and variance so the question
can be what is bias and variance in
machine learning so you just need to
give out a definition for each of these
for example a bias in machine learning
it occurs when the predicted values are
far away from the actual values so that
is a bias okay and whereas they are all
all the values are probably they are far
off but they are very near to each other
though the predicted values are close to
each other right while they are far off
from the actual value but they are close
to each other you see the difference so
that is bias and then the other part is
your variance now variance is when the
predicted values are all over the place
right so
the variance is high that means it may
be close to the target but it is kind of
very scattered so the points the
predicted values are not close to each
other right in case of buyers the
predicted values are close to each other
but they are not close to the target but
here they may be close to the target but
they may not be close to each other so
they are a little bit more scattered so
that is what in case of a variance okay
then the next question is about again
related to bias and variance what is the
trade-off between bias and variance yes
i think this is a interesting question
because these two are heading in
different directions so for example if
you try to minimize the bias variance
will keep going high and if you try to
minimize the variance bias will keep
going high and there is no way you can
minimize both of them so you need to
have a trade-off saying that okay this
is the level at which i will have my
bias and this is the level at which i
will have variance so the trade-off is
that pretty much attack you you decide
what is the level you will tolerate for
your bias and what is the level you will
tolerate for variance and a combination
of these two in such a way that your
final results are not way off and having
a trade-off will ensure that the results
are consistent right so that is
basically the output is consistent and
which means that they are close to each
other and they are also accurate that
means they are as close to the target as
possible right so if either of these is
high then one of them will go off the
track define precision and recall now
again here i think it would be best to
draw a diagram and take
the confusion matrix and it is very
simple the definition is like a formula
your precision is true positive by true
positive plus false positive and your
recall is true positive by true positive
plus false negative okay so that's you
can just show it in a mathematical way
that's pretty much you know that can be
shown that's the easiest way to define
so the next question can be about
decision tree what is decision tree
pruning and why is it so
basically decision trees are really
simple to implement and understand but
one of the drawbacks of decision trees
is that it can become
highly complicated as it grows right and
the rules and the conditions can become
very complicated and this can also lead
to overfitting which is basically that
during training you will get 100
accuracy but when you are doing testing
you will get a lot of errors so that is
the reason
pruning needs to be done so the purpose
or the reason for doing
decision tree pruning is to reduce
overfitting or to cut down on
overfitting and
what is decision tree pruning it is
basically that you reduce the number of
branches because as you may be aware a
tree consists of the root node and then
there are several internal nodes and
then you have the leaf nodes now if
there are too many of these internal
nodes that is when you face the problem
of overfitting and pruning is the
process of reducing those internal nodes
all right so the next question can be
what is logistic regression uh so
basically logistic regression is um one
of the techniques used for performing
classification especially binary
classification now there is something
special about logistic regression and
there are a couple of things you need to
be careful about first of all the name
is a little confusing it is called
logistic regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if it's
really you know if it is required and
they can also ask this like a trick
question right so that is one part
second thing is the term logistic has
nothing to do with the usual logistics
that we talk about but it is derived
from log so that the mathematical
derivation involves log and therefore
the name logistic regression so what is
logistic regression and how is it used
so logistic regression is used for
binary classification and the output of
a logistic regression is either a 0 or a
1 and it varies so it's basically it
calculates a probability between 0 and 1
and we can set a threshold that can vary
typically it is 0.5 so any value above
0.5 is considered as 1 and if the
probability is below 0.5 it is
considered as zero so that is the way we
calculate the probability or the system
calculates the probability and based on
the threshold it sets a value of zero or
one which is like a binary
classification zero or one okay then we
have a question around k nearest
neighbor algorithm so explain k nearest
neighbor algorithm so first of all what
is a k nearest neighbor algorithm this
is a classification algorithm so that is
the first thing we need to mention and
we also need to mention that the k is a
number it is an integer and this is
variable and we can define what the
value of k should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we need to mention
technically it can be even number also
but then typically it would be odd
number and we will see why that is okay
so based on that we need to classify
objects okay we need to classify objects
so again it will be very helpful to draw
a diagram you know if you're explaining
i think that will be the best way so
draw some diagram like this and let's
say we have three clusters or three
classes existing and now you want to
find for a new item that has come you
want to find out which class this
belongs to right so you go about as the
name suggests it you go about finding
the nearest neighbors right the points
which are closest to this and how many
of them you will find that is what is
defined by k now let's say our initial
value of k was five
so you will find the k the five nearest
data points so in this case as it is
illustrated these are the five nearest
data points but then all five do not
belong to the same class or cluster so
there are one belonging to this cluster
one the second one belonging to this
cluster two three of them belonging to
this third cluster so how do you decide
that's exactly the reason we should as
much as possible try to assign an odd
number so that it becomes easier to
assign this so in this case you see that
the majority actually if there are
multiple classes then you go with the
majority so since three of these items
belong to this class we assign which is
basically the in in this case the green
or the tennis or the third cluster as i
was talking about right so we assign it
to this third class so in this case it
is uh that's how it is decided okay so k
nearest neighbor so first thing is to
identify the number of neighbors that
are mentioned as k so in this case it is
k is equal to 5 so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that and and then the
new data point is assigned to that class
okay so that's pretty much how k nearest
neighbors work welcome to this video on
machine learning roadmap 2021
ai and machine learning have been the
top burst words in 2020. machine
learning can be an interesting career
move for programmers developers and
other professionals looking for a shift
in their career
over the last few years machine learning
and artificial intelligence together
have become a crucial component in many
of the world's most popular business
applications
as we approach 2021 it's a good time for
us to take a look at the machine
learning roadmap for 2021. in this video
we will discuss the basics of machine
learning and the company is actively
hiring for machine learning roles you
will understand the skills required to
become a machine learning expert in 2021
the salary of a machine learning
engineer and how simply learn can help
you get certified in machine learning
now let's look at what machine learning
is
machine learning is an application of
artificial intelligence that allows
systems to learn from vast volumes of
data
it enables you to process analyze and
train machines using data and create
models to solve business problems
machine learning has the potential to
learn from structured semi-structured
and unstructured data
there are various supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
algorithms used to build machine
learning models
some of the most popular machine
learning algorithms are linear
regression logistic regression support
vector machines k nearest neighbors k
means clustering knife base and others
now some of the top companies hiring for
machine learning roles are microsoft
spotify google cell
ericsson oracle and walmart
there are numerous product based service
based as well as startup companies that
are hiring for machine learning
positions now learning machine learning
can position an individual for a variety
of exciting careers in a growing number
of industries
with machine learning becoming more
widely accepted and adapted technology
let's look at the important skills you
need to know to become a machine
learning expert in 2021
first we have programming machine
learning mostly depends on algorithms
which means one should possess sound
knowledge of different programming
languages such as python and r
you should have knowledge of basic
programming concepts and understand data
structures this will help you write
better and efficient codes you should
also know about searching sorting and
optimization algorithms the second skill
you need to know is mathematics and
statistics
statistics is the backbone of data
analytics you should have knowledge of
various measures such as mean median
variance etc distributions such as
uniform normal binomial poison etc and
analysis methods such as anova manova
t-test chi-square test hypothesis
testing and others
now this is required for building and
validating models from observed data a
basic understanding of high school
mathematics will help you understand how
machine learning algorithms work
the topics include probability linear
algebra and calculus the third skill you
need to know is database and sql
very often machine learning tasks are
carried out using data stored in the
form of tables that are present in
database servers
so it's important to know about
databases and sql good understanding of
relational databases and no databases
such as mysql postgresql oracle database
microsoft sql server is vital to store
manipulate retrieve and handle
structured data now we have data
wrangling
now there's a lot of pre-processing of
data that is needed before you start
building your machine learning model
collecting the data cleaning it
identifying the problems asking the
right questions and formatting the data
are crucial steps in machine learning
you should have knowledge of libraries
and packages such as numpy pandas plier
deep flyer and idea to perform data
wrangling next we have data
visualization while working on any
machine learning problem it's important
to understand the data well data
visualization and exploratory data
analysis skills are very important to
show the hidden trends and insights in a
visual form using various charts and
graphs this will help you find out
unseen patterns in the data
you need to have experience with
matplotlib c-bond plotly and ggplot
libraries
it would be an advantage to know bi
tools such as tableau and power bi
finally
the most important skill is machine
learning itself
you need to learn different machine
learning techniques and algorithms that
are widely used to solve business
problems
then implement the algorithms using
python and r libraries such as
scikit-learn tensorflow garrett and mlr
having knowledge of natural language
processing computer vision and time
series analysis would be a really good
advantage
to gain more experience in solving real
world problems you need to work on small
projects using variety of data sets
data science and machine learning
challenges such as those on github and
kegel are a great way to get exposed to
different kinds of problems and their
nuances now talking about the salary of
a machine learning engineer
according to glassdoor in the united
states a machine learning engineer can
earn around 114 thousand dollars per
annum
while in india you can earn nearly 7
lakh 73 000 rupees per annum this salary
may vary based on your experience the
industry you are applying for and the
company policy now moving on to the
final section
let me tell you how simply learn can
help you start your career in machine
learning
so let me take you to our website first
okay so i am on the chrome browser
let me search for simplylearn.com
and here
under what you want to learn let me type
machine learning it will show me the
relevant courses that simply learn
offers
in the machine learning category
so you can see here there are multiple
courses
first let me open the
first link
and let's open the second link as well
so
so this is the post graduate program in
ai in machine learning which is in
collaboration with purdue university and
ibm
if i scroll down
you can see the key features of this
course
so we'll get purdue alumni association
membership
industry recognized ibm certificates
enrollment to simply launch job assist
there's 25 plus hands-on projects on gpu
enabled labs you have
450 plus hours of applied learning
capstone projects in three domains and
much more
and here you can see on the right this
is the certificate that you will get
after completing this program
and you will also get
certificates recognized by ibm
and another key feature of this course
is you can enroll to simply learn job
assist program so you will get im jobs
crew membership for six months resume
assistance and career monitoring there's
interview preparation and career affairs
if i scroll further here you can see the
learning path
and you will learn about python for data
science
this machine learning
deep learning with tensorflow and carers
that's advanced deep learning and
computer vision you will also learn
about natural language processing that
is nlp and speech recognition
we have reinforcement learning
and you also have the opportunity to
select a few electives so we have ibm
watson for chat bots machine learning
with r there's git and github training
and two others
here you can see
the skills that will be covered so you
will learn about statistics which is a
core component of machine learning we
learn about python supervised learning
there's dance computer vision tensorflow
there's reinforcement learning speech
recognition you will also learn about
numpy pandas and other libraries
and here you can see these are some of
the tools that will be covered in this
course
if i scroll further now this is the
important section you can see the
industry projects that you will get to
work on
so this is
on twitter there's one on zumato one on
uber
and mercedes benz as well
now they are our course advisors
so please go ahead and enroll to this
postgraduate program in ai machine
learning if you want to kick start your
career in
machine learning
now the next course we have is machine
learning certification course if i
scroll down you can see the details of
this course
so you will gain expertise with 25 plus
hands-on exercises you will get to work
on four real-life industry based
projects with integrated labs there will
be dedicated mentoring sessions from
industry experts 44 hours of
instructor-led training with
certification
here on the right you can see the skills
that will be covered
so we learn about time series modeling
linear and logistic regression you will
also learn about support vector machines
games clustering knife base decision
trees
random
forest and you learn the concepts of
bagging and boosting and deep learning
fundamentals as well
here you can see the
course content
and if i scroll further now these are
the projects that you'll get to work on
and finally you'll receive this
certificate once you complete the course
so that brings us to the end of this
video on machine learning full course i
hope it was useful and interesting if
you enjoyed the video then please
subscribe to the simply learn channel
thank you for watching and keep learning
you